CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AND IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE THREE. AN ACCESS CODE IS
SEVEN ZERO FIVE. SIX NINE ZERO
NINE. THAT. SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX
NINE ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. OR
ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT
AN OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME IN WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU'RE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS TO
COMMITTEE. PLEASE KNOW THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FOOD FEEDBACK. YOU MUCH MUTE
THE DEVICE THAT YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE THE
HEARING OUT OF HEARING ALL
BILLS ONCE ON OUR SCHEDULE.
AFTER THE INITIAL WITNESSES-
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
LIMITING PUBLIC COMMENT TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES PER SIDE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE AND HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHY EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND
IT'S CLOSE. TO THE MATTER AS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
ALL WE HAVE SEVENTEEN BILLS ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY SO WE'LL FULL
GENDERS SEVEN OF WHICH ARE ON
CONSENT AB TWO FIVE FOUR AB.
FIVE FIVE SEVEN EIGHTY SIX TWO
FOUR AB. SEVEN FIVE ZERO AB
EIGHT NINE FOUR AB NINE NINE
EIGHT IN AB TWELVE FORTY SEVEN-
AT SOME POINT WILL STOP THE
QUORUM AND THEN WILL ASK FOR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
RIGHT NOW ON. WE HAVE OUR FIRST
AUTHOR HERE WE HOURS ASSEMBLY
PERCHING GONZALEZ AND SHE'S
PRESENTING A V. FOUR EIGHT
EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISPRICED CHAIR AB
FORTY EIGHT WILL SET CLEAR
MINIMUM STANDARDS ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S USE OF LESS
LETHAL WEAPONS LIKE RUBBER
BULLETS AND TEAR GAS ON
PROTESTERS LAST SUMMER OVER A
HUNDRED PROTESTERS BYSTANDERS
AND JOURNALISTS TO STAIN
SERIOUS INJURIES FROM RUBBER
BULLETS AND BE BEING BAD ROUNDS
AT THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCLUDING SEVEN PEOPLE WHO LOST
IN NINE. IT IS CLEAR THAT WE
NEED STRICT STANDARDS FOR THE
USE OF LESS THAN LETHAL FORCE
LET LETHAL WEAPONS FOR CROWD
CONTROL. NO ONE WHO IS SIMPLY
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHT TO
PROTEST SHOULD BE SCARED TO
FACE SERIOUS INJURY OR DEATH.
BECAUSE OFFERS OFFICERS ARE
INDISCRIMINATELY FIRING RUBBER
BULLETS INTO ACCOUNT ARE USING
BECAUSE- APPLE CHEMICAL AGENTS.
AB FORTY CREATES CLEAR
STANDARDS THAT ONLY ALLOW
TRAINED OFFICERS TO USE THOSE
TOOLS IF THERE'S A THREAT OF
SERIOUS INJURY TO INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING OFFICERS. OFFICERS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH DE ESCALATION TECHNIQUES.
ONE THE CROWD AND GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO LEAVE
THE SCENE. THE ONLY COULD USE
THESE WEAPONS IN A MANNER
PROPORTIONAL TO THE THREAT NOT
INDISCRIMINATELY AGAINST A
CROWD OR TARGETED AT THE HEAD
OR NECK. THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
REPORT TO USE PROJECTILES AND
CHEMICAL AGENTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THE
RESULT IN INJURIES AND PUBLISH
ANNUAL SUMMARIES OF THEIR USE
WHICH WILL FURTHER PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY. AB FORTY ONE
SURE THE PROJECTILES AND
CHEMICAL AGENTS ARE USED ONLY
WHEN APPROPRIATE AND THAT THERE
ARE SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC WHEN
EXERCISING FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH PORAC AND POLICE CHIEFS ON
THIS- THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
AND CONTINUE TO DO SO TO ENSURE
THAT IT IS- WORKABLE- TODAY I
HAVE ON THE PHONE FOR SHEA
CONNOR CALLING IN WHO- WILL.
SHARE HIS EXPERIENCE AND SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THE
MODERATOR THE EVER. PRIMARY
LEAD WITNESS WILL PROVIDE THEM
THIRTY MINUTES OF TESTIMONY.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR ALL IN
ATTENDANCE. THANK YOU. THERE
I'M A TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD
BLACK MALE ONE ONE PURSUE A
CAREER IN LAW ENFORCEMENT OKAY
BEING A VICTIM. POLICE
BRUTALITY SHORT MY DURING. IN
LATE MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY I
WATCHED THE VIDEO GEORGE FOR
MURDER- ALL SHOPPERS STIRRED
OUTRAGE AND WHAT I SAW ABOUT MY
SAFETY MY RELATIVES AND FRIENDS
AND A LONG LIST OF BLACK MEN
AND WOMEN IN MORTGAGE WERE
MURDERED. TO POLICE MISCONDUCT-
BECAUSE THE BLACK LIVES
MOVEMENT BACK TO THE PRODUCT.
MAJOR FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TECH
PRO OF CAPITAL. THIS IS SPEECH
I TRAVELED THE AWAY FOR OFFICER
SIMPLY SHOUTING. JUSTICE IN
HOLDEN AMERICAN FLAG. I NEVER
BEHAVE IN A OR QUESTION MANNER.
DESPITE THIS OFFICES WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA AND BLACK SCREEN
IN MODERATE. CROWDER PROTESTERS.
YEAH I TRY TO RUN FOR SAFETY
OPTIONS OCTOBER LEGAL THAT. I
WAS SOMETHING WHICH ARE WAS THE
RIVER BE IT OKAY VERY CLOSE MY
RIGHT EYE ALL MY LOOK LEG. AND
BLOOD DRIPPING DOWN MY FACE.
ACCORDING TO THE IMMEDIATELY
SEE MEDICAL. ALEX TIME I WOULD
IN THEIR EYES HE WAS GOING
WRITE YOU. MY VISION IS
IMPAIRED. I MEAN REALLY. I HAVE
OF THE STOCKS MENTIONED IN
DEPRESSION. PRESIDENT TO THANK
MY LUCKY STARS NOTHING MORE
HAPPEN. OTHERS HAVE NO BEEN SO
LUCKY. RATING MORE STANDARDS ON
THE OF CONNECTICUT RIDGE
OUTGOING REMOVAL BEEN
BACKGROUND GAS REVENGE LIFELONG
THEM RATHER WHY COULDN'T TALK.
ARE YOU CAN HAVE A CONCLU
PROTEST. EXACTLY MUCH OKAY
EXACTLY ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND ARE
THERE ARE. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE. SHE
NINE WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM ARE THERE ANYONE DESIRING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AKB
FORTY EIGHT SENIOR NINE IN OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM MODERATE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES DO WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN Q. AND WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB FORTY
EIGHT. IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WELL FIRST GO TO
LINE TWENTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE NOT
A NOT LIKE A PUBLIC AFFAIR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
TWO. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
FIRST QUARTERFINAL THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ACCORDANCE. GO TO
LINE THIRTY EIGHT GO AHEAD.
THIS IS BREMBO CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION URGING
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ACCORDANCE. ONE TWENTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING SHARED MEMBERS MY
NAME IS A LITTLE UNDER HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S COULD FACE
INJUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BLIND. FIFTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING DONNA THANKS FOR
VISITING THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SUPPORTED
AB FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU. Q.
LINE. FIFTY TWO. ANYWAY LOOK AT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU FOR MONTHS Q. BY. TWENTY
FIVE. ASSEMBLY CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE FIFTY
SEVEN. JERRY THE MORE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA. HELLO
EXISTENCE IN SUPPORT. ONE FIFTY
FIVE. MEET YOU AT THE WORD
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER INTO
COURT THANK YOU. MY MODERATE
GAINS YES SOMEONE IN METER
DEVICE BECAUSE RETURN KEYBOARD
TYPING THE BACKGROUND. YES IF
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE ON THOSE
WITNESSES YOUR LINES ARE ARE
ACTIVE THROUGHOUT THE CALL SO
PLEASE KEEP BACKGROUND NOISE TO
A MINIMUM AND PLEASE USE YOUR
MEET FUTURE UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED
UPON TO SPEAK. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF AB
FORTY EIGHT AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO INNOCENT
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU NOW WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION- FORTRESS OF
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY FOR
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I SEE
THERE'S NO LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WE WILL NOW COME TO
THE HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO ALL
THREE OF YOUR ANYONE DESIRING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FORTY EIGHT. SEEN ONE HERE WELL
NOW MOVES TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
OF TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE MODERATOR CAN YOU Q.
CALLERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY EIGHT.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FORTY EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR KEYPAD AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE UP FIFTY
THREE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FORTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MCGEORGE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBER. WE'LL GO TO
LINE FIFTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. OUR
MEMBERS BRANDON UP ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR HERE
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANKS FOR BRINGING BACK TO
COMMAND DURING A QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AS RELIGIOUS MEASURE- AND-
SKINNER GONZALEZ RICHARD LEAD
TO CLOSING THE MEASURE. AT I'D
LOVE TO BE A SENATOR READ AND
STILL JUST ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
WITH THAT RIGHT YOU KNOW THIS
IS JUST A COMMON SENSE MEASURE
TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
STANDARDS ON LESS THAN LETHAL
USE OF FORCE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT ENSURE
IT'S WORKABLE BUT OUR OUR
WITNESS IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE
YOU SHOW UP AT A PROTEST YOU'RE
DOING NOTHING WRONG AND WITHOUT
WARNING GET STUCK IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU'RE
PERMANENTLY- INJURED. SELL OUT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS TO DEPLOYING THESE
WEAPONS ARE WELL TRAINED AND
THAT THERE IS WARNINGS GIVEN
AND THAT THEIR- USE PROPERLY
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH THIS BUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BUT WHEN THEY
PROCREATE TIME COMES THANK YOU-
ONCE WITH SUBSEQUENT WILL SEE
COMMOTION ON TO PASS A MOTION
TO APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU-
NEXT UP IS. AB. TWO FIVE FOUR.
YOU KNOW TWO MONTHS ARE AB
FORTY THREE BY. JONES SAWYER.
YEAH. GOOD MORNING CHAIRED BY
HERE TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB
FOUR EIGHT THREE EIGHT DISTRICT
BUILT THAT PROVIDES PEACE
OFFICER STATUS TO THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER
MUSEUM OFFICERS IN EXPOSITION
PARK THIS BILL ALSO ENSURES
MUSEUM OFFICERS ARE COMPARABLE
UNDER THE APPROPRIATE
CLASSIFICATION AND RECEIVE
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING UNDER
THE PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING POST MUSEUM OFFICERS
AT EXPOSITION PARK PROVIDE
SAFETY AND SECURITY TO MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ATTENDEES OF THE
SCIENCE CENTER. THE CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN MUSEUM AND
OTHER FACILITIES IN EXPOSITION
PARK THIS BILL RECOGNIZES THE
RESPONSIBILITY MUSEUM OFFICERS
HAVE BY SIMPLY CODIFY THE MO
YOU ENTERED INTO BY THE STATE
IN TWENTY NINETEEN- HAS NO
OPPOSITION NO NO VOTES AND
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. WITH ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS
SERGEANT KENNETH WILLIAMS THE
MUSEUM SECURITY OFFICER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCIENCE CENTER.
AND JENNIFER WROTE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION
SPONSORS BUT THE BILL. MEMBERS
ARE EXPECTED AFTER I BOUGHT.
BARGHOUTI TWO OF THE LEAD
WITNESSES ON MEN AND HOW TO
MAKE THEIR PRESENTATION SO WHEN
YOU'RE READY. IF IT'S SERGEANT
WILLIAMS RETURNED AGAIN YOU MAY
START YOUR CUSTOMER CARE AND
SENATORS AND MEMBERS I'M SORRY
CAN OF WILLIAMS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
EXHIBITION PARK HAVE BEEN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT FOR OVER TWENTY
ONE YEARS. OUR OFFICES. HAVE
BEEN DOING THE JOB WITH THE
RESPONSE WE APPEAL OF THE WHAT
OUT BEING. AS A OFFICER. THE OF
AB FOUR THREE WILL ALLOW OUR-
BE POST. WE SEE THIS TRAINING
THERE IS A AS COLD DIVERSITY.
RIGHT PROFILING. MENTAL ILLNESS
AND DISCUSS SOLUTIONS. DISTRICT
LIABILITY FOR TO AND THIS OF
CALIFORNIA. ADDITIONALLY WILL
HAVE THE- TO CONDUCT COMPLETE
BACKGROUND. PSYCHE BROWSE FOR
NEW HIRES WE WERE INSURED ARE
HIGHER OR QUALIFY OFFICERS.
THERE IS A REQUIREMENT TO
REPORT TO REPORT DATA TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THE
PASSING OF THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE REPAIR REPORTING AND
HELP STRENGTHEN TRUST WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY WE SERVE. OUR
DEPARTMENT IS VERSATILE. VERY
VERSATILE SORRY THE OFFICERS
HAVE BUILT TRUST WITH WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY. BECAUSE OF THIS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
FORTHCOMING WITH NEEDED
INFORMATION. WE HAVE POWERS OF
ARREST AND ARE TRAINED TO CARRY
THE USE OF FIREARMS HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF THE GREATER WE WORK
UNDER ARBITER VEHICLES ARE NOT
CLASSIFIED AS EMERGENCY
VEHICLES THIS PREVENTS US FROM
RESPONDING PROPERLY TO OVERSEE
CONSULTANTS. THE GRAY AREA OUR
BARGAINING UNIT UNIT SEVEN AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
AGREED. TO CLASSIFICATION
CHANGE TO THE EXCLUSION PART
DEPARTMENT OF SAFETY. AT THE
STATE CALIFORNIA RE OPENS LARGE
EVENTS HAVE STARTED COMING BACK
TO THE PARK SUCH AS VANCE. AND
AS SCHOOL FIELD TRIPS USC
FOOTBALL GAMES MLS SOCCER HAD
MUSIC FESTIVALS MAJOR CONCERTS
WORLD CUP AND THE UPCOMING TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY EIGHT OLYMPIC
GAMES IN CONCLUSION BECAUSE OF
THE CLASSIFICATION CHANGE OUR
DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BETTER SERVE AND
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITY. WE WILL
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
SAFETY OF OUR ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
ON PROPERTY AS WELL AS OUR
PRESCHOOL THE CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE CENTER. DEPUTY AMERICAN
MUSEUM THE NATURAL HISTORY
MUSEUM THE EXPO CENTER AND THE
UPCOMING MUSEUM TO GEORGE LUCAS
MUSEUM. AS WELL AS THE SAFETY
EMPLOYEES IT WAS A PARK IN THE
VISITORS THAT VISIT OUR PARK ON
A DAILY BASIS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND I HOPE YOU
SUPPORT AB FORTY THREE. THANK
YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO MISS WORLD.
GOOD MORNING MR KERRY MEMBERS
JENNIFER WROTE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE MY MOM PERSON
THAT YOU SHOULDN'T THINK
PARKING AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
THREE WHICH IS A FAMILY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER STATED CODIFIES
THE AGREEMENT MADE BETWEEN THE
AFFILIATE AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THEIR TWENTY
NINETEEN M. A YEAR TO CLOCK BY
THE MUSEUM SECURITY OFFICERS AT
THAT CALIFORNIA'S SCIENCE
CENTER AT. THE END WOULD AGREE
TO CONVERT THE THIRTY THREE
CONVENTION CURRENTLY STATIONED
DOWN THERE EXPOSITION PARK TO
FULLY MARK HUGHES DR CONDITION.
OFFICERS WILL HAVE TO UNDERGO
BASIC TRAINING AS MENTIONED AS
PART OF THE TAX RATE CHANGE
CHANGE OF A LONG TIME COMING
FURTHER SHOOT PROFESSIONAL I'VE
BEEN TRAINED AT THE UNIT THE
AND THEN HE WOULD GO TO THAT
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN ABBOTT. BILL
WITH AB ONE EIGHT. COULD NOT.
TO MAKE THAT THAT'D TEAM AND
THEN BECAUSE OF THE- IN AND-
YOU FOR THE REASON. PLEASE
DON'T BOB THERE AB THREE AND
HER YOUR I. THANK YOU KNOW A
BRING IT BACK TO THE- ROOM AS
YOUR- TO SPEAK SUPPORT. OF AB
EIGHT THREE YEAR AND FOUR TOOL.
SAYING NO ONE WILL GO TOWARD
FROM ROOM TWENTY FIVE. THERE'S
NO THERE AS WELL. MODERATOR CAN
YOU OPEN UP PHONE LINES AND FOR
THE WITNESSES WHO ARE WISHING
TO USE SUPPORT. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF AB- FOUR EIGHT
THREE. TO SPEAK INSUPPORT OF
AB FORTY THREE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP. OKAY
NOW WILL MOVE AND TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO FORMAL OPPOSITION
LISTED HERE IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
DESIRING TO SPEAK AND
OPPOSITION OF FOUR EIGHT THREE.
SHE NO ONE WILL GO TO TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS
WELL MODERATOR NOW WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AND IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN Q. DESIRING TO SPEAK
AND OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY
THREE NOW IS THE TIME. AND
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE AT THIS TIME. MR WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND AT THIS POINT ARE
THERE ANYQUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
AS RELATES TO THOSE BY ARC
COMMITTEE MEMBER. NO ALL RIGHT
WELL THIS SHERMAN JOHN
TREATMENT THANK YOU FOR THIS
MEASURE IT STATED IT'S A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE TO SOME OF THE
BILL I AUTHORED- AB. ONE TWO
EIGHT FIVE. EIGHT YEARS AGO ON
BEHALF OF THE LAX POLICE
pPOLICE STATUS EIGHT THIRTY
POINT ONE MANY PEOPLE ARE
UNAWARE UNTIL THAT POINT THAT
DESPITE IN THE UNIFORM AND
PROTECTING THE THIRD BUSIEST
AIRPORT IN THE NATION THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS DID NOT HAVE
FULL AUTHORITY TO SEIZE A
WEAPON ARE FOUND AT THE AIRPORT
OR IN A VEHICLE AND NOW THEY
CAN'T DO THAT IT'S WAS AN LAPD
IN THE SUMMER- THE FORTY SHOULD
BE GRANTED TO- THESE MEN AND
WOMEN I JUST SORT OF QUESTION
AT ONE POINT. DID NAY HELPFUL
STATUS AT SOME POINT- ON THE
PART TWENTY YEARS AGO DOES
NEVER THE CASE I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T KNOW IF. BUT ONE OF THE-
M. C. S. ELLIE A IT COULD. HAVE
HOPE THAT THEY KNOW. THE DAILY
THE LEAVE WITH HIS SISTER ON.
YES OUR MESSAGE STARTING OF
WHIMS AND NO WE NOT HAVE A FULL
SET. WE'RE UNDER THE ARTICLE
TRICKLED ONE OR AS A MUSEUM
POLICE BUT IT WASN'T IN THE
PENAL. R. OKAY I. IT WAS A ONE
POINT LARGE WITH TRY
TRANSPARENT ALL NOT TO
SOMETHING THAT IN OF YEARS AGO
OKAY GREAT. WHILE ALL. I WILL
ALLOW YOU TO MAKE YOUR CALLS
SHE TRANSFERRED IT JUST SIMPLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE. WE ARE
AGAIN WE'RE LOCKING IN A QUORUM
BUT AFTER PER PER TIME WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM WILL SEEK A
MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ON AB FORTY
THREE. THANK YOUR PRESENTATION.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AB TWO
NINE TWO WE'RE GONNA FIRST LET
ALONE HELLO HOUSE KEEPING
RECORDS ASSUME STONE AND THEN
YOU CAN MAKE YOUR PRESENTATION.
NO LONGER YOU YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB TWO NINETY TWO
IS ABOUT ACCESS TO PROGRAMMING
IN CALIFORNIA'S PRISONS WE KNOW
THAT. THE MORE ACCESS TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED HAVE TO
PROGRAMMING IN THE MORNINGS AND
IF THEY HAVE TO DO THAT PROGRAM
IN THE MORE SUCCESSFUL THEY ARE
INSIDE BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
WHEN THEY GET OUT OF TO GET
EDUCATED FOLKS TO TAKE THE
STEPS THAT THEY NEED INSIDE.
ARE FAR FAR LESS LIKELY TO
RECEIVE A THIS IS A RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION MEASURE. THERE'S TWO
ASPECTS THIS AND ONE IS WOULD
BUILDING EQUITY. AROUND SOME OF
THE CREDIT EARNING AND THE
OTHER PART OF IT. HIS ENSURING.
THAT PEOPLE ARE INSIDE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO COMPLETE THE COURSES
THAT THEY START. THAT THEY'RE
NOT BEING. UNNECESSARILY
TRANSFERRED FROM ONE FACILITY
TO ANOTHER AND BREAKING THEIR
ABILITY TO CAN TO FINISH THE
PROGRAM BEING THAT THEY STARTED
THE COURSES THAT THEY STARTED.
AS WELL AS PROVIDE SOME OF THAT
CONTINUITY BETWEEN. DIFFERENT
FACILITIES AND SO THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT CONTINUITY AND
IT'S ABOUT THE- EQUITY IN.
EARNINGS BUT ALSO IN MANAGING.
ONE'S OWN ABILITY TO DO THE
PROGRAMMING THAT ARE NECESSARY
WE ARE TALKING WITH CITY SEE
OUR AND OUR STAKEHOLDERS RIGHT
NOW. ABOUT SOME OF THE IMPACTS
THE SEARS REYES SOME SOME
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS AND WE'RE
VERY HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM. I
THINK WE ARE MOSTLY ON THE SAME
PAGE WITH THE AFFECTS OF THIS
BILL SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AND I WILL ASSURE YOU I'M
HOPING THAT THIS BILL DOES GET
OUT TODAY. BUT OBVIOUSLY WE
WILL STAY IN CONTACT WITH THE
COMMITTEE IF THERE ARE CHANGES
THAT COME UP OVER THE NEXT
MONTH SINCE WE HAVE QUITE A BIT
TIME BETWEEN HERE. AND END OF
SESSION WE WILL ABSOLUTELY LET.
THE COMMITTEE KNOW WHAT WE'RE
THINKING OR WORKING ON AND GET
YOUR APPROVAL ABOUT THAT ALONG
THE WAY. SO WITH ME I HAVE
KENNETH HARTMAN. WITH THE
TRANSFORMATIVE IN PERSON WORK
WORKGROUP IMPRISONED WORKGROUP.
AND MICHAEL RUSSELL WITH THE
ELLA BAKER CENTER. FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
AND WITH THAT. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWO NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU WILL GIVE BOTH YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES BUT A MINUTE
HAVE THREE MINUTES TOTAL SO IF
IT'S A STARK AND WHO'S PREPARED
TO GO FIRST- FOR GEORGE. GOOD
MORNING BOB I'M ME ADVOCACY
DIRECTOR FOR THE TRANSFER OF IN
PRISON WORK GROUP. WORK
COALITION OF SIXTY SIX
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT RUN THE KINDS OF
RESTORATIVE TRANSFORMATIVE
TRAUMA INFORMED HEALING
PROGRAMS ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
NINETY TWO WOULD ELEVATE. WE
ARE HONORED TO BE CO SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL ARE DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONES INSIDE COURAGE. I'M ALSO
CALLING CARD READER PERSON SIR
THIRTY EIGHT CONSECUTIVE YEARS
INSIDE THE CALIFORNIA PRISON
SYSTEM. THE PROGRAMS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY SAVED MY
LIFE AND HELP ME REJOIN SOCIETY
AS A PRODUCTIVEEMPATHETIC AND
STATE INDIVIDUAL. AB TWO NINETY
TWO DOES A NUMBER OF VITAL
THINGS. IT REQUIRES A CDC ARE
TO TREAT REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AS CO EQUAL IMPORTANCE
WITH OTHER FUNCTIONS INSIDE OF
THE PRISONS. IT ALLOWS FOR
THOSE SENTENCED TO LONGER TERMS
TO HAVE INCREASED ACCESS TO
PROGRAMMING OPTIONS BECAUSE
IT'S IN EVERYONE'S BEST
INTERESTS SURVIVORS
INCARCERATED PEOPLE STAFF
WORKING INSIDE AND THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. THAT EVERYONE HAS
ACCESS TO THE TOOLS TO BECOME
BETTER THAN THEIR WORST MOMENTS.
AND IT REMOVES UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING THESE
PROGRAMS AND ALLOWS FOR ALL
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO BE ON
THEIR WAY TO BE ABLE TO EARN
THEIR WAYTO ADDITIONAL TIME
OFF THEIR SENTENCES. NOTHING IS
BEING GIVEN AWAY BY THIS BILL.
WHILE I WAS INSIDE PRISON
SERVING TIME I PARTICIPATED IN
MULTIPLE RESTORED EVEN GIVING
PROGRAMS I WAS ALSO PRIVILEGED
TO BE ABLE TO FACILITATE
PROGRAMS. I KNOW THAT THERE IS
A DESPERATE DESIRE TO BE IN
REAL REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
AMONG THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE INSIDE A PRISON. THERE
ARE LITERALLY YEARS LONG
WAITING LISTS FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. THE BORDER PATROL
HEARINGS UNDERSTAND THEIR VALUE
AND WE ARE PARTICULARLY
GRATIFIED THAT THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTS EACH YEAR NINETY TWO.
EIGHT YOU UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE PROGRAMS.
AB TWO NINETY TO FILL THE VOID
THAT HAS EXISTED FOR TOO LONG
ANY DISTILL WHAT'S IN
EVERYONE'S BEST INTEREST TO
PASS THIS BILL AND EXPAND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GROWTH AND
HEALING. I URGE YOU TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF. THIS BILL TODAY THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU MR HARBIN WE GO TO THE- SO
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BRADFORD BY THE BRADFORD HERE
PATROL BOAT. TROUBLED HERE
COMMAGER YEAH KAMLAGER HERE
SKINNER WIENER WE HAVE A QUORUM
THE QUORUM IS PRESENT- NOW WILL
MOVE TO. MISTRUSTFUL. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERING THIS BILL IN
NINETEEN TWELVE WHAT IS NOW
KNOWN AS THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT CORRECTIONS CALL THE
CALIFORNIA TENS OF BUREAU IN
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE IT WAS
RENAMED THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IN A
TWO THOUSAND FOUR. THE PARADIGM
SHIFT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS WAS
RENAMED THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. WHY IS THIS
IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
SHOW'S OF GROWTH AB TWO NINETY
TWO THE ACCESS THE PROGRAM AN
ACTIVE AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
THAT GROWTH. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
RUSSELL AND I'M THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COORDINATOR FOR
THE OTHER BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS. IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE I WAS SENTENCED TO
LIFE WITHOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
PAROLE AT THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR. THE
HOBBIT THE STATE PRISON IN
MONTHS WILL BE ACROSS THE RACE
AND WIN THE WAR REHABILITATION
WAS ADDED TO CDC. UNDERSTOOD
THAT THE WAR REHABILITATION
MEANT THE PROCESS OF RESTORING
SOMEONE'S WAY USEFUL THANK OF
STRUCK THE PLACE OF SOCIETY. SO
FOR ME THIS MEANT THAT IF I
COULD GAIN ACCESS TO.
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING I
CAN MAKE A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
IN MY LIFE AND THEREFORE EARN
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REGAIN MY
FREEDOM HOWEVER I HAD NO ACCESS
TO REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS FOR
THE TWELVE YEAR. I WOULD HOW
THE KIND OF THE FAVORITE. ON
AVERAGE THE INSTITUTION WITH A
LOT ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS OUT OF
THE YEAR CONTRIBUTING
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE LACK OF
MEANINGFUL PROGRAMMING
OPPORTUNITIES. AS SUCH AN
ENVIRONMENT EIGHTY TO NINETY
TWO REQUIRE THE INSTITUTION TO
PROVIDE AN ALTERNATIVE TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION SO THAT
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO PARTICIPATE
IN REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM. WHAT
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
AB TWO NINETY TWO IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT OFFERS A PLACE TO GIVE ME
THAT PLACES AN EMPHASIS ON
REHABILITATION. BY REQUIRING
THAT PROGRAMMING OPPORTUNITIES
CONTINUES DOING. CONTINUES DOOR
LOCKED OUT AT THE NOT THE NOT
THE ONE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE THE VITAL WORK OF
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT. HAVING
ACCESS TO PROGRAMMING. NOT ONLY
MAKE THE ENVIRONMENT SAFER ON
THE INSIDE OF INSTITUTIONS BUT
IT WILL ALSO MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
SAFER HOW. AB TWO NINETY TWO OF
THE BILL THAT WOULD GRANT
PROGRAM AND OPPORTUNITIES OF
THE RIGHTS OF THOSE SEEKING TO
IMPROVE THEIR LIVES FOR THE
BETTER. THAT'S IN TURN HELPING
THAT PERSON TO ONCE AGAIN BE
WHOLE AND NOT TO RETURN TO OUR
COMMUNITY BROKE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION AND
ON THIS MATTER. THANK YOU
MISTER FOR YOU JUST NOW LET ME
BACK TO HEARING OR FORTY TWO-
THREE OR THERE IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WOULD WISHING TO TESTIFY
SUPPORT. OF AB TWO NINE TWO
SCENE ONE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM IN TWENTY FORTY
KNOWN THERE AS WELL MODERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES IS
ARE THERE WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
NINE TWO NOW'S THE TIME.
WITHOUT BY AND SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE I'M GETTING TO COURT
ON BEHALF YOU ORGANIZATION.
NATIONAL PREVENTION COALITION
TO IMPROVE LIVES TO
COOPERATING. THANK ARGUED
PROGRAM THREE EVOLUTION
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FIND AND
REBOUND THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU.
NECKLINE. TWENTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF THE
CENTER FOR ITS EMPLOYMENT.
OPPORTUNITY AND SUPPORT THIS
MORNING THANK YOU THANK. THANK
BY TWENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THE CORTES BLINDS FIND
SEVENTY FIVE. NUMBER ONE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
NINE TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE. SEVENTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING GOING BACK INTO THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS FUND COMES BONTA
ORGANIZATIONS I WAS ASKED TO.
INFORMATION CAN ACTUALLY BE
SUBORDINATION JIM SUPPORT. DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE WHICH ASIAN
PRISONER SUPPORT COMMITTEE.
ALMOST FREEDOM PROJECT
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. DEFY VENTURES. WITHIN
PROJECT DEALS PROJECT YOU KNOW
COLUSA FOR COMMUNITY LEADERSHIP.
LOS ANGELES REGIONAL REENTRY
PARTNERSHIP- IN SHAKESPEARE
COMPANY AND SILICON VALLEY DE
BUG THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THIS. ONE SIXTY EIGHT. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TEMPLES OTHER
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ACTUALLY NINE FIFTIES. OUR
REALIGNED FIFTY SEVEN. SURE
TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CHINESE THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR. ONE FIFTY FIVE. WHICH IS
THE WOOD NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY SEVEN. HI
GOOD MORNING GENTLEMEN- THIS IS
GREGORY FIDEL WITHIN ISSUE
JUSTICE R. COSPONSORED IN
STRONG SUPPORT ALSO READING
SUPPORT ON THE ACTED HELLO
COSPONSORED RESTORE JUSTICE IN
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
SANDWICHES GO PUBLIC DEFENDER
SANTA CRUZ OF BIOSIMILARS
SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL JUSTICE
BAY AREA PETER WORKS PROJECT
WHITE PEOPLE FOR BLACK LIVES A.
I. D. A. PRISON GROUP. GETTING
RAY GINGER POWER ACROSS
ALLIANCE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE. SEVENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
CATHY SHORT FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION WITH CORN. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO LINES INTO THANK YOU
NOW WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION
IMPORTANT SAME OPPORTUNITY I
SEE THERE'S NO LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION LISTED- SO WE'LL
COME BACK TO COMMITTEE ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE- HERE. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
NINE TWO YEAR AND FORTY TOOL
THREE SEEN NINE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM OF TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS WELL
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO PHONE
LINES INTO THERE'S- WINDOWS
JUST WISHING TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO NINE TWO.
SPEAKING OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN CHEWING UP
I'M RIGHT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMANDER THERE ANY
QUESTION OF ONE LINE THAT OKAY
WE WANTED IT AND ONE NINE THAT
IS QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM THEIR LINE
NUMBER. RIGHT. BORDERLINE SIXTY
THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE. MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY JASON LEE SO COUNTY
DECEMBER AND YOU KNOW IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NOT FOR THE LINES. PART WE'RE
BRINGING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS IT
RELATES TO THIS MEASURE SURE
CALM WATER NO I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS BUT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME OF THE BILL
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION OF CENTER
CHOI BOOK ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. RIGHT
SHOULD ASSUME STONE APPRECIATE
THIS MEASURE TO COMMONSENSE AS
ONE OF YOUR WITNESSES SAYS AT
SOME POINT. DARDEN
REHABILITATION NEED TO MEAN
SOMETHING AND NOT- BY PROVIDING
THESE. CLASSES AN OPPORTUNITY
REALLY ALLOW SOMEONE TO- TO
PROVE THEIR LIFE AND- REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AND- GIVE THEM
OPPORTUNITY TO BE CONTRIBUTING
MEMBERS JUST AS WELL FOR YOUR
WITNESSES CLEARLY HAVE
DEMONSTRATED TELL. AT THIS
POINT I'LL LOVE YOU TO MAKE
YOUR CALLS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SENATORS I JUST ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. MURATSUCHI
CAN WE HAVE A MOTION IT TO DO
PASS BUT OUR FIRST RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS. COUNCIL YOU
CALL THE ROLL ON A. B. TWO NINE
TWO. AB TWO NINETY BRADFORD AYE
BRADFORD AYE A CHAU BOKE.
SHOWBOAT NO COM AUGER I AM
UNDER AYE SKINNER WIENER. THE
MEASURE AS TO VOTED TO
APPROPRIATE TIME WILL LIBERAL
OPEN AT FOR BATON WILL. THANK
YOU OPEN THE ROLE IN THAT NOW
WE'RE MOVE TO YOUR SECOND
MEASURE A. B. SEVEN ONE SEVEN
THANK YOU THIS CHAIR AND
SENATORS SO AB SEVEN ONE SEVEN
IS A CONTINUATION OF WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING TO ENSURE.
THAT EVERYONE COMING OUT OF
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS HAS AN
ACTUAL ID WE RAN A BILL A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO. AND IT WAS
FRONT IN A MINUTE ON A TEST
BASIS THAN WE WERE TRYING TO
GET TO. 150% OF PEOPLE COMING
OUT WORRIED ABOUT 30% SO WHAT
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO USE
EXPAND. ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA
ID'S. FOR IN SOME CASES
DRIVER'S LICENSE OF SOMEONE IS
ELIGIBLE FOR RENEWAL. FOR A
REPLACEMENT DRIVERS LICENSES
THAT'S IT AN APPROPRIATE FORM
OF. OF IDEAS WELL IN THE END WE
ARE WORKING WITH CDC ARE ON
THIS BILL WE'RE ALSO WORKING
WITH SENATOR ROB. BEEZY AGREES
WITH US ON. THE NEED FOR ID'S
ID'S ARE CRITICAL FOR PEOPLE
COMING OUT TO BE ABLE TO RE
INTEGRATE. TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED. NO
ONE WANTS TO SHOW PRISON NINETY
AND THOSE ARE NOT ALWAYS
ACCEPTED OR EVEN UNDERSTOOD TO
AN APPROPRIATE CALIFORNIA ID.
IS REALLY CRITICAL SO WE WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
BILLS ARE IN HARMONY AS WELL
THE CDCR AND OTHERS TO JUST.
TAKING THE STEPS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE BROADER ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE ID'S. AND GETTING
PEOPLE INTEGRATED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES REDUCING RECIDIVISM
AND I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. SO
I DO HAVE. WITNESSES BUT SURE
AWARD FROM A NEW WAY OF LIFE
AND EDWIN PROGRESS FROM ROOT
AND REBOUND OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. WE'LL START WITH YOUR
FIRST WITNESS WILL PROVIDE THEM
A MINUTE HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THREE MINUTES SO. MS WARD IF
YOU'RE PREPARED YOU CAN BEGIN
YOUR TESTIMONY. MODERATOR TO WE
HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES.
ONLINE. ONE MOMENT. MY
APOLOGIES THE NAMES WERE
LOOKING FOR AGAIN. LOOKING FOR
SURE AWARD AND EDWIN PARK
OFFICE. BUSINESS YEAR AWARD YOU
READY FOR ME TO SPEAK YES. YES
WE ARE BUT- OKAY THANK YOU
HELLO THERE MY NAME IS CHERYL
WARD IN AN ATTIC THE SPEAK TO
YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVENTEEN AS THE HOUSING
BENEFITS COORDINATOR AND IN THE
WAY OF LIFE REENTRY PROJECT I
IT DID WOMEN RETURNING THE
COMMUNITY AFTER HAVING TERROR.
AND TWENTY THIRTY AND WE HAVE
ONE LADY NOW WOULD COME HOME
AFTER FORTY FOUR YEARS I HAVE
MEANT TO CURE THEIR NEEDED
DOCUMENTS BECAUSE MANY WOMEN
ARE COMING HOME WITH JUST THE
PRISON ID AND FOUND NO IDEA AT
ALL AND IN THE WORLD WE LIVE IN
TODAY WITHOUT PROPER ID YOU
DON'T GET FAR AND WHILE MAN THE
CARD IS ACCEPTED ALMOST
EVERYWHERE. PRISON AIDID'S ART
IN ORDER TO OBTAIN A BIRTH TO
GIVE THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY YOU
HAVE TO STAND IN THE NOTARIZED
APPLICATION NOTARY ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA ID AND LONG ACCEPTED
PRISON ID DON'T KNOW OUR
UNIVERSE IF IT AND THE IN THE
ONLINE ACCOUNT CANNOT BE
CREATED AS IT DOESN'T ACCEPT
PRISON ID THIS VERIFICATION OF
IDENTITY. BUT WE ARE FORCED TO
PHYSICALLY GO INTO THE INDIAN
ARTICHOKE BY FOR CALIFORNIA HI
DEAR LIKE THEY TELL US YOU MUST
HAVE A BIRTH. WE TELL THEM WE
ALREADY TRIED THE ARTEON BURKE
IF YOU THINK AND NOT DEAL TODAY
IN THE MORNING THE BRIDGE ID
PURPOSE THAT I. TO ORDER
REPLACEMENT THE FUTURE CARD
ONLINE IN THE READ AN ACCOUNT
YOU CAN'T HOWEVER BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T VERIFY YOU ARE WHO YOU
ARE WITH THE PRISON NINETY YOU
MUST NOW THE APPLICATION WITHIN
A REGION OF CALIFORNIA ID WHICH
YOU DON'T HAVE BECAUSE ONLY A
PRISON THAT YOU ONLY HAVE
PRISON ID AND THEY GONNA
WRITTEN IDEA AT THE END DATE.
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE VITAL TO A
PERSON'S ABILITY TO OBTAIN FROM
THE SENATE AND HOUSING DRUG
TREATMENT AND EMPLOYMENT YES
THE NAME WHICH DO THERE ARE
MANY IN OUR COMMUNITY WE CAN'T
VERY BECAUSE OF OUR CAPACITY
CONSTRAINTS WE ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHT OUR COMMUNITY. BY MAKING
THE NECESSARY DOCUMENTS THE
THIRD IS. AVAILABLE MAKING
TRêN. EASIER FOR THE AND
COMMUNITY. OF FORMALLY
INCORRECT FOR. AND I THINK FOR
YOUR AND CONSIDERATION WE GO.
SEVEN SEVENTEEN. THANK YOU NOW
WILL NOT WITNESS OF MEN AND HOW
FOR TEST. HI- MY NAME IS THEN
TRY AND I. A. B. ONCE SAID.
HOUSING COSTS A ONE HOUR
SIXTEEN CONCERT TWENTY THREE
YEARS AND WE NEED ON THE TO
NINETEEN. FROM THE A RATING
THAT WILL BE PROBLEMS GETTING
MY YOU ON. NOT HAVING
IDEALISTIC FROM THE ONE WENT TO
THE PRO BOARD THE- ME HOW.
FEDERAL MY POPE PAUL PLAN WAS.
WELL WITHOUT A IDEA I COULDN'T
MIGHT PLAY TO MOST. ALTHOUGH
ENTRY WE SAW ARE FOR NOT CUT
OFF BECAUSE NINETY. ALSO COURTS
SCHOOL. WERE PUT ON HOLD
BECAUSE I NO IDEA KNOW THE.
BASHED AND TUNNEL TOLL BUT
EXTERNAL TOLD BUT THEN TRY TOLD
I BELIEVE WAS MORE INTENSE. NOT
HAVING I HAD ME FEELINGS
SOMETHING THAT I'M FAMILIAR.
WITH THE FEELING THAT WHEN I
THE BEST VERSION OF MYSELF. YOU
HAD ME FEELING AGAIN IN FEAR
I'M HAPPY FEELING LIKE I HAD TO
LIVING IN THE SHADOWS AGAIN. I
FELT LIKE A SECOND CLASS
CITIZEN WATERSIDE ALL THE CRAZE
TO BE NORMAL AGAIN AND TO BE
ACCEPTED AS A CONTRIBUTOR.TO
OUR SOCIETY I HATED THAT OLD
FEELING I KNOW HOW. LONELY MY
WORK AND I KNOW I CAN. AFTER
EIGHT MONTH I WAS ABLE TO
ACHIEVE ID FROM THERE. I CAN I
TOOK OFF. WORK DREAMLAND PROP I
GO SCHOOL ON WEEKEND TO GET MY
CERTIFIED. TO BE CERTIFIED DRUG
ALCOHOL COUNSELOR AND A NIGHT
I'D SEND CULTURAL DIVERSITY
COLLECTORS. I AM I'M ALSO A
BOARD MEMBER IN THE IN A WE
ANSWERED ORGANIZATION. I STILL
AS I RECEIVE MY EMAIL DOOR
OPENED I WAS CONFIDENT POPPING
UP IN A- BEING. TO KNOCK ON
DOORS THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. NOW WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB SEVEN
ONE SEVEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PUSH MORTGAGE
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COULD BE
PACKED PATRICK ESPINOSA ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WERE
CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE HERE TO
FIFTEEN NO ONE WILL VOTER OR
FOR ROOM TWENTY FORTIES THERE'S
NO ONE THERE. MODERATE WILL GO
TO PHONE LINES DOWN IF YOU
HAVE. WITNESSES IN Q. WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SEVEN
ONE SEVEN OUNCE TOP. TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN ONE
SEVEN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO FIRST TO
LINE TWENTY TWO GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN KAREN LAYING ON
TOP OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND THE CENTER
FOR YOUTH EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT THIS
MORNING THINKING. ONE TWENTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
FOUR. NO ONE WOULD BE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN ONE
SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
WOOD BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY
THREE. HIGHNESS ON BEHALF OF
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
UP CROWDS BECAUSE SPONSOR AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING CATHY SHARPER ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN COURT. Q.
BY. TWENTY ONE. GOOD MORNING IT
IS A LITTLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING SURE TO MARBLE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE. FIFTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS RYAN
CHAIRMAN OF THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. PINE FIFTY
FIVE. DIMITRIUS WE WOULD
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
SEVEN. GREGORY THE COMMISSION
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU BYE. EIGHTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
MICHELLE THOMAS JOB
REPRESENTING THAT ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY. GOOD
MORNING STEPHANIE JEFF CUT ON
BEHALF OF- A NEW WAY OF LIFE
ALSO A CO SPONSOR IN PRAGUE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
CALIFORNIANS STATE. OUR JOHN
ROWLAND OUR ROAD PRISON PROJECT.
I AM PROUD SUPPORT- AFTER I.
THANK YOU FOR. WE HAVE NO OTHER
LINES INTO MISTER CHAIR. Q. NOW
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION AFFORD
THEM THE SAME OPPORTUNITY I SEE
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WILL NOW COME TO THE
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
YEARS OR ANYONE HERE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVEN ONE SEVEN. YOU KNOW ONE
MOVING WILL GO TO TWENTY FORTY.
SHE WENT NO ONE THERE MODERATOR
NOW WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
AND SEE IF THERE'S WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WISHING TO TESTIFY
TELEPHONICALLY. THIS ONE. AND
IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MR HERE WE HAVE
NO ONE KID UP AT THIS TIME.
RIGHT WE BRING YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE HAZARD QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS AS RELATES TO THIS
ROGER. CENTER COMMONER THANK
YOU I HAVE NO QUESTIONS OTHER
THAN WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A CO AUTHOR AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL. THANK THE COOLEY
NOTED IT HAS BEEN MOVED- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEN NONE TO PASS A
MOONSTONE WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS OKAY COME TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON A. B. SEVEN
ONE SEVEN WE HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. TO ADD TO
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AB SEVEN ONE SEVEN
BRADFORD. ROAD FOR DIETRO VOGUE
I TROUBLE GUY COMMAGER.
KAMLAGER EYES SKINNER WIENER
WIENER I THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU THANK
YOU HAS ENOUGH TO. THANK YOU-
AT THIS POINT- COUNCIL CAN WE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE SEVEN ITEMS ON
DOOR NEED TO LIST OFF SOME I
CAN DO IT AGAIN OKAY PLEASE-
CONSENT CALENDAR AB TWO FIFTY
FOUR AB FIVE FIVE SEVEN AB SIX
TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
AB EIGHT NINE EIGHT AB NINE
NINE EIGHT. AB TWELVE FORTY
SEVEN. BRADFORD HI BRADFORD I'D
CHOI BOGUE TROUBLE GUY KAMAGRA
BUY KAMAGRA ICE SKINNER WINNER
WHEN ARE I. THAT MEASURE HAS
FOR THE CONCERT CALENDAR HAS
FOUR VOTES WILL LOSE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS I
SHOOT- WE DO NOT HAVE A SOME
REMEMBER BOBCAT. KAYHAN SO WE
HAVE A CINNAMON LACKEY SO HE'S
HERE TO PRESENT. AB. SIX SIX
NINE. THANK YOU CENTERED
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT- AB SIX
SIX NINE WHICH WAS AND AN
AMERICAN OVERSIGHT FROM A-
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW. COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TO CONTINUE. TO USE
NON ROSTER FIREARMS UPON THE
SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION OF THE
FIREARMS PORTION OF THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
AUTHORIZED COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT OFFICERS TO
PURCHASING UTILIZE NON ROSTER
FIREARMS. LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE ADDED A REQUIREMENT
FOR COMPLETION OF THE POST
BASIC COURSE. BEFORE ALLOWING
THE COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT
OFFICERS TO PURCHASE AND USE
NON ROSTER FIREARMS. THIS
INADVERTENT. BUT SHE'S BEEN A
BURNLEY- AFFECTED PROBATION
OFFICERS WHO ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO COMPLETE THE POST BASIC
COURSE AS A CONDITION OF HIGHER
CONTINUED EMPLOYMENT. BECAUSE
OF THIS LANGUAGE PROBATION
OFFICERS ARE PROHIBITED FROM
USING NON ROSTER FIREARMS ON
DUTY BECAUSE OF THE POST BASIC
COURSE REQUIREMENTS. IT WOULD
ALSO FORCE PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TO PURCHASE NEW
FIREARMS ANYTIME A DEPARTMENT.
ISSUED ROSTERED FIREARMS. I'M
SORRY ANY TIME A DEPARTMENT USE
ROSTER FIRE BALLS OFF THE LIST
BECOMES A NON ROSTER FIREARM.
BECAUSE THE CLARIFICATION THIS
BILL PROVIDES WILL ALLOW COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS TO
MAINTAIN THE USE OF FIREARMS
THAT HAVE BEEN PURCHASED.
RENDON USED BY THOSE
DEPARTMENTS FOR WHICH ITS
PROBATION OFFICERS HAVE FULLY
BEEN TRAINED. WITHOUT THIS BILL
THESE DEPARTMENTS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO PURCHASE NEW
WEAPONS FOR THE AFFECTED
OFFICERS. SB SIX SIX NINE WOULD
EXEMPT SALES TO A COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENT AN OFFICER
WHO HAS COMPLETED THE FIREARMS
PORTION OF A TRAINING COURSE
SET BY POST. A COMPLETE TO LIVE
FIRE QUALIFICATION PRESCRIBED
BY THEIR EMPLOYING ENTITY AT
LEAST ONCE EVERY THREE MONTHS.
WITH ME ON THE LINE IS ALL
ALBERTO UP TO RICO. GREG STUPOR
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
COALITIONS A PROBATION OFFICER
ORGANIZATIONS. BOOKER TO FIRST
WITNESS IN SUPPORT WILL GIVE
THEM A MINUTE MINUTE HALF. H.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN GOOD
MORNING THIS IS A BOROUGH
RECALL THE STREET CLOSURE
COMMISSION ORGANIZATIONS
SPONSORS OF THE LEGISLATION
GOES THROUGH LIKE HUGE
REPRESENTED TWENTY SIXTEEN
SOMEONE BETTER SOMEONE ON THE
BONTA CARRIED EVERY TWENTY FIVE
WHICH A LOT PROVISIONAL SYSTEM
POLLUTION APARTMENT TRUMPCARE
NOT MUCH OF CRIMES WHICH THEY
WERE NOT LOCKED TO DO BEFORE.
CONSEQUENTLY FROM 201-720-1820
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY UP UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S DEPARTMENT
FROM THE STATE ARGUES NUMBERS
FIREARMS PARTS OF SOME OF THOSE
FIREARMS TRAINED OFFICERS WHO
USES THOSE FARMS IN TWENTY
TWENTY. TO TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE BUT MISSED SANTIAGO
CARDIFF EXPANDED THE LIST OF
DEPARTMENT THAT CAN USE OUR
COUNTRY AS A KID YOU KNOW LOTS
OF FIREARMS AND ALSO INCLUDED
TRAINING REQUIREMENT WHICH I DO
NOT BELIEVE SUPPORTING THE
SPONSORS WERE NOT INTENDED TO
EXCLUDE PROVISIONAL SERVICE BUT
AS FOLKS ON THE DANISH
UNDERSTAND AND KNOW VERY WELL
PROBATION OFFICERS UNDERGO VERY
DIFFERENT TRAINING REQUIREMENTS.
THEN RECONCILE PEACE OFFICERS.
OPTION PART CALLED AND THE DE
SHERIFFS THANK YOU DO NOT GO TO
ENTIRE. IN TO GO TO TEST YOUR
STREET WHICH IS DIFFERENT
BECAUSE OF THE REHABILITATION.
DUTIES THAT OFFICERS. HAVE IN
OUR SENSE TO THE PROPER
ADMINISTRATION AND HOW YOU CAN.
OF REALIGN. AS A RESULT-
BECAUSE OF THAT THAT GENTRAN
REQUIRE. R. O. CAN NO LONGER.
DEPARTMENTS LONG THIRTY ONE
MUST FIREARM. IN ADDITION TO
THAT- JUST TO POINT OUT THAT
OBVIOUS YOU AS YOU FUTURE IS A
FROM. OFFICERS FOR GOOD
PURPOSES AND THE NOW AS AN
AMENDMENT TO CODIFY. A
QUARTERLY REQUIREMENTS UNDER
POST FOR THE USE OF NON
MUSCLEPHARM. RANKING TOP POLICE
OFFICERS ONLY UP TO GO TO THE
TRAINING TWICE FOR YOUR AS A
POST RACIAL SLURS WHICH WE GO
TO THE TRAINING. FOUR TIMES A
YEAR FINALLY I WOULD SAY THAT.
EIGHT THIRTY POINT ONE
CLASSIFICATION A WHICH GIVES
OFFICERS THE NON ACCESS TO THE
NON ROSTER FIREARMS HAS BEEN
EXPANDED. EVEN TODAY THE BILL
BEFORE YOU FOR MISTER JONES
SAWYER IS GOING TO DO JUST
THAT. AND IN THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL THERE WAS THERE WAS
PROVISION TO NURTURE EXPAND.
FOR STATE OFFICERS AND MORE NOT
MOST OF THE MORE ACTUAL NON
LUSTER FARM SO. WE BELIEVE A
FROM LOOK FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF TRAINING AND BE FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF CONSISTENCY IT
MAKES SENSE THAT. NOT MUCH FARM
SPEAK. WE REINSTATED PROBATION
OFFICERS. WITH ADULTS IT OVER
TO GREG THE PRESIDENT THE
SACRAMENT COUNTY SHE UNION AND
THE LESSER PRISCO PUT MUCH
TRUMP PROGRESS. MR COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE UP THIS MY
NAME IS GREG STEWART THE LEAD
TO VICE OF THE STATE OF ORDER.
AND THE PER SECOND FOR ME SO
HERE IN STRONG SO OF AB SIX
SIX. IT'S AN ALL MISTER TRICO
STATE THAT LIKE TO DRAW YOU
WANT THE MAIN THINGS. OF THE
OPPOSITE. THE OPPOSITE STATES
THAT HER FOR. ALL DOES NOT COME.
THE POST OF COURSE WE CANNOT BE
SAFE WITH GUNS I. RESPECTFULLY
THIS STATEMENT IS NOT CORRECT
IN THE CERTAINLY NOT BASED UPON
FACT- THE POLICE BASIC CORE
STANDARD FORMAT. THE POST BASIC
COURSES COMPRISES SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR HOURS OF TRAINING
BROKEN INTO FORTY THREE
LEARNING DOMAINS. ONLY A SINGLE
DOMAIN DOMAIN THIRTY FIVE
FIREARMS CHEMICAL AGENTS
COMPRISED OF ONLY SEVENTY TWO
HOURS PROVIDES FIREARMS
TRAINING. WITHIN THE SEVENTY
TWO HOURS A DOMAIN THIRTY FIVE
TRAINEES ARE NOT TO STOP THE
USE OF A HANDGUN BUT ALSO THE
USE OF A SHOCK WHICH
PROVISIONAL STREET DO NOT USE.
IT IS IMPORTANT NOTE AS WELL
THAT THE SEVENTY TWO HOURS
PROVIDED AND DOMAIN THIRTY FIVE
ALSO INCLUDES THE FIREARMS
PORTION OF EIGHT THIRTY TO
TRAINING. TO WHICH PROVISIONAL
MEASURES ALREADY MANDATED TO
COMPLETE. ALSO UNDER PCA THIRTY
POINT FIVE PROBATION OFFICERS
ARE REQUIRED TO QUALIFY. YOU
BUT THEIR FIREARM WHICH IS
TWICE THE AMOUNT OF OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. THE FACT
IS PROBATION OFFICERS RECEIVE
MORE FIREARMS TRAINING WITH A
HAND GUN. AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. ENFORCING
PROBATION OFFICERS TO COMPLETE
FIVE HUNDRED NINETY TWO HOURS
OF COMPLETELY UNRELATED. POST
BASIC COURSE TRAINING HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH FIREARM
SAFETY. FOR A FEW EXAMPLES
PROVISIONAL OFFICERS WOULD BE
FORCED TO COMPLETE TRAINING
DOMAIN EIGHTEEN VEHICLE
OPERATIONS. DOMAIN TWENTY
PATROL TECHNIQUES THE MAIN
TWENTY ONE VEHICLE PULLOVERS
DEMAND TWENTY FIVE CROWD
CONTROL. THE MAIN TWENTY SEVEN
TRAFFIC ENFORCEMENT AND DOMAIN
TWENTY EIGHT TRAFFIC COLLISION
INVESTIGATIONS JUST TO NAME A
FEW. PERMEATION RECEIVED
DIFFERENT TRAINING FOR A REASON
WE ARE DIFFERENT WE ARE FOCUSED
ON REHABILITATION TO COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION. AND I BELIEVE ALL
OF YOU WANTED TO REMAIN THAT
WAY. IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY OUR
PROBATION OFFICERS MUST
COMPLETE AN EIGHTY HOUR
FIREARMS COURSE WHICH INCLUDES
A FIREARMS PORTION OF THE
THIRTY TWO TRAINING. BEFORE
EVEN ENTERING OUR FTO PROGRAM.
ARMED OFFICERS MUST QUALIFY
QUARTERLY WITH A FIREARM AND
MUST COMPLETE ADVANCED OFFICER
TRAINING ANNUALLY. PERMEATION
OFFICERS ARE QUALIFIED AND
PROPERLY TRAINED AND HAVE BEEN
USING THESE FIREARMS THREE
YEARS WITHOUT ISSUE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR YES VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW WILL COME BACK TO THE
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
YEARS OR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
SIX NINE JEAN ON HERE WILL GO
TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM TWENTY
FOUR THE THERE'S NO ONE THERE
AS WELL MODERATOR CAN WE OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINE FOR THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF AB SIX SIX NINE. TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT PRESS. ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. WE'LL
GO FIRST TO LINE NINETY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. MISTER CAREY
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE SEEMS YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU NOW WILL COACH YOU
ARE WITNESSES AND OFFICERS
SHAUNA- SHERRY. WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
AS THE ONE LENT LINDLEY AND WE
HAVE GROUP INDEX A MODERATOR OR-
EITHER OR BOTH OF THOSE ARE
WITNESSES PREPARED TO TESTIFY
AT THIS POINT. AND THEY'LL HAVE
A MINUTE HAVE EACH. CHAU MR
LINDY'S LINE IS HIS ATTACHED.
GOOD MORNING AUDIBLE ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MANY MISSING
ONLY A TWENTY YEARS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT EXPERIENCE AND WAS
A CHEAPER CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
JUST AS A PHARMACY TWO THOUSAND
NINETY TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I
AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE. EIGHTY SIX SIX
BECAUSE- EXPERIENCE EXEMPTION.
UNSAFE HANG ON AREN'T THERE'S
NO REASON ONLY TO ALLOW
OFFICERS LESS CONFLICT RENDON'S
WELCOME OF THE POLICE. ALL CAN
CREAM A CAT COURSE BEGINS OPEN
ARE TO THE IS A CALL. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I NINETY NINE
PROBLEM DON'T GO IN FOR SAFETY
LAWS RIGHT INAKI THE UNSAFE
PANGA REQUIRES ALL YOU NEED A
MODEL NEED RELIABILITY AND
SAFETY. OVER TO CERTIFIED FOR
SALE OR MIND. OR PLEASE ON
MONSTER A TIME DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE EARLIER OVER EIGHT- GUN
ON AND WE WILL FOR SURE CAL.
THE STANDARDS OUTLINED IN UNDER
ACT REVELA TO SAVE LIVES AND
THEY HAVE DONE SO PROPERLY
ACTUALLY DISCHARGES ON OF
STUDENTS TRACKING AND AN
AFFRONT ARMS OF MICROSOFT
TECHNOLOGY BONTA SPONSORS HAVE
COMPLETED IN HER POST ON
ACCOUNT WE ALONG WITH EXEMPTION
WOULD YOU KNOW. AND THE ANSWER
ACT SB SIX MINE WILL COVER
ABOUT ANOTHER EXEMPTION FROM
THIS TAX ACCOUNT OFFICERS SB
SIX PROVISIONS CORRECTIONAL. ON
THE FARM PORTION OF THE
TRAINING COURSE IN ORDER TO BE
SENT OUT FOR THE TAX RATHER
THAN THE POST TRAINING. FIRST
ALONG PORTION. OFFICIALS IT'S A
GOOD TIME SOME CLEAN AT THE
ALTAR SUPPORTERS OF THIS GREAT
RISK IT UNDER A IMPORTANT
PROTECTION WHICH WOULD PUT IT
LAW LAST YEAR IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WORKING ON COMPLETELY
AND COURSE. 40% HANDLED WEAPON
AND IMPROVE THE NURSES. WITHOUT
THAT MANDATED EXPENDITURE AND
RETRAINING. ONLY ADULT YOU OWN
CLASSIC HANG ON WILL BE A ****
TO THEMSELVES AND TO OTHERS AB
TEXAS NINE WILL LIKELY ALSO
MORNING WEAPONS IN THE HAGUE OF
THOSE WHO SHOULD NOT HAPPEN TO
BE ON. SALES CALLED WANTS OCT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN GUILTY ON.
CRIME OFTEN HANG TO CIVILIANS
PROBABLY CALPERS OFFICERS NOT
SPEAK OF CAR OUT BECAUSE NEED
TO KEEP IT OFF CERTAIN FORMS OF
FINANCIAL REASONS OR ARE UNABLE
TO COMPLETE A FULL POST KERN
COUNTY BECAUSE BEFORE OR GUNS
BUT ARE NOT ONE THE HIGHER. ON
THE ROSTER MODELS TO BECAUSE A
FIREMAN TRICKY TO REFUSE TO
COMPLY WITH THE- OF
CALIFORNIANS UNDER ACT IN PART
DUE TO DISCONTINUE A CARBON JIM.
WHITE SB SIX SIX NINE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS SHOULD
SHOULD NOT ESTABLISH PRESIDENT
ALLOW PUBLIC OFFICERS ONLY
OTHER BOND FORTY PICTURES THE
STATE DO YOU UNSPECTACULAR
WITHOUT EXTENSIVE TRAINING OUR
RECORDS ARE. OKAY LINES MONEY I
WOULD CONTINUES TO ALLOW THE
FIREMAN ST LUCIANS TO NOT
COMPLY WITH CALLUM UNDER ATTACK
AND PLEASE REGION'S WE OPPOSE
AB SIX SIX NINE THANK. MODERATE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES INTO
AFTER A WITNESSES. IN QUEUE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY. TECH
ANTICIPATE AN OPPOSITION OF AB
SIX SIX NINE MISTER MARK- YEAH
BERMAN DECKS ONLINE IT WAS ALSO
A- SORRY YES WE HAD WE HAD
ANOTHER ON MY BACK WE ANOTHER
PRIMARILY. MR DECKS. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME. I'M
SORRY GO AHEAD. THAT CAN GREAT
INDEX COCHAIR OF THE OPEN BRADY
CHAPTER. THANK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SIX SIX NINE. IT WOULDN'T
UNDERMINE PUBLIC SAFETY BY
ALLOWING PROBATION OFFICERS TO
PURCHASE AND SAFE OF PRESS
TRANSPARENT. I PERSONALLY KNOW
THE DEVASTATING BECAUSE SEVEN
FIVE HANDGUNS. IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR MY BELOVED SON
KENZO WAS KILLED AT A FRIEND'S
HOUSE WHEN HIS FRIEND QUIETLY
GOT A HANDGUN FROM HIS FATHER'S
BEDROOM HIDEAWAYS AND WALDRON.
AND MISTAKENLY SHOT AND KILLED
HIM. TRANSACTION A PROMINENT
CHAMBER LED INDICATOR. SENATE
CANDIDATE WHO WAS KILLED I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH MANY OTHERS
TO MAKE CAN KERN SAFER AND WE
MADE IMPORTANT PROGRESS. IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WE PASSED
THE UNSAFE HANDGUN ACT WE SET
UP A ROSTER OF HANDGUNS
APPROVED FOR SALE IN THE STATE
AND WE REQUIRED CHAMBER LOADING
INDICATORS AND MAGAZINE
DISCONNECT SAFETY DEVICES ON
SEMI AUTOMATIC PISTOL. THE
STANDARDS LED TO A TWO THIRDS
DECLINE IN THE STATE'S RATE OF
UNINTENTIONAL GUN DEATHS THAT'S
A 66% REDUCTION IN OTHER WORDS.
BUT A BASIC SIX NINE BY
ARBITRARILY ALLOW PROBATION
OFFICERS TO USE UNSAFE HANDGUNS
WITHOUT COMPLETING THE FULL
BASIC POST TRAINING. MANY OF
THEM WENT CARRYING UNSAFE
HANDGUNS THROUGHOUT THEIR
CITIES AND TO THEIR HOMES. THE
RISK TO THEMSELVES THEIR
FAMILIES AND TO THE PUBLIC
WOULD INCREASE. THERE'S NO
REASON TO UNDERMINE THE LAWS
SENATE STANDISH HANDGUN SAFETY
STANDARDS AND HAVE SAVED SO
MANY LIVES. IF AB SIX SIX NINE
PASSES MORE LIVES THANK MY SON
CAN SHOWS WILL BE LOST. THANK
YOU FOR THAT TIME AND I ARE
CLEANS OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW MODERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES INTO
THEIR WITNESSES ARE IN QUEUE
SHOULD TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF
AB. SIX SIX NINE. TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP.
YOUR I'LL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO
THIS MAJOR. OKAY WELL I DO HAVE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS AND I JUST
NEED TO UNDERSTAND- WHAT IS
PROBATION FEEL THAT THEY NEED.
TO STOP WEAPONS WHEN THEY
ALREADY HAVE A LIST OF APPROVED
WEAPONS ITCHING TO BE JUST FINE.
WE HAVE MISTER TREE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN OF HIM BECAUSE I AM ON
THE LINE PAY ME MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SO PART OF THE PART OF THE
CHALLENGE FOR PROBATION
OFFICERS IS THAT IN AREAS
COUNTIES AROUND THE STATE
THEY'RE PART OF A- COUNTY MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL TASK FORCES
MULTI DEPARTMENTAL TASKFORCE'S.
TO INTERDICTION DURING
INTERVENTION OTHERS. IN ORDER
TO BE PART OF THOSE UNITS THERE
THERE YOU ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE
THE SAME WHAT THE SHOW. IS TO
EIGHT THIRTY POINT ONE OFFICERS
ARE CARRYING ON BOTH HER
PARENTS WHICH ARE USING TO- THE
PROBATION OFFICERS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
FIELDS OF THE SAME WEAPONS SO
THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE. THANKS
THAT'S ONE OF THE DRIVING FORCE
BEHIND BUT ALSO WE NEED
CONSISTENCY IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE BUT USED TO OTHER
DEPARTMENTS. BUT IN THIS
ARGUMENT AFTER THE BEIJING. THE
THIRD OF FROM RANKING FILE
POLICE OFFICERS WHY SHOULD THEY
CARE THE SAME TYPE OF WEAPONS
IS RECKONED FOLLETT THEY- WANT
BROUGHT SAID THEY'RE DIFFERENT
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT. WE ARE
DIFFERENT AND THEN AND WE CAN
MOST OF THEIR DUTIES ARE
DIFFERENT. HOWEVER HOME
WHENEVER LET'S SAY FOR EXAMPLE
THEY'RE SERVING WARRANTS. AND
ANOTHER DEPARTMENT YOU CALLED
IN TO HELP SERVE THE WARRANT TO
SEARCH THE VIOLATION OCCURRED
IN A NEW CHARGE YOU CAN BE.
BROUGHT UPON TROUBLED
COMMERCIALIZATION THE ONLY WAY
THEY'RE GOING TO PUSH OPTION
PARTICIPANT IS TO CONSUME A
BUNCH OF OTHER DEPARTMENTS SO.
YES THERE ARE THEY ARE
DIFFERENT. HOWEVER WHAT I WILL
SAY IS THE SAME. BAKSHI
ENHANCED ENHANCED TRAINING FOR
NON MUCH FARM USE FOR PROBATION
OFFICERS UNDER THE BILL ON THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS AND- DOESN'T
MENTION BEFORE. THEY'VE BEEN.
TRANSACTION MULTIPLE LAST FOUR
YEARS AND HAS NOT. INCIDENT
IMPROPER USE OF A LONG HAUL
TRUCKER. TODAY. MICROSTRUCTURES
REFLECT ADD MORE ONE OF THE
DIFFERENCE MISTER FIVE. SPEAK
IS THAT THE- GENERAL ON
FORTUNATE DOESNT MARK BLACK AND
WHITE VEHICLES. AND THAT THEY
ALSO HAVE SHOT GUNS MOUNTED
WITHIN THE VEHICLES USUALLY
THESE ARE GROUPS THAT- HIS%
PROBATION OFFICER JOIN WITH OUR
UNDERCOVER. TYPE VEHICLE SO
THAT MAKES IT MUCH DIFFERENT
THAN THE REGULAR UNIFORMED
OFFICER. THAT'S ALL THERE IS TO
GET A CLEAR DISTINCTION AND A
DIFFERENCE IN THE AND ACCESS TO
THE SHOT GUN IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST DIFFERENCES. THE I GOT
IT. I GUESS I'M ISN'T GUN IS A
GUN IS A GUN TO MAIN SHOW IF
YOU HAVE SOME THAT ARE ALREADY
ON THE LIST ARE PROVED TO BE-
YOU CAN USE I UNDERSTAND THE
NEED TO EXPAND. FROM A LONGER
TOUR RUGER. OR GLOCK TO. ANYWAY
OKAY. THAT AS WELL FOR YOUR
QUESTION I THINK I CAN GIVE
CLARIFICATION. I'M SORRY.
MACARI CLARIFICATION YOUR
QUESTION AS WELL SIR AND WHO IS
THIS- GREG HUMOR FROM HIS
GLORIA ALICIA PROVISIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS. SO THE OTHER
ISSUES SO IN SACRAMENTO RIGHT
NOW WE WERE USING A GLOCK FIVE
WHICH IS A NON ROSTER SO
STARTING JANUARY WE HAD TO MOVE
TWO O'CLOCK THREE WHICH IS THE
ONLY BLOCK THAT'S ON A ROSTER.
YOU WANT TO STAY WITH THE SAME
BRAND BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE AN
OFFICER DOWN WE HAVE OFFICERS
NOW USING TWO DIFFERENT TYPES
OF WEAPONS YOU GOT TO STAY
WITHIN THE SAME WEAPONRY SO
THAT YOU CAN INTERCHANGE- CLIPS
SO RIGHT NOW WITH THE GLOCK
THREE WEHAVE BEEN ATTEMPTING
TO PURCHASE A CLOCK THREE BUT
BECAUSE IT'S ON A ROSTER. IT'S
ON A ROSTER WITH THE ENTIRE
PUBLIC OF CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
NOW SEVEN MONTHS IN AND HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO PURCHASE WE HAVE
NOT PUT A SINGLE NEW OFFICER TO
ARMING- YET TO BE OUT THERE
DOING REHABILITATION BECAUSE WE
CAN'T PURCHASE THE FIREARM IN
ORDER TO DO IT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
IT READILY AVAILABLE- THE OTHER
ISSUE COMES UP IS ONCE WE MOVE
THE CLOCK THREE O'CLOCK THREE
DECIDES TO. CHANGE THE PAINT ON
THE GUN ARE- A MECHANISM ON IT
NEXT YEAR IF FALLS OFF ROSTER
WE HAVE TO CONFISCATE ALL THOSE
CLOCK THREE IS FROM THOSE WHO
JUST GOT UP. AND THEN TRY TO
FIND A ANOTHER GUN THAT IS NOW
ON THE ROSTER PURCHASE IT
RETRAIN EVERYBODY AND THAT
WEAPON- AND SEND THEM BACK OUT
WHICH IS A WHOLE BUNCH OF
DOWNTIME THAT WE'RE NOT DOING
REHABILITATION AND I'M NOT
GOING COULD FALL OFF THE
FOLLOWING YEAR COULD JUST BE A-
VICIOUS CYCLE OF US CHASING.
ROSTER GUNS HOPEFULLY BEING
ABLE TO PURCHASE IT BUT EVEN
ONCE YOU PURCHASE A TRAIN AND
DO ALL THIS EXTENSIVE TRAINING
WE COULD END UP HAVING TO
CONFISCATED. FROM THOSE
OFFICERS AND START ALL OVER
AGAIN. OKAY THIS OF AMOUNTS BY
I ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
THIS IS GROWTH INDEX- I'VE I'VE
SPOKEN BY THIS AND- WHEN AND
PREVIOUS BILLS. WHEN WESTERN.
CHIEF CAN JAMES. WHO WAS THE
FORMER- HEAD OF. FIREARMS IN
CALIFORNIA THE FIREARMS THE
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
FIREARMS GROUP. AND- HE SAID. A
BOGUS- ISSUE- THE- CASH FORCES
GENERALLY TRAINED AS A UNIT AND-
OKAY. THIRTY HERE'S THE SAME
GUNS THEMSELVES GENERALLY
POLICE DEPARTMENTS- HELLO YEAH
B. R. FISH TAKE CHOOSE FROM
SEVERAL DIFFERENT APPROVED
MODELS- HELLO THE OFFICERS
THEMSELVES MAY BE USING
DIFFERENT. MODEL- HELLO.
TRANSACTION IS NOT VERY. YEAH
PROPRIA. THANK YOU HI I SEE NO
COURTS TO THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS SOMEONE
LIKE YOU TO LOOK CLOSE. ALL I
CAN SAY IS THAT I THINK ON THE
POINTS MADE BY THE OPPOSITION
EITHER MISLEADING OR SOMEONE AN
ACCURATE. AND THIS IS A REALLY
REALLY CRITICAL FOR THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF A PROBATION TO
BE ABLE TO DO THEIR JOB SAFELY
IN OUR LAST YEAR I SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT- SHE CAN MOST I HAVE NO
RECOMMENDATIONS MEASURES SHOW
OVER THE COMMOTION- THERE'S A
MOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB SIX SIX NINE BLACKIE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD NOT VOTING A
CHOKE I TROUBLE GUY COME LONGER.
KAMAGRA NOT VOTING SKINNER
WIENER INTERNAL. FEDERAL BROKEN
WILL LOSE THE ROLE OPENBUT
THAT MEASURE RIGHT NOW SHORT OF
THE NECESSARY VOTES NEEDED TO
GET OUT COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU. NOW WILL MOVE TO
HAVE ANOTHER AUTHOR. IF NOT. I
WILL SIX X. INTERCOM LONGER DO
YOU WANT TO PRESENT YOUR TO
MEASURES.
YOU HAVE TO MEASURES
REPORTS TODAY YOU HAVE AB ONE
TWO FOUR AND AB THREE THREE
THREE SO WHATEVER YOU FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH STARTING WITH
RICHARD PLEASURE. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A. B.
ONE TWO FOUR JUSTICE FOR
SURVIVORS A LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL. I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL AND-
STATING THAT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS. THAT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS NARAL THIS BILL BY
DELETING SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
FROM THE BILL AND ADDING A
RESTRICTION OF FIRST DEGREE
MURDER UNLESS IT IS FELONY
MURDER TO THE AFFIRMATIVE
DEFENSE PROVISIONS. YOU KNOW
THIS BILL WAS BOND FROM. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF KIANA ALDRIDGE
A YOUNG WOMAN WHO ARM. WAS
PURCHASED FOR SEX- AND FOR
PROSTITUTION AND HER LIFE WAS
PEPPERED WITH SEXUAL ABUSE AND
TRAUMA- NONE OF WHICH WAS TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION DURING HER
SENTENCING- AND ALL WERE PART
OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT LED
TO HER TAKING BACK HER LIFE-
ALBEIT- USING CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR.
THE ACLU ESTIMATES THAT NEARLY
60% OF FEMALE PRISONERS
NATIONWIDE AND AS MANY AS 94%
OF CERTAIN FEMALE PRISON
POPULATIONS HAVE EXPERIENCED
PHYSICAL OR SEXUAL ABUSE BEFORE
BEING INCARCERATED. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
AND INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
AND OTHER SEVERE FORMS OF
TRAUMA ARE MORE LIKELY TO LAND
IN THE CRIMINAL COURT SYSTEM.
YET OUR STATE'S CURRENT LEGAL
FRAMEWORK LACKS CLEAR
MECHANISMS TO CONSIDER RELEVANT
FACTORS AND EXPERIENCES THAT
CONTRIBUTED TO THE COMMISSION
OF THE OFFENSE. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE SOCIETAL TRAUMA CAUSED
BY CRIMINALIZING THESE
INDIVIDUALS SPANS GENERATIONS
RESULTING IN FAMILY SEPARATION.
AND PERPETUATING CYCLES OF
ABUSE AND DRAMA TRAUMA AND
DRAMA TRAUMA AND DRAMA AND WE
KNOW THAT OFTEN TIMES. IN AND
WOMEN ARE SENTENCED DIFFERENTLY
SOMETIMES BASED ON THE SAME
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR BECAUSE OF
THEIR GENDER. AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR ADDRESSES GAPS AND
FAILURES IN THE CURRENT LEGAL
SYSTEM BY ALLOWING THE COURT TO
CONSIDER AT VARYING STAGES OF
SENTENCING IN RESENTENCING HOW
THE DEFENDANT'S OWN. RAMA
SEXUAL TRAUMA CONTRIBUTED TO
THE COMMISSION OF THE OFFENSE
AND OR CONVICTION. AB ONE
TWENTY FOUR WILL EXPAND ACCESS
TO THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE EXPANSION
DASCHLE DISCRETION TO AVOID
IMPOSING SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS ON SURVIVORS. WILL
REQUIRE JUDGES TO GIVE GET
GREAT WEIGHT TO YOUTHFULNESS
TRAUMA SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
VICTIMIZATION THROUGH INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. WHEN EXERCISING
DISCRETION AT SENTENCING STAGES
ALLOW COURTS TO CONSIDER
WHETHER THE SURVIVORS
EXPERIENCE OF TRAUMA WAS A
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR IN THE
COMMISSION OF THE OFFENSE. WHEN
EVALUATING WHETHER TO GRANT A
REDUCED SENTENCE AND WILL
EXPAND THE BACK A TOUR LAW TO
APPLY TO CRIMES THAT WERE THE
DIRECT RESULT OF BEING A VICTIM
OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE OR SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. AB ONE TWENTY FOUR
WILL GIVE SURVIVORS A MECHANISM
TO SEEK JUSTICE THAT IS
HOLISTIC AND REHABILITATIVE
WITH ME AND SUPPORT OUR APRIL
GRAYSON POLICY ASSOCIATE AT THE
YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER
AND JAMIE BACK PRESIDENT AND
MANAGING ATTORNEY AT FREE TO
THRIVE. YOUR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES ELEMENT AND HAVE EACH
AND- MISS GRATION PURITY YOU
MAY BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS A
PROGRESSION OF YOU GUYS NOW AND
I'M A PERSON WHO EXPECT EVERY
SYSTEM I WAS ONE OF THE SYSTEM-
MY MOTHER WAS BEEN MURDERED
WHEN I WAS THREE HOURS ADOPTED
ADAMS LOOK FAMILY THAT- HAD
SEVERE ISSUES MOST OF THEIR
COMMON PROBLEMS THAT. ONLY
PERPETUATED THE ABUSE THAT I
HAD SUSTAINED- PRIOR IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM- AND WORKING
MONTHS BEFORE MY FIFTEENTH
BIRTHDAY THAT MOTHER HAD A
HEART ATTACK AND DIED THREE
MONTHS LATER MY DAD PUT ME BACK
INTO THE POCKETS CARE SYSTEM-
MY BROTHER A WILD ABOUT THE
CHARACTER WHEN I WAS ARRESTED
AT FIFTEEN AND A MENTAL
HOSPITAL- AND OUT OF THE
FIFTEEN CHILDREN IN DOWN. ONE
CAPISTRANO BUT HE- WELL IF YOU
PUT IN OUR ARRESTED HAVING OUT.
FOR THE TWO KIDS SO MY FRIEND
AND YOU GET TO THE OUT THAT'S-
WOMAN. **** LAUDE FROM BEING A
TIE- BROTHER- DIED IN A CAR
CRASH IN DIDN'T. I AM MEANT TO.
AT THAT. OF EIGHTEEN TECHNICAL
CHARACTER BEING KICKED OUT OF
FOSTER CARE. A FEW MONTHS LATER
I FOUND MYSELF SACRAMENTO
COURTHOUSE SPACE FACING PICKING
UP PANDERING CYCLE. DONE LIKE
EXTENDED LARGE. LARGE CLIENT.
ADEQUAN SEVEN YEAR OLD CALL THE-
WHO WHAT MY TRAFFICKER BUT HE
WAS GOING AT PRACTICAL AND IT
TO COME OUT OF EVEN KNOW HOW
BEING. EIGHT THEY SENT ME TO.
TWENTY YEARS EIGHT MONTHS AFTER
SEVENTEEN YEARS IN PART BECAUSE
OF THE- WONDERFUL CLARITY I.
ROLLED SIX YEARS AGO AND I
STILL HAD NEVER IDENTIFIED WITH
THE FACT THAT I HAD BEEN
TRAFFIC. OR THAT I WAS THE
VICTIM OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING- I
CAME IN CONTACT WITH AN
ORGANIZATION WHO IDENTIFIED ME
AS A TRAFFIC WITH ONE AND
THOUGHT IT COULD BE THE WORK.
OF A PRESS ONE WHO HAD BEEN
TRAFFIC- I HAVE NEVER BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS THE VICTIM OF AN
ALLOWED IDENTIFYING. THEM I
LOOK AT THE INCREASE AT AGE
THIRTY FIVE IDENTIFIED AS THE
VICTIM OF. MY MOTHER'S MURDER.
MANY OF THEM PLACE BY A PEOPLE
WERE EVER ANY EIGHT THE MAIN-
HAD EIGHTY ONE TWENTY FOUR BUT
ALLOW. SOMEONE AT THEIR
CRITICAL PROSECUTOR OR GET
IDENTIFIED ME AS A VICTIM OF
THE NEEDS. ME BACK THERE WE
ALWAYS HAVE A LOT OF STEPS. AND
I HAD NEVER HAD A CHANCE IN
LIFE IN OFFERED ME ONE- WE NEED
A SYSTEM IN PLACE ELECTED WOMEN
AND SURVIVORS AND HELP PEOPLE.
ASKING AND BEING BEFORE WE.
SEND THEM. R. O. OR INCORRECTLY.
I NEEDED SOME TO LOOK AT ME AND
A CUSTOMER WAS. NOTHING WE DOWN
AND WHITE. THAT IS WHY WE NEED
AB ONE TWENTY FOUR- PLEASE.
THIS AND MOBILE ENOUGH PIPELINE
AND WILL PREVENT THEM LET ME.
THANK YOU. THANK NOW MOVES TO.
JAMIE BACK. THANK YOU CARE AND
COMMITTING I THINK IS GREAT FOR
POWER CHAU YOUR LINDA AND THE
OF THE BILL MY NAME JENNY AND
PRESIDENT MANAGING ATTORNEY OF
RECORD PRICE WE ARE CALLING
BASED LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDER
FOR SURVIVORS HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
PRIVATE BYPASS FOR. WHEN AND-
SURVIVOR WE WILL CALL MY AT.
DOCTOR ACT FOR HOW. I HAD TO
DEFEND HERSELF BUT IT BACKFIRED
TRIED TO RAPE HER. EVEN THOUGH
MY WITHIN TRAFFIC EITHER HER
TRAFFICKER NORTH EXPIRES
BRIDGET CHARGE FOR THEIR CRIME.
I WAS CONVICTED OF ATTEMPTED
INVOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER AND
SENTENCED TO FORTY YEARS TO
LIVE. MY ARE LIKE SO MANY OTHER
COMPLY SURVIVORS NEEDED JUSTICE
SYSTEM BETTING KNOWLEDGES THE
INTERCONNECTED NATURE OF TRAUMA
AND INCARCERATION. YOU NEED THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT WOULD
REQUIRE HER AND HER RECOVERY
RATHER THAN PUNISH HER FOR HER
VICTIMIZATION. AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR WITH THE COURT MY AND
COUNTLESS OTHER SURVIVORS BY
REJECTING THE GAPS IN THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM FOR
SURVIVORS SHOULD BE BUT ARE
OFTEN NOT IDENTIFIED. THESE
GAPS DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
WOMEN OF COLOR. OVER 75% OF OUR
CLIENTS ARE BY TALK AT LEAST
88% OF OUR CLIENTS ARE VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE. MOST
OF OUR CLIENTS HAVE SUFFERED
THAN AVERAGE NUMBER OF I WISH
HOUSE. EIGHT THE PRESIDENT HIGH
TWENTY THAT HE PUBLISHED BY
GEORGETOWN LAW SHOWS THAT THE
DISPARITIES FACED BY BLACK AND
BROWN GIRLS WHO ARE OVERWEIGHT
ACTUALIZED. ADULT ASIDE AND
CRIMINALIZED FROM FROM A
YOUNGER AGE. ARE YOU STUDIES
SHOW THAT ON AVERAGE 60% OF
INCARCERATED WOMEN HAVE
SUFFERED SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY FOR SURE THE
IDENTIFICATION OF SURVIVORS
DURING EVERY STAGE OF THE CASE
GOING TO COURT. TWENTY
BARGAINING THE FIRM OF THE
SENATE. THE PUBLIC CONNECTION
EARLY IT WILL PROVIDE AN AVENUE
FOR THE MONSTROSITY OF SEVERE
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA HUMAN
TRAFFICKING INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THE KNOWLEDGE THIS BILL DOES
NOT FEATURE WITH ACCOUNTABILITY
IN ANY. WE ASK THE COURTS TO
CONSIDER THE WHOLE PERSON AND
EXPERIENCE WHEN DECIDING WHICH
COULD IMPACT AND MAY BE IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF DR. EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN
COUNT ON EACH OF YOUR VOTE TO
CONTINUE THE FIGHT TO PROTECT
VICTIMS IN OUR COMMUNITY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NOW WILL MOVE
TO WITNESSES HERE AND FORTY TWO
OLD THREE AND SUPPORT OF AB ONE
TWO FOUR. SHE NINE WE WILL
MOTOR OR FULL RUN OF TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NO ONE THERE IS A
WALL MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN Q. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE
TWO FOUR. AND TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE ONE OH FOUR GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THE ONE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWO FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY NINE TWENTY FIVE. LESLIE
CALDWELL HOUSTON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE OH
THREE. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS MODELING COOPER FOR
NIELSEN WORKS MARIN BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
FIVE. DIMITRI SEE WHAT NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE. SIXTY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHAEL
OF WITH FREE TO THRIVE AS CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY FOUR AND IT IS ALSO
MY HONOR TO PROVIDE THE NAME OF
OTHER PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SUPPORT THE- BILL
ALONGSIDE. ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION. CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY DOCTOR
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALIFORNIA
PRISON FOCUS CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS.
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA CITIZEN FOR CHOI.
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE YOUTH JUSTICE. THE
LEGAL SERVICES IN EAST PALO
ALTO CONFOUNDED COMMUNITY CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. HELLO BAKER CENTER FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS EMPOWERING PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITIES. AND
SOLITARY SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
ESSIE JUSTICE GROUP FAMILY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT
PRESS NOBODY ELSE NEEDLE. AND
YOU SHE DRESSES. KERN COUNTY
PARTICIPATORY DEFENSE MONARCH
SERVICES NATIONAL CENTER FOR
YOUTH LAW NATIONAL INSTITUTE
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
PEOPLE OF POTTERY PROJECT POINT
LOMA NAZARENE UNIVERSITY CENTER
FOR JUSTICE AND RECONCILIATION
RESTORED JUSTICE RIGHT FOR
GIRLS SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE BAY AREA SISTER
WARRIORS FREEDOM COALITION SAN
JOSE APPROX OF THE- ON
CONNEMARA URBAN STRATEGY
COUNSEL UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND CHANGE COLORS.
W. HEY WOULD BURN INSTITUTE AND
FINALLY YOUNG WOMAN FREEDOM
CENTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MY GOODNESS. BLIND
ONE OH EIGHT. NOT CHAIR AND
CHAIR NUMBER THE COMMITTEE
ESPANA ON BEHALF OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BLIND. ONE ELEVEN. JIM WEINBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE PRINT MEDIA AT
THE QUESTION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE LINE ONE
LINE. ONE TWELVE. TURN RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
HOWEVER WE HAVE BEEN HAVING
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OTHER TOP OF THE MUCH
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THEM THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
NOW WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION AND
FOURTH IN THE SAME
CONSIDERATION WILL. GIVE THE
PRIMARY WITNESS- I THINK
SOMEONE ONCE IT WILL ALLOW THEM
THREE MINUTES. IN TOTAL AND- I
THINK IT'S OUR RICHARD MILLER.
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENT BY THE
AUTHOR TO MOVE TO REMOVE THE
CHANGES TO THE PENAL CODE
SECTION TWENTY EIGHT FROM AB
ONE TWENTY FOUR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY SOME MORE
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS-
REGARDING AB ONE TWENTY FOUR AT
THIS TIME WE REMAIN. CONCERNED
WITH SOME OF THE ONE TWENTY
FOURTH POSITION PROVISIONS THAT
GO FAR BEYOND EATING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS SUCH AS THE
YOUNG WOMAN MENTIONED BY THE
AUTHOR THIS MORNING INSTEAD
OPEN UP MULTIPLE AVENUES OF
RELIEF TO CRIMINAL OFFENDERS
THROUGHOUT OUR COURT SYSTEM.
FIRST AB ONE TWENTY FOUR
ESSENTIALLY MANDATES THE
IMPOSITION OF A LOWER TERM FOR
ALL FELONIES PROHIBITS THE
IMPOSITION OF ANY SORT OF
ENHANCEMENT. AND PROHIBITS
CONSECUTIVE SENTENCES NO MATTER
HOW MANY CRIMES WERE COMMITTED.
AS LONG AS ONE OF THE FOLLOWING
IS ESTABLISHED. WHEN THE PERSON
IS EXPERIENCE PSYCHOLOGICAL
PHYSICAL OR CHILDHOOD TRAUMA
THAT IS A QUOTE CONTRIBUTING
FACTOR IN THE COMMISSION OF THE
CRIME. THERE IS NO DEFINITION
OF WHAT LEVEL OF TRAUMA IS
REQUIRED THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THERE BE A
DIRECTORY EVEN IN DIRECT LINK
BETWEEN ANY TRAUMA AND THE
COMMISSION OF THE CRIME.
THERE'S NO DEFINITION IN THIS
CONTEXT OF WHAT CAN CONSTITUTE
A QUOTE CONTRIBUTING FACTOR OR
NUMBER TWO PERSONALLY USED
DEFINED BY AB ONE TWENTY FOUR
ITSELF AS SOMEONE LESS THAN
TWENTY SIX YEARS OLD. OR THREE
THE PERSON WAS A VICTIM OF
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE OR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THIS VERSION
OF AB ONE TWENTY FOUR MEANS
THAT ANY TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
RAPIST CHILD MOLESTER
RESIDENTIAL BURGLAR. DOMESTIC
ABUSER ANIMAL ABUSER ARSONIST
HE CRIME PERPETRATORS HUMAN
TRAFFICKER. OR ANYONE ELSE
CONVICTED OF ANY FELONY IN THE
STATE WILL BENEFIT FROM ITS
PROVISIONS EVEN IF YOU IN
TRAFFICKING OR INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE. PLAGUE ZERO ROLE IN
YOU THE CRIME OR IN THE
PERPETRATORS HISTORY. THERE'S
NO DOUBT THAT ANYONE UNDER
TWENTY SIX WILL ASSERT THEIR
EACH CONTRIBUTED TO THE
COMMISSION HER CRYING. THERE IS
NO PRACTICAL WAY TO REPORT THIS
CLAIM. NEITHER THE TRUMP
PROVISION NOR THE YOUTH
PROVISION IN AB ONE TWENTY FOUR
HAS ANYTHING TO DO WITH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. BUT THESE
PROVISIONS THE TRUE SUBSTANCE
ON THIS BILL AS WE SEE IT AND
IT'S SILENT ON THE MEDIAN
SUFFERING OF VICTIMS WHEN THE
CRIME IS COMMITTED AND SILENT
ON THE LASTING OFTEN LIFE
CHANGING EFFECTS ON THEIR
PERPETRATORS CRIMES. BY GIVING
THE COURTS NO GUIDANCE ON WHAT
A CONTRIBUTING FACTOR IS NO
THRESHOLD LEVEL OF
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA. PHYSICAL
TRIAL DRAMA OR EVEN WHEN
CHILDHOOD ENDS FOR THE PURPOSES
OF CHILDHOOD TRAUMA FOR EXAMPLE
IS IT UP TO AGE TWENTY SIX OR
LESSER EACH. THIS PROVISION AB
pONE TWENTY FOUR WILL THROW
RECORDS INTO A PERIOD OF
EXTENSIVE LITIGATION OVER THESE
UNDEFINED TERMS AND WILL RESULT
IN VASTLY. DISPARATE SENTENCES
FROM COURTROOM TO COURTROOM
COUNTY TO COUNTY AS JUDGES
WRESTLE WITH HOW TO APPLY
LANGUAGE FOR WHICH NO GUIDANCE
IS PROVIDED. THIS WILL BE
COSTLY BECAUSE HE NEEDS TO ONE
TWENTY FOUR PROVIDES NO
FUNDING. AB ONE TWENTY FOUR
ALSO PROVIDES AN AFFIRMATIVE
DEFENSE FOR VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE VICTIMS. WE HAVE NO
QUARREL WITH THIS IN PRINCIPLE.
BUT THIS DEFENSE IS ALREADY
WIDELY AVAILABLE UNDER CURRENT
LAW AND HAS BEEN FOR MANY YEARS
WITH COMMONSENSE REQUIREMENTS
THAT MUST BE MET. AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR BE MORE CLEAR AND MORE
EFFECTIVE IF IT PROVIDED A
TAILORED SET OF WELL DEFINED
CRITERIA. TO APPLY IN A CASE
WHERE DIFFERENT RAISES THIS
DEFENSE IN A HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SCENARIO OR INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE SCENARIO. HAS WRITTEN
AB ONE TWENTY FOUR DOES NOT NOW
DEFINED THE DEGREE OF HARM
INVOLVED NOR DOES IT DEFINE THE
TYPE HE DOES NOT DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN PHYSICAL HARM. WOULD BE
A SLAP OR A SEVERE BEATING ON
MOTIONAL HARM WOULD BE A SINGLE
VERBAL INSULTS OR REPEATED
DEGRADATION IN FRONT OF AN
ABUSED SPOUSES CHILDREN. OR
FINANCIAL PARK WOULD BE STEP TO
TWENTY DOLLARS FROM HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS PURSED WHAT
WOULD IT BE COMPLETE FINANCIAL
TAKEOVER OF THE VICTIMS
RESOURCES RENDERING THEM
COMPLETELY DEPENDENT ON THEIR
ABUSERS FOR FOOD. CLOTHING
TRANSPORTATION AND SHELTER SOME
OF THE SHOULD GET SOME
CONSIDERATION IN A DEFENSE LIKE.
I SAID WE HAVE NO QUARREL WITH
HIS IN PRINCIPLE BUT SOME.
MURDER MANSLAUGHTER KIDNAPPING
HOME INVASION BURGLARY AND
ARSON THIS IS NOT HYPERBOLE
THESE ARE NOT BUZZ WORDS THE
ONLY WAY TO TALK ABOUT THE
CRIMES FOR WHICH AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR. SEEKS TO PROVIDE A- AN
AFFIRMATIVE DEFENSE AS WELL AS
THEY COULD TO RELIEF HE'S CAN
NAME THEM AND THOSE ARE THE
NAMES OF THE VIOLENT CRIMES
WHOSE PERPETRATORS WILL BENEFIT
FROM AB ONE TWENTY FOUR.
VICTIMS OF THESE AWFUL CRIMES
ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
LANGUAGE OF AB ONE TWENTY FOUR
THAT MAKES THESE WHOLESALE
CHANGES. OTHER PROVISIONS AB
ONE TWENTY NEED TO REQUIRE WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. ASIDE FROM THE
VERY REAL POTENTIAL INJUSTICES
THAT MAY RESULT FROM AB ONE
TWENTY FOUR AB ONE TWENTY FOUR
WILL ENSURE EXTENDED LITIGATION
OR TRIAL AND APPELLATE COURTS
IF ENACTED IN ITS CURRENT STATE
FOR THESE REASONS WE REMAIN
OPPOSED AB ONE TWENTY FOUR IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NOW
WILL COME BACK TO COMMITTEE
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE OR
THEIR WITNESSES. AND OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE TWO FOUR HERE IN THE
ROOM. SHE NINE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM AND TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NO ONE THERE IS A WALL
NOW MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AND LET'S SEE IF
THERE ARE WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE TWO FOUR.
THANK YOU- TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION AB ONE TWO FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE FILED BY
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB ONE TWO FOUR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND HONEST HERE WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE QUEUEING UP WILL
BE WITH YOU IN ONE SECOND.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH LINE FIFTY
SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY
SIX. BRIAN SHERMAN RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION WILL NOT
THE SYSTEM ALONG WITH THE
POLICE OFFICER ASSOCIATIONS
FROM PALACE VERDES. UPLAND
INGLEWOOD CORONA NEWPORT BEACH
SANTA ANA ARCADIA ALERTS AND
AMONA BURBANK RIVERSIDE OVER SO
THE LOS ANGELES SCHOOL POLICE
ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF SCHOOL SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS AND PLUS YOU'RE A
DEPUTY SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ON
STRONG OPPOSITION TO. AB ONE
TWO FOUR THANK YOU. IN A COOL
LINE. ONE HUNDRED. ONE HUNDRED
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
HEALTHY IT MAKES YOUR ANGER AND
WHAT THE NORTH WINDOW LEDGE
FOUNDATION WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AS IT IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN AS THE OPPOSITION
STATED. AND A FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TWO ARE EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION FOR AB ONE TWO FOUR.
ONE FORTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. HI
THIS IS STEPHANIE WITH CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED AMARIN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF AB ONE TWO FOUR.
AND THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMAND OR
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS SHOULD
AUTHOR IN REGARDS TO AB ONE TWO
FOUR. SENIOR CENTERS HERE. OKAY
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR SCANNER. NO QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS FROM. MEMBERS YOUR
IN THIS COMMENT THAT TIME.
WHILE THERE THE TESTIMONY WAS
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THIS- THESE
FACTORS CAN ALREADY BE FACTORED.
I THINK WE HAVE LOTS OF
INDICATION. OF- I WILL FOCUS ON
WOMEN FOR THE MOMENT OF WOMEN
WHO ARE SERVING QUITE LONG
SENTENCES WHO- WERE THE VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND WHERE
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WAS A
FACTOR IN THE IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCE OR AND OR THE
HUMAN TRAFFICKING. AND YET IT
DID NOT AFFECT THE CIRCUMSTANCE
SO WHETHER- AND IN MY-
UNDERSTANDING IS BECAUSE THERE
WAS NOT ENOUGH CLARITY IN THE
LAW THAT'S WHAT I THINK THIS
BILL DOES IS CREATE THAT TYE
OF CLARITY SO IT REALLY CAN BE
FACTORED IN I THINK THAT'S IN A
VERY VERY IMPORTANT FACTOR IN
SENTENCING SO THAT IS WHY
SUPPORTABILITY THANK DR PER
BRING AFFORD. OKAY SKINNER
COMMODORE TO CLOSE YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'D LIKE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE COMMENTS-
FROM THE OPPOSITION. HEY WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM-
AND HAVE TAKEN QUITE A FEW
AMENDMENTS TO NARROW DOWN THIS
BILL- SO. I WOULD LIKE THEM TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AT SOME POINT-
THE SECOND THING IS. IF YOU
LISTEN TO THE TESTIMONY- SO A
THIS IS NOT ABOUT A WOMAN WHO
STEALS A GALLON OF MILK. YOU
KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. THE
CRIMES THAT WERE COMMITTED THIS
IS NOT ABOUT EXEMPTING AND
CONDONING CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR
EITHER BUT IT IS ABOUT ALLOWING
THE COURTS TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF SEXUAL ABUSE AND TRAUMA THAT
LED TO THAT PARTICULAR BEHAVIOR
THIS IS NOT A GET OUT OF JAIL
FREE CARD- BUT IT ISN'T ONCE
AGAIN ABOUT. SOMEONE IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT EXEMPTING ALL KINDS
OF YOU KNOW CRIMINAL OR FELONY
OR VIOLENT CRIMES TO FOCUS ON
THESE NON SERIOUS NONVIOLENT
CRIMES THAT DON'T. THE REALITY
IS THAT MANY OF THE WOMEN WHO
ARE OR WHO HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED. HAVE STORIES THAT
INVOLVE SEXUAL ABUSE OF THEIR
BODIES AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE COURTS DO NOT SEE THAT
BECAUSE THEY WERE DESIGNED. YOU
KNOW BY A PATRIARCHY. KIANA
STORY APRIL STORY INVOLVES
SITUATIONS WHERE MEN. IN
MULTIPLE TIMES PURCHASED AND
SOLD AND TRAUMATIZED THESE
WOMEN AND THOSE FOLKS WERE NOT
GIVEN ANY KIND OF SERIOUS
PUNISHMENT. AND WE KNOW THAT
COURTS LOOK VERY DIFFERENTLY AT
WOMEN. WHO TAKE. HOLD OF THEIR
BODIES AND THEIR FREEDOM. I'M
VERY DIFFERENTLY THAN MEN AND
SO THIS WORKS TO ADDRESS THIS I
WOULD ALSO JUST LIKE TO ADD
THAT THE VERY NARROW
PRESCRIPTIONS AT THE OPPOSITION
CONTINUES TO ASK FOR ACTUALLY
CREATE. INFLEXIBILITY WITH IN
THE COURT SYSTEM AND TIE THE
HANDS OF JUDGES AND WE KNOW
THAT. JUDGES DON'T WRESTLE
OFTEN TIMES WITH THESE KINDS OF
ISSUES THEY ERR ON THE SIDE OF
THE CONSERVATIVE RULING- AND SO
THE GOAL IS TO ALLOW FOR
DISCRETION AND FOR FLEXIBILITY
IN THE COURT SO THAT JUDGES ARE
ABLE TO LOOK AT ALL OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT ARE PART OF
A PARTICULAR CHARGE WHEN
THEY'RE MAKING A SENTENCING-
RULING. THAT THE DEFENSE COULD
WE STILL HAVE TO DISPROVE THESE
THINGS SO IT'S NOT LIKE YOU'RE
HAVING FOLKS COME OUT. WITH
THESE RANDOM ACTS OF LOVE WILD
VIOLENCE AND YOU HAVE TO LET
THEM OUT BECAUSE OF THESE BILLS
THINGS STILL HAVE TO BE PROVEN
AND THEY HAVE TO BE DISPROVEN
WE'RE JUST ASKING. THAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF REAL SUSTAIN
SEXUAL ABUSE AND TRAUMA ARE
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION. BACK
THE TIME OF SENTENCING OR
RESENTENCING AND IN SOME
INSTANCES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RESENTENCING BECAUSE THE WOMEN
ARE ALREADY IN PRISON SERVING
VERY LONG SENTENCES. SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVALS. SEVEN CONSULTANT-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. IT'S TO
PASS AS AMENDED CORRECT A
COMMA- IT'S AS AMENDED YES YES
I DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR BRADFORD I JUST REALIZED
THAT IF HE DID NOT BASS
PROMOTIONAL SORRY THE PILOT OF
CREDITORS SKINNER MADE A MOTION
EARLIER APOLOGIZE- THE CHOKE.
NOT VOTING AGE OF ABOUT
BUILDING COMM MARKER KAMLAGER
AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE WIENER.
WIENER WRITES THREE VOTES WE
CAN LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
BRADFORD LEAVE THE ROSE LAW
FIRM. HE WAS MISSING FROM IT
WILL GO UP TO THAT. THANK YOU
SENATOR KAMLAGER IN CARE. SO I
WILL PRESENT THE NEXT BILL
THAT'S ALLOWED OKAY GREAT- AND
A CONTINUED GOOD MORNING I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK. THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL AND ALSO
STATING THAT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS ON THIS BILL. THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AT FIRST
DEGREE BURGLARY BACK INTO THE
LIST O PREDICATE OFFENSES
RECASTS THE PART OF THE BILL
DEALING WITH COMMON BENEFIT.
WHICH IS MORE THAN REPUTATIONAL
TO APPLY TO ALL OF PC ONE
EIGHTY SIX POINT TWO TWO. AND
ASK CLARIFYING DEFINITION OF
ACTIONS THAT COULD MEET THIS
REQUIREMENT. AND AMEND PENAL
CODE ONE EIGHTY SIX TO TWO
SUBDIVISION. B. THREE WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN FOUND TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. TO EXTEND THE
SUNSET ON THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
THAT FIX THE ON CON. I
COMMITTED. TO ENGAGING STEAK TO
OUT THE LEGISLATIVE. INCLUDE
ABA. CURRENT GETTING IN ARE I
YOU FOR BELOW LEE AND FOR.
AGAINST PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
HAVE RESULTED IN THE SYSTEMIC
CRIMINALIZATION OF CULTURES AND
COMMUNITIES. OUR CURRENT GANG
ENHANCEMENT STATUTES HAVE VAGUE
DEFINITIONS THEY HAVE WEAK
STANDARDS OF PROOF AND ARE
PERHAPS THE MOST RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATORY PART OF OUR
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM 92% OF
PEOPLE WITH GANG ENHANCEMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. TO THIS POINT I HAVE
SHARED THIS MANY STORIES DURING
MY TIME WITH THIS BILL.
LAURIE'S OF A YOUNG BLACK MAN
WHO STOLE A TALL CANNOT BEARD
AND A GALLON OF MILK WHO
HAPPENED TO BE IN A GAME BUT
DID NOT STEAL EITHER OF THOSE
THINGS BECAUSE HE WAS IN A GANG
AND WAS LEVIED WITH GANG
ENHANCEMENTS CHARGES. VERSES
EIGHT YOUNG WHITE MAN WHO WAS
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATING IN A
GAME KILLING PEOPLE WEARING LOW
THROWING UP SIGNS WEARING
INSIGNIA OUT WEARING COLORS AND
BOASTING ABOUT HIS GANG
AFFILIATION AND NOT HAVING A
GANG ALLEGATION LEVIED ON HIM.
NO ENHANCEMENT THESE ARE REAL
STORIES OF REAL PEOPLE THAT
SPEAK TO THE DISCRIMINATORY
APPLICATION OF THESE
ENHANCEMENTS. AB THREE THREE
THREE MAKES CHANGES TO THE LAW
THAT WILL REDUCE THE DAMAGING
APPLICATION OF GETTING
ENHANCEMENTS TO THE CRIMINAL
CASES. IT ALSO MAKES THE
STANDARD FOR APPLYING A GANG
ENHANCEMENT RIGOROUS
REENGINEERING THESE
ENHANCEMENTS TO FUNCTION AS
ORIGINALLY INTENDED. THIS BILL
ALSO ALIGNS WITH POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS PROVIDED IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE ON THE
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE I
WANT TO SAY THIS IS NOT ABOUT
GANGS ABOUT DUE PROCESS AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY THIS BILL IS
JUST ABOUT MAKING SURE. THAT
YOU HAVE TO PROVE THE CHARGES
THAT YOU ARE LEVYING AGAINST
pENHANCEMENTS SHIFT THE FACT
FINDERS LANDS AWAY FROM PROVING
THE BASE CHAKRA TIME. AND
TOWARDS THE DEFENDANT'S ETHNIC
MAKE UP WHERE THEY LIVE AND WHO
THEY HANG OUT WITH. WHEN AS A
RESULT OF GANG ENHANCEMENTS
ORDINAY CRIMES. ARE TURNED
INTO GANG CRIMES BECAUSE OF OUR
FEAR OF GANGS AND THE STEREO
TYPES ASSOCIATED WITH GANGS
THIS BILL DOES NOT SEEK TO MAKE
THE APPLICATION OF A GANG
ENHANCEMENT IMPOSSIBLE RATHER
IT ASKS THAT SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE BE PROVIDED IN ORDER
TO PROVE THAT THE UNDERLYING
OFFENSE WAS ACTUALLY COMMITTED
ON BEHALF OF THE GAME IT ASKS
THAT PROSECUTORS DO THEIR JOB
IT ASKS THAT YOU DO NOT LEAN ON
ARCANE TOOLS OF RACISM AND BIAS.
THIS SENSIBLE CHANGE WILL
ENSURE THAT GANG ENHANCEMENTS
ARE APPLIED ONLY. TWO CASES
WHERE THERE'S GANG ENHANCE
ACTIVITY DONE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF A GAME. AND ALSO BECAUSE OF
OUR SYSTEM ONCE YOU ARE LABELED
AS A GANG MEMBER YOU CAN NEVER
BE D. LABELED AS A GANG MEMBER
BECAUSE OF OUR GANG REGISTRY SO
EVEN IF YOU AGE OUT OF BEING IN
A GAME. YOU ARE STILL LABELED A
GANG MEMBER AND THAT CAN BE
USED AGAINST YOU SO IF YOU JAY
WALK AT EIGHTY SEVEN YEARS OLD
AND AT AGE TWENTY TWO YOU WERE
ACTIVE IN A GANG A GANG
ENHANCEMENT CAN BE LEVIED
AGAINST YOU. BY ADDRESSING
SEVERAL DAMAGING EFFECTS OF
GETTING EVIDENCE AT TRIAL. AND
NARROWING THE APPLICABILITY OF
SUCH EVIDENCE. AB THREE THREE
THREE TAKES AN IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD AT UNDOING SOME OF THE
HARM CAUSED. BY CURRENT GANG
ENHANCEMENT STATUTES WITH ME
AND SUPPORT IS- CERRO HEADED
OUT OF THE YOUNG WOMAN'S
FREEDOM CENTER AND LISA ROMANO.
I JUST GOT A TAX. SENATOR
CAMARGO WE JUST RECEIVED A
NOTICE THAT YOUR MIKE MIGHT
HAVE GONE OFF FOR A WHILE THERE
SO IF YOU TO MY WORK IN A TO A
CHECK. DO A CHECK. AB THE
MICROPHONE GOT NERVOUS. I'M
HERE HI MY NAME IS LIU SAID-ALRIGHT I'LL I'M THE BILL
DETERMINATION COORDINATOR AT
THE YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM
BANNER MORNING XLR MY MOTHER
FLED HER COUNTRY DUE TO
GOVERNMENT POLITICAL VIOLENCE
FACTORED INTO THE GLOBAL WAR
THE CIVIL WAR BILL MILITARY
TANK THAT TRAIN CHILDREN TO USE
VIOLENCE. MY MOTHER CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES WITH A PARTY AND
CORRUPTION ONLY TO EXPERIENCE
MUCH OF THE THING HERE I GREW
UP IN SAN FRANCISCO MISSION
DISTRICT WHERE MANY OF MY
FRIENDS AND FAMILY WERE PULLED
OUT AND LABELED GANG MEMBERS
WHEN I WAS SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD
I WAS CHARGED AS AN ADULT WITH
THE GANG ENHANCEMENT AND ALL MY
EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY I WAS
TRANSFERRED TO THE ADULT JAIL
WOULD TWELVE FELONY COUNTS SUCH
AS TERRORISM. MAY HAVE AN
ATTEMPTED MURDER MY BROTHER WAS
ALSO PROFILE IN TARGETED IN
EVENTUALLY REPORTED AND LATER
WITH MURDER AND SOME OTHER IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. I MEAN
LIKE MANY OTHER HAVE COME TO
THE U. STATES BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF WE THOUGHT. AND EXPORTS
BUT INSTEAD OF FREEDOM FROM.
THINKING WE ARE. BECAUSE OF THE
GIVE ME AND WE FROM. IT'S ABOUT
THE NINETEEN. 70% OF THE-
PRISON POPULATION OUT OF THE
ONE DAY AND MORE THAN NINETY.
OF STOCK WITH THE GANG AND IN
THE STATE PRISON IS EITHER
BLACK OR BROWN. GANG IN
HAPPENING TO LOCK. THAT
PROFILING REPORT. IN MY BROTHER
EIGHT THAT. HAVEN'T BEEN
CHARGED WITH THE GANG AND HAS
SPENT I HAD TO BET YOUR I THINK
MEMBER JERRY BLUE. THAT
IDENTIFIES ME AS THE MEMBER.
NOW ONLY DID IT HUMANITE YEAH
LET ME TO BE A TARGETED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WHEREVER I WENT
AND MET THE FRIENDS AND FAMILY
OFTEN DO NOT WANT TO BE AROUND
ME. THEY LOOK MORE AT THE
GENKAI THAN THAT BEATING AND OF
MY ABUSER. HERE LEFT ME WITH.
EVEN WHEN DEFENDING WILL NOT
SEPARATE THE GENKAI ON MY THERE
ARE HAVING AND- HOW. TO BE FOR
INTO THE- TO GET CAUGHT. DUE TO
BEING A- OF AN ABUSIVE WILL.
WITH MY- I'M JUST OF ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE HARMED BY
AND I WOULD THE BIG. ABUSE AND
PAM AND MARKETS ARE BEEN.
WORKING OUR HAVE A BETTER
CHANCE. AT HAVING A FAIR TRIAL
NOT THE OUT WITH. POSSIBLE OR
PRE A BY AGAIN ME AND LETTING
MY TO. I'M ARGUED VOTE YES ON A-
THREE THREE BECAUSE NEED TO
HUMANITE BLACK. CREEK NINETY
HUMAN RIGHTS. CRIMINALIZED AWAY
DO YOU LIVE OR HOW THEY ELECT.
THANK YOU FOR THE DAY. THE ONLY
SERVER. AND I FOR A DAY.
PURPOSES SIGNED THE DIRECTOR OF.
ISSUES WITH. AT THE OFFICE OF
THE STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER
HOWEVER I'M HERE TESTIFYING
TODAY. IN MY INDIVIDUAL
CAPACITY IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE THREE THE STEP FORWARD
ACT. AB THREE THIRTY THREE IS A
MODEST BILL THAT WOULD MITIGATE
SOME OF THE IMBALANCES BETWEEN
PROSECUTORS. AND PEOPLE ACCUSED
UNDER THE ANTI GANG. LAW WE
KNOW IS THE STEP BACK. WHEN IT
WAS PASSED OVER THIRTY YEARS
AGO THE STEP UP PROPONENTS OF
THE STEP ACT PRESSURED
CALIFORNIANS THAT IT WOULD BE
USED IN ONLY THE MOST EGREGIOUS
CASES. BUT THAT ISN'T THE CASE
IN FACT IN THE LAST TEN YEARS
THE USE OF GANG HANDS MRS
INCREASED OVER FORTY PERCENT.
WHAT CRIMES OF ALL TYPES HAVE
DECREASED SIGNIFICANTLY. THIS
IS TRUE IN LARGE PART BECAUSE
OF LEGISLATIVE ADVANCEMENTS AND
JUDICIAL INTERPRETATION OF THE
STEP ACT THAT HAS GREATLY
ENHANCED ITS REACH. ORIGINALLY
PROPONENTS JUSTIFIED THE
INCREASE IN PUNISHMENT FOR
PEOPLE INVOLVED IN CRIMINAL
STREET GANGS. BASED ON TWO
FACTORS FIRST THE ORGANIZED
NATURE CRIMINAL STREET GANGS
AND SECOND THE PATTERN OF
VIOLENT CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT
THEY ENGAGED IN. BUT NOW ALMOST
ANY CRIME CAN BE DESIGNATED I'M
SORRY ANY GROUP CAN BE
DESIGNATED AS A CRIMINAL STREET
GANG AS LONG AS A POLICE
OFFICER SAYS SO. AB THREE THREE
THREE WOULD TIGHTEN THE
REQUIREMENTS IN ESTABLISHING A
CRIMINAL STREET GANG IN
IMPORTANT WAYS FIRST IT WOULD
REMOVE EIGHT ACTUALLY IF WE
TAKE A BERKELEY SEVEN. A
NONVIOLENT PROPERTY CRIMES FROM
A LIST OF THIRTY THREE
PREDICATE OFFENSES THAT- THAT
ARE USED TO PROVE UP PATTERN OF
GANG ACTIVITY. SECOND IT WOULD
NOT ALLOW THE CURRENT- CHARGED
OFFENSE TO BE A QUALIFY AS ONE
OF THE PREDICATE ACTIVITIES
FENCES. AND THIRTY WOULD ENSURE
THAT ONE OF THE PREDICATE ONE
OF THE- PREDICATE OFFENSES
OCCURS WITHIN THREE YEARS OF
THE CHARGED OFFENSE. MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY IT WOULD
BIFURCATE THE PROOF OF THE GANG
ENHANCEMENTS. RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT MERELY PRESENTING GANG
EVIDENCE CAN MOVE JURORS TO
CONVICT EVEN IF GUILTY BEYOND
REASONABLE DOUBT HAS NOT BEEN
ESTABLISHED. AB THREE THREE
THREE CAN ALSO HELP MITIGATE
THE EXTREME RACIAL DISPARITIES
THE SENATOR COM LOCKER HAS
REFERRED TO- AS WE IS NOW 92%
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE- GANG
ENHANCEMENTS ARE BLACK AND
LATINO. YET REPUTABLE SURVEY
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT WHITE
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
IDENTIFIED AS GANG MEMBERS AT
THIS AT ROUGHLY THE SAME RATES
THAT LATINO AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN CHILDREN DO. IN SOME
AB THREE THREE THREE IS A
REASONABLE AND MEASURED
APPROACH TO RETURN THE STEP
BACK TO ITS ORIGINAL INTENT AND
PERFECT AND TO PREVENT THE
UNJUST CONVICTION OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
TESTIMONY ARE MISERABLE WE WILL
NOW. I WILL MOVE ON TO ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE THREE HERE IN OUR
COMMITTEE ROOM. CNN WE WILL GO
INTO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. C. NINE
THANK YOU NUMBER ONE TWO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCES.
MONTEREY IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WHEN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE THREE. THANK YOU TO SET
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF IT AB
THREE THREE THREE PLUS PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO NINE ONE ONE
FIVE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
BASICALLY WHAT ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
WE'RE CALLING IN SUPPORT- AB
THREE TWO THREE THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTY SEVEN. SURE READ MORE
WHAT CALIFORNIA CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. HOW BY ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
NINE TWENTY FIVE. WE CALDWELL
HOUSTON FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
SEVENTEEN. NO WONDER WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE
THREE THANK YOU. LINE. TWENTY
ONE. GOOD MORNING FEDERAL WORK
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
ONE OH TWO. GOOD MORNING CATHY
SURE FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR. HEROD RILEY ON HOW
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION AT THIS TIME WE
DO HAVE BEEN CONCERNED AND WE
HAVE BEN ON AN ONGOING
DIALOGUE WITH THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS AND ARE HOPING TO
RESOLVE THE CONCERNS THANK YOU.
NINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING GOING BACK IS FOR THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS AND DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
NINETEEN. GOOD MORNING I'LL
HAVE THAT DONE WITH WIDENING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. NINE ONE
OH THREE. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS NOT A COOPER NIELSEN
WORK MORE ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY AFFILIATE ON THE BORDER
THANK YOU. PINE FIFTY FIVE.
THERE WERE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE TWENTY THREE. JIM WOOD
BURKE ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THAT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE ZERO EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS LONG AS WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION WE
ARE A PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE THREE THREE
I JUST SAID THE COMMITTEE TIME
OVER READING OFF A LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS ARE GIVEN AT THE
COMMISSION TO SAY THAT THEY ARE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SHOWING UP
FOR RACIAL JUSTICE STORAGE I
THINK THAT PART I LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN UNDER BROWN SCHOLARS
INITIATIVE AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC. DEFENDER WHO
IS ALSO A CO SPONSOR THANK YOU.
PINE SIXTY EIGHT. BUT I'M SURE
MEMBERS GAMBLES ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE NO OTHER LINE IT'S IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATE IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
CHECKING THE LINES ONE MORE
TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL THAT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE THREE THREE. AFTER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP.
THANK YOU MODERATOR. HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WILL NOT FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE LEAD
OPPOSITION OF WITNESSES WE HAVE
SHARE A RYAN SHERMAN AND DANIEL
OWENS AND- THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING US VICE CHAIRPERSON AND
NOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR HEARING FOR ME
THIS MORNING TODAY I APPEAR
REPRESENTING BOTH SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY SUMMER
STEPHAN AS WELL AS THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DEPT DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION
AND ITS THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MEMBERS MMHM THIS STEP IN AND
MY ASSOCIATION ARE FULLY
COMMITTED TO IMPROVING OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THROUGH
SMART AND RESPONSIBLE REFORM
BUT IN ORDER TO BALANCE OUR
SOCIAL JUSTICE EFFORTS OF THE
STATE WE MUST ALSO CONSIDER OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY NEEDS. RECENTLY
MR EVAN HAS INSTITUTED
PROGRESSIVE REFORMS SUCH AS
DISSOLVING ALL CIVIL GANG
INJUNCTIONS FROM WITHIN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY BECAUSE THEY CAN
BE AN IMPEDIMENT TO RE
INTEGRATING MEMBERS OF- THAT
HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN INVOLVED IN
GANG ACTIVITY THAT NOW ARE
SEEKING TO BECOME LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS AB THREE THIRTY THREE
AS PROPOSED TODAY SIMPLY FAILS
TO MEET ITS STATED GOALS WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND IT'S PROPONENTS
SINCE IT- LET'S WILL REGION IN
THE HOUSE AND WE CONTINUE TO DO
SO AND WE SIMPLY URGE OUR
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN
AT THIS TIME. THOSE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ARE COMMONSENSE THEY
ARE REASONABLE AND THEY DO NOT
ADDRESS ANYTHING THAT HAS TO DO
WITH THE CARGED DEFENDANT ON
TRIAL THEY SIMPLY GO TO THE
LEGAL DEFINITION THAT EXISTS
FOR WHAT THE PROSECUTION MUST
PROVE BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT- THAT THE GANG EXISTS
GANG VIOLENCE IS VERY REAL AND
REMAINS A SUBSTANTIAL PUBLIC
SAFETY CRISIS AS A GANG
PROSECUTOR I WORKED DIRECTLY
WITH THE COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
DEVASTATED BY THE IMPACTS OF
GANG VIOLENCE. THE SAN DIEGO
POLICE DEPARTMENT REPORTED JUST
LAST WEEK THAT THERE IS A ONE
HUNDRED AND 29% INCREASE IN
GANG RELATED SHOOTINGS THERE
HAVE BEEN SIXTEEN UNSOLD GANG
SHOOTINGS IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS
ALONE IN SAN. DIEGO IN THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO. STATEWIDE THE
RATE AND CAL. WAS TWO THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND TWO LINES INTO
THE IN TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MORE
LIVES THAN IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
THREE FOURTHS OF ALL MURDERS
COMMITTED STATEWIDE INVOLVED
THE USE OF GUNS AND 28% OF
MURDER STATEWIDE ARE COMMITTED
BY GANG MEMBERS. THERE'S A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT UPON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR INDEED IN
GETTING RELATED VIOLENCE AND
STATEWIDE STATISTICS FOR THE
MURDER RATE 31% OF MURDER
VICTIMS WERE AFRICAN AMERICAN.
45% OF MURDER VICTIMS WERE
LATINO. THIS IS THE HIGHEST A
NUMBER OF LIVES LOST IN OUR
STATE IN THE LAST THIRTEEN
YEARS. SIMPLY PUT NOW IS NOT
THE TIME TO ELIMINATE THE LEGAL
TOOLS THAT WE HAVE TO
INCARCERATE THE MOST VIOLENT
OFFENDERS AND THAT INCLUDES
GANG MEMBERS. THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ARE COMMONSENSE
FIRST WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
DELETE THE MODIFIER ORGANIZED
FROM THE DEFINITION OF A
CRIMINAL STREET GANG. THE
CURRENT DEFINITION AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS TECHNICAL
IT IS PRECISE AND IT'S PROBABLY
ONLY SOMETHING THAT A LAWYER
WOULD APPRECIATE BUT WHAT I
WOULD SUBMIT TO THIS COMMITTEE
IS THAT THE PEOPLE MUST PROVE
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT. THAT
A GAME IS A ORGANIZATION GROUP
OR ASSOCIATION WITH THREE OR
MORE MEMBERS WITH A COMMON SIGN
OR SYMBOL WHO HAVE AS THEIR
PRIMARY ACTIVITIES. FOR LOANING
US CONDUCT THESE FELONIES
INCLUDING MURDER ROBBERY
KIDNAPPING EXTORTION VIOLENT.
THAT ARE COMMITTED. I MERRILY
WITHIN THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES.
ORGANIZED CHANGES THAT STANDARD
BECAUSE GANGS ARE NOT ALWAYS
ORGANIZED THEY MAY EVEN MAKE
KIND OF QUALIFY AS AN
ORGANIZATION ASSOCIATION OR
GROUP BUT TO REQUIRE THIS HIRE-
HURDLE FOR THE PROSECUTOR TO BE
ABLE TO PROVE THAT THE GANG
ITSELF IS ORGANIZED SIMPLY IS
NOT REFLECTED IN THE REALITY OF
HOW GAINES CONDUCT THEIR
BUSINESS. IF YOU DELETE THAT
TERM THEN WE CAN TURN TO THE
SECOND A PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO
DELETE. THIS REQUIREMENT THAT
THE COMMON BENEFIT OF A
PREDICATE OFFENCE BE MORE THAN
REPUTATIONAL. IF THE IF THAT
LANGUAGE IS DELETED THEN OUR
OPPOSITION CAN SHIFT TO NEUTRAL
AND WE WENT COLD WE WOULD IN
KOREA IN COURAGE. OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS TO DO THE
SAME THE REASON WHY WE
SUGGESTING THIRD THAT THIS MORE
THAN REPUTATIONAL BENEFIT
LANGUAGE NEEDS TO BE DELETED IS
BECAUSE- INCREASING A GANG'S
REPUTATION FOR VIOLENCE IS THE
PRIMARY MOTIVATION OF MOST GANG
CRIME. THE AUTHOR HAS USED THE
EXAMPLE OF AN ELDERLY
INDIVIDUAL WHO MAY BE JAY
WALKING AND GETTING ENHANCEMENT
IS GOING TO BE OUT LATE AGAINST.
BUT THERE SIMPLY IS NOT BASED
IN REALITY. REALISTICALLY THE
VAST MAJORITY OF GANG
ENHANCEMENTS ARE LEVIED AGAINST
VIOLENT CRIMINALS INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE COMMITTED A CURRENT
OFFENSE INVOLVING VIOLENCE. END
THEIR MEMBERSHIP REFLECTS A
ASSOCIATION WITH A GROUP THAT
HAS ENGAGED IN VIOLENCE AS WELL.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THESE TWO
AMENDMENTS AND AGAIN WE COMMIT
TO SHIFTING OUR OPPOSITION TO
NEUTRAL IF THEY ARE TAKEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
OWENS AND WE ALSO HAVE A SECOND
OPPOSITION WITNESS- RYAN
SHERMAN IS THE ON THE LINE.
PLANT MANAGER THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING RIGHT SURE MODES OF
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION AND
ALSO REPRESENTING. POLICE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION THE
PALESTINIANS UPLAND INVALID
CORONA NEWPORT BEACH. KALHANA
ARCADIA. FULLER CHEN AMONA-
BANK REVERSAL COVERS. LOS
ANGELES SCHOOL THE FUTURE CAL
COALITION THANK YOU
PROFESSIONALS AND FIVE GONNA
GET THE SHERIFF THE- ALL OF
JOHN. A THREE THREE WHICH WAS
ENDING THE PUBLIC BY READ LIKE
OF SENTENCE FOR VIOLENT GANG
MEMBERS WE WITH THE COMMENTS
SHARE BY COLLEAGUES IN DIEGO
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. REGARDING
THE CHALLENGE TO SECURING FOR
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT GANG RELATED
CRIMES AB THREE THREE THREE
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. MORE TO COME
BECOME LAW. THREE CLEAR TO US
AB THREE THREE THREE. DISREGARD
THE LIVES OF CRYING AT THE THAT
WOULD. AND THE- LIVES CUT SHORT
AGAIN. GET END GANG MEMBERS TO
BILL A NAME.OR TO INCREASE THE
GAME REPEAT. GROW A THREE THREE
THREE DOES SIX PROTECT THE BLUE
BROWN IMMIGRANT. THE TERM
FREQUENTLY THE TARGET. AGAIN BY.
INSTEAD AB THREE THREE THREE
ATTEMPTS TO PORTRAY HARDING
VIOLENT GANG MEMBERS OF THE
REAL VICTIMS IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM SH THE FINDINGS
AND DECLARATIONS OF THE BILL
MAKE THIS CLEAR SH THIS BILL
SAYS A GANG ENHANCEMENTS DON'T
REDUCE CRIME OR VIOLENCE. THIS
IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE EVERY DAY
THAT THESE CONVICTED GANG
MEMBERS ARE PRESENT ANOTHER DAY
THEY CAN'T VICTIMIZE THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT ARE
MOST OFTEN TARGETED BY THESE
GANGS. AB THREE TWO THREE THANK
ST THE CURRENT GANG
ENHANCEMENTS. CRIMINALIZED
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES. AND WE KNOW
THIS IS JUST PATENTLY FALSE.
SHE HAS NO CRIMINAL RECORDS
JANE HANSEN'S CRIMINALIZED GAME
NUMBERS WHO COMMIT CRIMES
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE.
AB THREE THREE THREE ALSO
CLAIMS HI GAIL HANSEN EVIDENCE
CAN BE UNRELIABLE AND
PREJUDICIAL. HOWEVER IF THE
EVIDENCE IS UNRELIABLE OR
PREJUDICIAL JUDICIAL DISCRETION.
AB EXERCISE REGARDING ENGINES
ARE SHOWN AND I HAVE TO ASK YOU
TO CLOSE UP. OKAY AS WE'RE
ALREADY- YES- JUST BRIEFLY-
WHAT I'LL CONCLUDE THE HARMFUL
EDUCATION WAS OPENED EARLY
RELEASE CURRENTLY INCARCERATED
VIOLENT GANG MEMBERS OR DO SEEM
OUT OF PRISON TIME FOR
CONVICTED GANG MEMBERS IN THE
FUTURE. SHE BECAME MEMBERS
SHOULD BE THE VERY LAST GROUP
OF VIOLENT JONES TO GET ANY
TYPE OF BREAK ON THEIR
SENTENCES AND FOR THESE REASONS
WE REMAIN. STRONGLY OPPOSED AB
THREE THREE THREE. WE REQUEST A
NUMBER. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SHERMAN FIRED FOR TO
TODAY AND MISTER OWENS WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO A ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THREE THREE
THREE. SEEING WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WILLING TO TESTIFY
THE AT THE TELECONFERENCES.
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE THREE THREE WILL BEGIN
AND IF YOU WOULD AT THE RIGHT
CORRECT TIME LET US KNOW HOW
MANY WITH PEOPLE WE DO HAVE ON
LINE. THANK YOU AND IT IS
BEACON OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
THREE LINES INTO AT THIS TIME
WE WILL FIRST GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN AND I WANT TO
CORRECT THAT WE HAVE TEN LINES
IN Q. ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM VICE CHAIR AND SENATORS
WHO SHAUN MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THREE THREE THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FOURTEEN. PARDON ME
WHILE I'M ONE SIXTEEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MEDEVACED YOU'RE A
NUMBER OF BRANDON UP ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK. OR
WITH. LINE. ONE FOURTEEN. GOOD
MORNING LIEUTENANT SO LATE THAT
WILLIAM SAMBAR TO DINO SHERIFF
DEPARTMENT ON BEHALF BUT YOU'RE
LIKE MAN RESPECTFULLY AND
OPPOSITION. PINE ONE OH FIVE.
GOOD MORNING JIM KERBER ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGANS AGAINST
CRIME AND OPPOSITION AB THREE
THREE THREE THANK YOU. PINE.
SIXTY TWO. NINE SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE ONE EIGHTEEN GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SORRY BRONFMAN
ESCAMBIA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. NINE FORTY SIX.
STEPHANIE LAMBERT WITH CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED AMBER IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF AB. THREE THREE
THREE. NINE ONE TWENTY FIVE.
MICHELLE CANNOT BE PRESIDENT OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES THE
COUNTY ALSO KNOWN AS THE GANG
CAPITAL OF THE NATION WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY THREE
THIRTY THREE WHICH UNDERMINES
OUR ABILITY TO COMBAT GANG
VIOLENCE THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE THIRTY ONE. YES THIS
CURRENT MEMBERS LARRY MORRIS-
BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION- WE
RESPECT AND APPRECIATE- SENATOR
CALM WATERS- ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS- WITH US AND- THE
OTHER OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL-
AT THIS TIME HOWEVER WE REMAIN
OPPOSED. LINE. ONE TWENTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING LAURIE HOT FROM
THE SAN DIEGO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION WE ARE
STILL REMAINING OPPOSED TO THE
SPELLING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. LINE ONE OH
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING I REMEMBER
CLOUD RESIDENT WARNS COUNTY M.
STRONG OPPOSITION OF. THREE
THREE THREE. NINE ONE HUNDRED.
THE MORNING HOPING TO GIVE HER
ANGER RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND STRONG OPPOSITION
WITHOUT THE AMENDMENT CHANGES
THAT'S REQUESTED THANK YOU. IF
THERE ANY OTHER VOICES IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I'M SURE WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS TO IT ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON AB THREE THREE
EIGHT. THREE SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU CHAIR. I WILL MOVE
THE BILL. AND- THIRD QUARTER
YOU DID A GOOD OPENING HOURS
THANK YOU KNOW VARIOUS
QUESTIONS I COULD ASK YOU THAT
COULD HELP REFUTE THE ARMED
OPPOSITION'S COMMENTS BUT I
HOPE YOU'LL DO SO IN THE
CLOTHES RATHER THAN MY TRYING
TO CONSTRUCT QUESTIONS RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE AS I HEARD IT.
THERE WAS- BASICALLY THAT-
THINGS LIKE- THAT WE NEED THESE
GANG ENHANCEMENTS TO- IN FACT I
WILL INTERPRET FURTHER PUNISH
FOLKS. AND THEN THE NATURE OF
THE VIOLENT CRIMES. AND I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO GET AT IS
THAT WE THIS DOES NOT IMPACT AT
ALL THE BASIC SENSE OF THE
VIOLENCE AGAINST ON THE VIOLENT
CRIMES AND IT STILL ALLOWS THE
PERSON TO BE CONVICTED OF A
VIOLENT CRIME THAT THEY MAY
HAVE COMMITTED. AN ARMED AND-
AND ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES GET
THE HIGHEST SENTENCE FOR
DATABASE CURRENT. IN CALIFORNIA
JUST IF WE IN EVEN ELIMINATING
OUR ENHANCEMENTS THINKING
HANSON'S INSECT RB SENSES ARE
ALREADY LONGER THAN MOST OTHER
STATES. INTERESTINGLY WE HAVE
A- FIVE IF WE COMPARE OURSELVES
EVEN THE TEXAS RB SENSES ARE
LONGER IN MOST CASES IN MOST OF
OUR CRIME CATEGORIES AS BAY
CENSUS BEN EVEN STATES LIKE
TEXAS OKLAHOMA VERY SUTHERS
THAT SOME PEOPLE FEEL ARE YOU
KNOW THAT COULD NOT BE
CHARACTERIZED AS SOFT ON CRIME.
SO I SEE WHAT YOU ARE DOING AS
TRYING TO CORRECT. A IS NOT TO
TRY TO ELIMINATE. THE
CONSEQUENCE FOR SOMEONE WHO
ENGAGES IN A VIOLENT ACT BUT
RATHER TRYING TO ELIMINATE
THOSE THINGS THAT ARE. AND THIS
IS WHERE THE OPPOSITION WOULD
OF COURSE DISAGREE WITH ME BUT
ARE SOMEWHAT SUBJECTIVE WE KNOW
AND I'VE BEEN PART OF MANY-
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON THIS
QUESTION. OF HOW WE DEFINE. I'M
GETTING. A PARTICIPATION AND
HOW YOU CAN HAVE A GAMING
ASSOCIATION PUT ON YOU YOU CAN
HAVE A SIBLING WHO IS SEEKING
MEMBERS YOU MAY NOT BE A GANG
MEMBER AT ALL. YET BY
ASSOCIATION YOU ARE BRANDED
WITH THIS. AND WE EVEN HAD A
CIRCUMSTANCE FOR MANY YEARS
WE'RE IN OUR HIGH SECURITY
POSITION AFTER PRISON IN
PELICAN BAY. THAT BRANDING OF
THE GANG ASSOCIATION COULD PUT
YOU IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT FOR
YEARS. DAND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
WELL THERE ARE GAMES THAT ARE
DOMINATED BY CAUCASIAN MEMBERS
IS RARE TO NEVER THAT A PERSON
BEING SENTENCED TO
RECIPROCATION GETS THE GANG
AFFILIATION SO I SEE YOUR BILL
AS TRYING TO CORRECT SOME OF
THESE ARE IN EFFECT BASIC
PROBLEMS WITH OUR SENTENCING
SCHEMES AND NOT TRYING TO
REDUCE THE CONSEQUENCE TO
SOMEONE WHO ENGAGES IN A
VIOLENT CRIME. AND THAT'S WHY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I
HOPE THAT YOU WILL- EVEN BETTER
THAN I ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNS IN YOUR CLOTHES. OTHER
DO SO QUESTIONS OR COMMENT BY.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I TOO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS WHAT REALLY
WAS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE AND
I THINK I WAS OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM. OAKLAND CLEARLY STATED
ISSUES A AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
BROWN KID SIMPLY LIVE IN THE
WRONG NEIGHBORHOOD TO. GET TO
TAG OF GANG MEMBERS AND I NEVER
GIVEN THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF. THEIR ZIP
CODE OR HE CANONIC STATUS SO I
THINK HE WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE
IS TRYING TO CLARIFY AND MAKE
SURE THAT. ONE IS NOT. LABELED
AND BRANDED IN SOMETIMES
CURIOUS. THAT LABEL FOR LIFE
AND- SILVA I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE AND I. AT THE
PROPER TIME WITH. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS. BILL WE DO HAVE A MOTION
TO. AT THIS PINT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES CHAIR THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- COMMENTS SENATOR SKINNER-
I WILL TRY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION IN MY CLOTHES AS
WELL. HERE NO ONE WANTS TO OR
IS PUTTING FORTH A BILL THAT
SUPPORTS GANGS. I DON'T SUPPORT
GANGS. A FAMILY FRIEND OF MINE
WAS KILLED TWO MONTHS AGO BY A
GANG. AND LET A GANG MEMBER AND
BLED OUT IN HIS HOUSE IN
COMPTON FOR TEN HOURS. THIS IS
NOT ABOUT GANG MEMBERS BEING
VICTIMS. THIS IS ABOUT EVERY
ONE. REGARDLESS OF YOUR RACE OR
CREED DESERVING DUE PROCESS
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE FIGHTING
FOR. EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE
RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW FOR DUE
PROCESS IF YOU COMMIT A CRIME.
PRUE AND YOU ARE CHARGED WITH A
CRIME. THIS BILL IS ASKING THAT
YOU PROVE THOSE CHARGES. BEYOND
A REASONABLE DOUBT AND
CURRENTLY OUR SYSTEM SAYS YOU
GET A PASS. IF YOU ATTACH A
GANG ALLEGATION. IT BECOMES A
CATCH ALL FOR ALL KINDS OF
ALLEGED CRIMES IN PARTICULAR
NEIGHBORHOODS. GETTING AXED
BIRDS ARE NOT GETTING EXPERTS.
VICTIMS OF THE CRIMES ARE GANG
EXPERTS. GETTING EXPERTS ARE
OFTENTIMES POLICE OFFICERS WHO
WORKED PATROL WHO SCROLL THE
INTERNET AND WHO KNOW HOW TO
USE THE JARGON AT THE RIGHT
TIME IN FRONT OF THE RIGHT
AUDIENCE TO SCARE PEOPLE BACK
INTO THE ORIGINAL A NATIONAL
IMAGE THAT WE ALL HAVE IN OUR
HEADS UP WHO WOULD GANG MEMBER
IS. THIS IS ABOUT BIFURCATING
CHARGES. IF I CHARGE YOU WITH
SOMETHING WITH ANYTHING. YOU
SHOULD DEMAND THAT I PROVE IT
THAT'S ALL THIS BILL SAYS JUST
PROVE IT BECAUSE THE GANG
ALLEGATION CARRIES FIFTEEN
YEARS FIFTEEN YEARS YOU PUT
SOMEBODY AWAY. BUT CALLING.
WELL FEES SINCE. AND WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS YOU TO GET
AWAY WITH THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
SHAME ON ANYONE WHO SAYS. THAT
THESE GAMES ARE NOT ORGANIZED.
THEY'RE NOT JUST FOOD GROUPS OF
PEOPLE WHO POP IN AND OUT. AND
COME UP WITH LIKE WELL
DESIGNED. ACTS OF VIOLENCE TO
COMMENCE. THERE ORGANIZATIONS
OF PEOPLE. WHO KNOW HOW TO
COMMUNICATE. WHO KNOW HOW TO
STRATEGIZE WHO KNOW HOW TO PAY
IT. YOU KNOW HOW TO MANAGE
PEOPLE. AND MAYBE KNOW HOW TO
EVADE THEIR ORGANIZED. YOU CAN
PROVE IT. IF YOU CAN PROVE ALL
THESE OTHER THINGS GOING ON IN
OUR COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES YOU
CAN PROVE THAT TO. AND IF
YOU'RE GOING TO CHARGE SOMEONE
WITH BEING IN A GANG. CALL
MAYBE IT AGAIN. SEPARATE THE
CHARGE THAT'S ALL. PROVE THAT
THEY DID WHATEVER THEY DID. BUT
IT'S NOT FAIR TO SAY. I GET AN
ADDITIONAL NINE YEARS FOR
STEALING A BEER. BECAUSE AT ONE
POINT I WAS IN A GANG OR MAYBE
BECAUSE TODAY I'M IN THE GAME
BUT I DIDN'T DO IT FOR THE GAME.
I DID IT BECAUSE I MADE A BAD
DECISION BECAUSE I'M STUPID
BECAUSE I WAS AIR AGAINST.
THAT'S DIFFERENT. AND THEN THE
OPPOSITION WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
KNOWS KNOWS THAT JURIES LEAN
INTERFERE. BECAUSE NO ONE WANTS
TO SAY I SUPPORTED GANG THIS IS
NOT THIS IS NOT ABOUT THAT
HONESTLY. AND IN MY DAYS AND
NIGHTS WORKING ON THIS BILL I
WISH IT WASN'T ABOUT THIS GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT WE'VE DEMONIZED
BECAUSE FIGHTING FOR DUE
PROCESS SHOULDN'T BE THIS HARD.
I AM CONTINUED. WAITING TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION. TO HELP
THEM SEE WE WILL AGREE TO
DISAGREE ON CERTAIN
FUNDAMENTALS I GUESS ABOUT WHO
DESERVES RIGHTS. BUT I DON'T
JUST BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE YOU.
AND JUST BECAUSE I'M SCARED OF
YOU. DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU
DON'T DESERVE THE SAME RIGHTS
THAT I DO AND THAT IS ALL THIS
BILL SAYS. AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
MY EMOTION. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. WE HAVE
A MOTION TO DO PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COUNTERMANDED. AS AMENDED AS
AMENDED- COUNCIL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON AB THREE THREE
THREE AB THREE THREE THREE PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I'D CHOI
BOGUE NOW TROUBLED NO COMMAGER
COMMA- I SKINNER SKINNER AYE
WIENER. THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR UP TO MEMBER NOW WILL MOVE
ON TO YOUR DOCTOR FALL I DON'T
KNOW I MEAN I THINK IT'S- AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX BY. A
CERTAIN NUMBER BY OUR BAR QUE
HAN. BECAUSE WORKING THERE.
THANK YOU MISTER TURN NUMBERS
AND- I WISH TO APOLOGIZE FOR
HER MOTIONS. IT'S AN HONOR TO
FOLLOW HER AND A PASSION. FOR
THIS COMMITTEE FOR JEFF. I HAVE
BEEN PREGNANT THREE TIMES NOT
ONE OF MY THREE PREGNANCIES
WITH SIMPLE. ONE OF THEM I WAS
SO SICK THAT I ALMOST DIED AND
I HAD TO SEEK MEDICAL CARE TO
SAVE MY LIFE. EVERY TIME THEY
CAME IN WIH A MEDICAL
INTERVENTION. I'D SAY TO MY
DOCTOR WHAT IS GOING TO DO THE
FETUS. AND EVERY TIME THE
ANSWER WAS WE DON'T KNOW BUT WE
HAVE TO SAVE YOUR LIFE. AND I
WOULD CONSENT. AND WHEN I WAS
WELL ENOUGH TO ACTUALLY PAY
ATTENTION TO THE FACT THAT I
WAS STILL PREGNANT. I WENT TO
MY DOCTOR. I WALKED IN
PRIVATELY. I HAD A CONVERSATION
ONE ON ONE WITH MY PHYSICIAN
ABOUT MY CHOICES. SHE HELD MY
HAND SHE SAID WE WOULD GET
THROUGH IT TOGETHER. I LEFT.
NOBODY KNEW THAT HAPPENED HIPPA
PROTECTED ME AND MY PRIVACY.
BUT I'M A WHITE WOMAN OF
PRIVILEGE. AND I HAD EMPLOYER
BASED HEALTH CARE. TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE STATE
WOMEN WILL GO AND SEEK THAT
SAME HEALTH CARE PREDOMINANTLY
WOMEN OF COLOR PREDOMINATELY
UNDER INSURED AND UNINSURED
WOMEN AND THEY WILL NOT GET THE
SAME RIGHTS THAT I HAD THAT DAY.
THEY WILL BE HARASSED AND YELL
THAT THEY MAY BE CHASED. THEY
WILL HAVE THEIR PHOTOGRAPHS
TAKEN POSTED ON THE INTERNET.
THEIR PRIVACY WILL NOT BE
INTACT WHEN THEY LEAVE THAT
APPOINTMENT THEIR DIGNITY WILL
NOT BE INTACT WHEN THEY LEAVE
THAT APPOINTMENT. IN FACT IN
EQUITY IS WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY MEMBERS. THIS
COMMITTEE FOCUSES AS YOU JUST
DID IN THE BILL THAT WAS HEARD
BEFORE THIS ONE SO DEEPLY ON
THE INEQUITIES IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AS WE SHOULD.
AND TODAY WHAT I ASK YOU TO
LOOK AT IS THE INEQUITY HERE
FOR THE VICTIMS. CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA IF YOU VICTIMIZE
THAT DOG THEY ARE MORE
PROTECTED THAN THESE WOMEN. AND
SO WHAT I AM ASKING YOU TO DO
IS HARD I'M ASKING YOU DO SOME
THINGS THIS COMMITTEE RARELY IF
EVER DOES. WHICH IS ENHANCE THE
PENALTIES ON THESE CRIMES. BUT
I'M ASKING YOU TO DO IT BECAUSE
WE HAVE WOMEN THAT ARE BEING
DENIED THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT. TO WALK INTO THESE
CLINICS AND GET THE HEALTH CARE
THAT THEY ARE ENTITLED TO
BECAUSE THEY TURN AWAY BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID AND IT IS OUR
JOB TO PROTECT THEM WE ARE A
STATE THAT STANDS AND SAYS WE
WILL ALWAYS PROTECT A WOMAN'S
RIGHT TO CHOOSE. BUT THAT
DOESN'T JUST MEAN THAT WOMEN
HAVE A LEGAL RIGHT TO AN
ABORTION IT MEANS ENSURING
THEIR SAFETY SECURITY AND
DIGNITY WHEN THEY WALK IN TO
SEE THEIR HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
AND THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL
DOES. ANY DOES IT IN A NUMBER
OF WAYS IT ENSURES THAT OUR
POLICE ARE TRAINED IT ENSURES
THAT WE HAVE THE LAWS THERE TO
ENFORCE TO ENSURE THAT THESE
WOMEN ARE NOT VICTIMIZED WHEN
SEEKING THEIR HEALTHCARE. AND
THE PROBLEM IS ONLY GETTING
WORSE AND SO I KNOW I'M ASKING
THIS COMMITTEE DO SOMETHING
HARD TODAY. BUT I THINK IT IS
SO CRITICAL TO THE WORK THAT WE
DO WITH THE LEGISLATURE. TO
PROTECT THE WOMEN. NEED THESE
RIGHTS AND THEY NEED OUR
PROTECTION AND THAT'S WHY I'M
HERE ASKING FOR THIS. AND WITH
THAT I WILL TURN IT OVER TO MY
WITNESSES. I BELIEVE WE HAVE
MISTAKES HERE FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND- SOMEONE ON THE
LINE AS WELL FROM PPL WAY
MICHELLE SEMANSKY DIRECTOR OF
SAFETY FROM CAMPAIGNER MARTY.
GOOD MORNING I REMEMBER. FOR
THE RECORD BREAKING TRANSPARENT
MARMONT HERE IN THE CORNER OF
AB ONE THREE FIVE THANK. YOU
FOR SENATE. ATTACK AND HARASSED
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND ABORTION
FOR DECADES. PROTEST NUMBER
OUTSIDE PPM AND HELPCENTER
CALLING CREEK DRAMATICALLY IN
RECENT MONTHS IN JANUARY WE
DOCUMENTED TWO HUNDRED FORTY
THREE PROTESTERS AND FEBRUARY
THERE WERE SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO AND IN MARCH THERE
ARE. ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE PROTESTERS. THE
RECENT PROTESTS PACKED THANK A
AND DESIGN. TO INTIMIDATE
PROTESTERS BLIND SIDEWALKS AND
BIKE LARGE GRASS DESIGN A
GAUNTLET THROUGH WHICH- MUST
WALK OR DO I GARDAI
APPOINTMENTS THE CHASE DOWN. TO
GET THEM TO AND GREEN PEOPLE
AND THEY ENTER THE- TELLING
PATIENTS THEY ARE MY- AND BATH
THAT PAYCHECKS ARE IN BLOOD.
THEY EVEN PUT FIND YOUR THAT
THEY THE CLINIC IS CLOSE
INTERNET TO PATIENTS. AFTER
FOUR BY CAMERAS BUSINESS. THANK
YOU. BURKE SET UP I'M TRY. DOWN
PATIENT AND STAFF AND THAT
BANNER. IN APRIL I DOCTOR
PROTECTED HAD SET UP A
CHARACTER AT THE LOT DON'T HER
PARKING AND ENTERING A BUILDING.
AND MARK. AND PATIENTS WHO INTO
A FELLOW. STARTED YOU BEING
COME BACK. THAT WAS THE THEY
WERE POSTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA
TELLING PEOPLE SHE HAD GONE TO
PLAN PARENTHOOD BURNER. SHE
ASKED THE PROJECT THE STOCK
SELLING BUT THEY. CARDCAPTOR
OFTEN HAD THEIR LOOK AND AT THE
CENTER PLAN PARA HELPED AND CO
PICTURES AND VIDEOS OKAY. TAP
ON THE MEDIA. WELL BEING FOUND
ARE NOT AS FOR BERMAN AND HAVE
NO. OVER HOW PERSONAL IN ARE
YOU. ARE PAYING AND STAFF A
RIGHT PRIVACY AT OUR HOUSE
CENTERS AND THEY SHOULD BE FREE
OF THE- AND SCARE TACTICS. FOR
THE THREE I ARE YOU SUPPORT ON
A ONE FIVE THANK AND THAT
THEY'LL GO FOR QUESTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
WITNESS. HI CHIU HICKS
PRESIDENT CEO PLAN OF COLOR. MY
LATEST TO AND I ARE HERE TO
ALSO ANSWER BUT JUST WANT.
BRIEFLY TO ON WHO WERE TALK
ABOUT AND SPUR. THE PROTESTERS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OVER.
EXTREME THE OVERLAP BETWEEN THE
PROTESTERS THAT WE FACE AS WE
CALL THEM PROTESTERS THERE
REALLY SOMETIMES TERRORIST
ACTIVITY- THE OVERLAP BETWEEN
THE WHITE SUPREMACIST GROUPS
AND OTHER TERRORIST GROUPS HAS
BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED. ON THE
TYPE OF ACTIVITIES THAT THAT
OUR PATIENTS AND WORKERS ARE
FACING WE HAVE A HUNDRED NAY
HEALTH CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THE PATIENTS THAT WE
SERVE OVER 85% ARE ON MEDICAID
AND THE UNINSURED LARGELY
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND LARGELY
YOUNG WOMEN- THE WORK FORCE
THAT ARE ALSO BEING HARASSED
COME FROM THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
ARE LARGELY PEOPLE OF COLOR.
WHEN WE CALL THE POLICE WE GET
BEARING- NEED- RESPONSES AND SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
UPDATE BOTH POLICE TRAINING BUT
ALSO. HAVE SOMETHING THAT IS A
DETERRENT FOR THIS ACTIVITY TO
STOP BECAUSE IT'S A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE WITH THE GOAL FOR
THEM IS TOO INTIMIDATED
PATIENTS THEY DON'T WALK
THROUGH OUR DOORS. OR TO DO
THINGS LIKE BOMB THREATS OR THE
ACTIVITY IS ESCALATED SUCH THAT
WE HAVE TO SHUT DOWN FOR THAT
DAY. THAT'S THE WIN FOR THEM
AND THAT BECOMES A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISES FOR THAT
COMMUNITY SO WE REALLY THINK OF
THIS AS A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE.
I WANT TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON. THE BEST WAY TO
STOP THIS ACTIVITIES WE CAN
CONTINUE SERVE THE PATIENTS
MOST NEED. OUR HEALTH CENTER SO
THE ONLY PLACE THAT THEY HAVE
TO GO. OVER HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOW WILL MOVE
JUST TWO MEMBERS HERE AND THE
CHAMBER WHO MIGHT BE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB. THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX. THERE'S NO ONE THERE IS A
WALL MODERATE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO FIRST TO LINE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BILLION
NOTHING BURKE ON BEHALF OF NAY
ROUTE PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. BY. NINETY THREE.
BRANCH MANAGER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT. BY
NINETY NINE. GOOD MORNING WITH.
MY NAME IS KATRINA CANTRELL I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
WOMEN'S HEALTH SPECIALISTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE THREE FIVE
SIX- I AM WE ARE A REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CLINIC IN CHICO READING
AND GRASS VALLEY WE HAVE BEEN
BUSY BY PROTESTERS WERE NOW
FORTY FIVE YEARS IN OUR CLINIC
IN THE FARTHEST WORLD PART OF
CALIFORNIA IN REDDING
CALIFORNIA WAS FIRE BOMBED FOUR
TIMES WE HAD TO GET YOUR
DEFICIT IN TACT. ECHO
CALIFORNIA AND WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE VANDALISM HARASSMENT AND
REALLY NEED TO- HAVE- DRASTIC
OVERSIGHT OF THE ON GOING-
HARASSMENT THAT CONTINUES TO
THIS DAY- AGAINST CLIENTS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AGAIN. AT TRIAL OF
THE BORDER AB THREE BY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU THE CLIP WE
THIS NAME OR- POSITION. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR. NOW WILL
MOVE AND TURN TOWARD OUR
MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION I SEE WE
HAVE ONE PRIMARY WITNESS A
MATTHEW MCREYNOLDS. AND
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX OUR- MODERATOR IF HE'S
READY WILL ALLOW HIM TO TESTIFY
AT THIS POINT KILL OUT THREE
MANAGE. THANK YOU YOUR YOUR
TOTAL AGREEMENT SUBMIT MINIMAP
THIS ALSO A LESLIE CALDWELL
HOUSTON AS WELL OKAY. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING THAT SHARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MATTHEW
MCREYNOLDS SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH THE PACIFIC
JUSTICE INSTITUTE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC POLICY- IN OPPOSITION I
WANT TO FIRST SAY WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
DONE IN PRIOR COMMISSION DONE.
TO REDUCE THE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL- THOSE
EFFORTS TO BAN- IMPORTANT BUT
THERE'S STILL A LONG WAY TO GO
AND WE'RE CONVINCED THAT THE
BILL IS BASED ON A FLAWED
PREMISE CONSTITUTIONALLY AND
THAT IS THAT HARASSMENT
INTIMIDATION. IS ONLY GOES ONE
DIRECTION IN THE ABORTION
DEBATE AND IF YOU READ
CAREFULLY THE TEXT OF THE BILL
YOU'LL SEE A FOCUS SOLELY ON
ANTI REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS CRIMES
YOU'LL SEE LIMITATIONS. ONLY ON
THOSE WHO WERE OUTSIDE OF
ABORTION CLINICS IN NOTHING IN
REGARDS TO THE HARASSMENT AND
INTIMIDATION AND EVEN PHYSICAL
ASSAULTS THAT ARE PERPETRATED
BY BY CLINIC STAFF IN BY OTHERS
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
ABORTION DEBATE TOWARD- DOES ON
THE SIDEWALKS INCLUDING NOT
ONLY SIDEWALK COUNSELORS BUT
PRIESTS AND NUNS. THAT MAKES
THIS AID AND GREGIS LEE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILL AWAITING
IT PROVIDES A STRONG DEFENSE TO
ANYONE WHO'S GOING TO BE
ACTUALLY CHARGED UNDER THIS
BOTH FACIALLY AND AS PPLIED WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO LOOK PAST
THE STRONG EMOTIONS OF THE BILL
IN CAREFULLY CONSIDER. THE
CONSTITUTIONAL IMPLICATIONS AND
THE DISPARITY THE INEQUITY
BETWEEN TREATMENT OF THOSE ON
ONE SIDE OF THE BAY VERSUS THE
OTHER- RENDER THIS RENDERS
MEASURE INVALID IN SO FOR THOSE
AND MANY OTHER REASONS. WE
URGED THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE NOW.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU THIS IS LESLIE CALDWELL
HUGHES IN. CAN YOU HEAR ME HI
JUST FINE. OKAY THANK YOU I'M
SORRY- LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION WHILE I'M
PERSONALLY HORRIFIED BY THE
BEHAVIOR THAT'S DESCRIBED BY
THE PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL. WE.
I'M SORRY I'M VERY MOVED BY IT
HOWEVER THE LAW IN THIS AREA
ALREADY EXIST AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX SIX TO INCREASE THE
PENALTIES BY INCREASING
INCARCERATION TIME MAKING THE
OFFENDERS ELIGIBLE FOR PRISON
SENTENCES AND LAKE WOULD MAKE
THOSE CONVICTED LIFELONG FELONS
WE KNOW THIS DOES WORK CURRENT
LAW PROVIDES FOR PUNISHMENT UP
TO SIX MONTHS OR ONE YEAR IN
JAIL DEPENDING ON THE EXTENT.
SIZEABLE FINES ARE ALSO CURRENT
PUNISHMENT AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX WOULD MAKE THE OFFENSE'S
POTENTIAL FELONIES WITH UP TO
THREE YEARS IN PRISON OR JAIL
GPD A STRONGLY SUPPORTS
MEMBERSHIP IS MADE UP OF
CRIMINAL DEFENSE PRACTITIONERS
WHO PASSIONATELY DEVOTE
THEMSELVES TO PROTECTING THE
RIGHTS OF OUR CLIENTS ACROSS
THE STATE EVERY DAY WELL WE
WOULD LIKE TO APPLY TO ANY
EFFORT TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES RIGHT AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX IT MISGUIDED AND BAD
PUBLIC POLICY TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITY THERE IS NO NEED TO
FURTHER CRIMINALIZE AND
INCARCERATE. ANYONE VIOLATING
THESE LAWS CAN BE APPROPRIATELY
PUNISHED CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
NEED TO MAKE MORE PEOPLE FELONS
AND INCARCERATE THEM IN OUR
PRISONS FOR NONVIOLENT OFFENSES
WELL INTENTIONED BUT FLAWED
CRIMINAL WAS OR HOW CALIFORNIA
BECAME THE STATE WITH THE
HIGHEST INCARCERATION RATE
AMONG DEVELOPED NATIONS
MOREOVER AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
IS UNNECESSARY ANY ACTIVITY OF
COVERED BY AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX THAT IS VIOLENT IS
PUNISHABLE BY A NUMBER OF
ALREADY EXISTING ASSAULT AND
BATTERY CRIMES. BECAUSE THEY BE
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX IS NOT IN
THE PUBLIC INTEREST WE URGE.
YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW WILL BRING ABOUT TO.
OUR COMMITTEE ROOM IS- IN HERE.
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX YEAR AND FORTY TWO OR THREE.
SHINO ONE MOVEMENT- WILL NOW GO
TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM A TWENTY
FORTY. THERE'S NO ONE THERE IS
WALL. MODERATOR NOW WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AND SEE IF
THERE ARE CALLERS WHO ARE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX NOW TO TALK. READ TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL
FIRST GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY ONE
THREE ZERO GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KING WHEN DEAN ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO MARKHAM AND IT.
WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE ONE TEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
GLORIA DURAN AND I'M IN TURN
WITH THE RIGHT TO LIFE WEEK OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
OPPOSE AB. THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX.
BY IN ONE FORTY THREE. MY NAME
IS SUSAN ARNOLD I'M AN ATTORNEY
WITH THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE FORTY SIX.
MY NAME IS KRISTEN TURNER I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR LIKE
SAN FRANCISCO AND WE OPPOSE AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX IN MY TWO
YEARS OF PEACEFULLY OFFERING
ALTERNATIVES OUTSIDE OF THE
WOMEN'S HEALTH SPECIALISTS AND
READING I WOULDN'T KNOW
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR COME COLLECT
NUMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY BUT I
HAVE TO THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
ON YOUR- BY NINETY SIX. HI MY
NAME IS AMY I'M CALLING FROM
MODESTO AND I RESPECTFULLY AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
ROBERT BYRD AND I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH PRO LIFE SAN
FRANCISCO AND I STRONGLY URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON AB. THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX. ONE ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
MY NAME IS TO MICAH AND THE
RESIDENT ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE THREE
FIVE SIX THANK YOU. BY. ONE
FORTY ONE. HI THERE MY NAME IS
RUNNING YOU JUSTIN I'M A TO A
LAW STUDENT DOWN HERE IN
VENTURA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BLATANTLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL
LAW- ONLY TWO YEARS AND I CAN
ALREADY SEE THAT THIS IS JUST A
COMPLETELY UNCONSTITUTIONAL
MARC RIDICULOUS AND- I STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
FORTY NINE. NINE ONE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS ARLENE AND HER LAST A STATE
PRESIDENT OF EAGLE FORUM AT
CALIFORNIA ALL OF OUR MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
CENTURY TO VOTE AGAINST IT.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY. THIS
IS STACEY PHILLIPS AND I AM
FROM MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND I
BELIEVE THAT WOMEN IN CRISIS
PREGNANCIES APPRECIATE KNOWING
ALL OF THEIR OPTIONS AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
LINE. ONE THIRTY NINE. HI THIS
IS RICHARD PRINTEMPS CISCO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. LINE.
ONE FORTY FOUR. NINE ONE FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PINE.
ONE FORTY THREE. THIS IS SUSAN
AREN'T ALL IN THE DIRECTOR WITH
THE LIGHT RIGHT TO LIFE LEADERS
SEVEN CALIFORNIA AND WE OPPOSE
A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX. LINE
ONE FORTY FIVE. GREG BIRD FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL
DOES NOT CEMENTED. BLIND. ONE
THIRTY NINE. BY ONE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE CHECK
COMMUNICATOR. LINE. ONE FORTY
FOUR. ANY HEARING CHEN FROM SAN
DIEGO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE AND GIVE IT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. NOW WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS AS IT RELATES TO
THIS MEASURE THAT ANYONE HAS
HAD TO STOP. EVERY QUESTION
CENTERS SKINNER I GET A
CLARIFICATION OF FIVE READ THE
ANALYSIS CORRECT. BOB WEIR OR
FELONY COMES INTO PLAY AFTER
THE SECOND OFFENSE IS THAT
CORRECT. TODAY IN IN THE WAY
THE BILL'S CURRENTLY WRITTEN
ISN'T IT A MISDEMEANOR IN THE
FIRST OFFENSE BUT- B. THE
WOPULAR COMES IN THE PLAN
SECOND OFFENSE. LET ME SEE WHAT.
THAT I CAN HELP A FIFTY. DONNA.
THERE'S A FEW DIFFERENT
MODELERS ONE IS- THE CURRENT
OFFENSE IS ONE IS. CREDIT
FENCES UP TO A YEAR IN COUNTY
JAIL WHEN THERE'S INJURIES WITH
A FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE
THIS MAKES IT A WOBBLER WITH A
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE IN
SO IF THERE'S AN INJURY THEN
EVEN AND FIRST OFFENSE BECOMES
A WAFFLER YES AND THEN THERE'S
A COUPLE DIFFERENT WATERS IN
THE BILL. REPORT THE OTHER ONES
WERE A SECOND OFFENSE. LISA
READ IT'S A NEW IT'S AND THE
OTHER ONE'S A NEW OF A NEW. HI.
YEAH THERE'S A WOBBLER FOR A
SECOND OFFENSE OF. PHYSICAL
OBSTRUCTION- AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER ONE HOLD ON.
THERE'S A
WOBBLER FOR- A FIRST OFFENSE IF
YOU FOR INTIMIDATING A PERSON
OFFERING- BURKE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. FOR A SUBSEQUENT.
THE SUBSEQUENT OFFENSE IS ALSO
A WOBBLER SO THAT'S THE NEW
CRIME THAT THEY'VE CREATED.
BOTH OF THOSE ARE WATERS TWO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF VIOLATIONS.
EVEN AND FIRST OFFENSE VENTING
FIRST THE FIRST OFFENSE HAS A
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
FINE THE SECOND FUNDS HAS A
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE. BUT
BUT A DOUBLE FLOWERS HELLO SO
THE ONLY THROUGH THE WAY THE
BILL'S CONSTRUCTED NOW. THE
ONLY ONE ONLY ASPECTS THAT
BECOME FOR THAT FAR WOBBLER ST
FIRST OFFENSE R. WHERE THERE'S
AN INJURY AND THEN THE- NEW- IN
FACT THE NEW CRIME THAT IS
CREATED BY THE BILL YES. ALL
THE OTHERS ARE NOT UNTIL THE
SECOND OFFENSE. YES BUT THERE'S
PHONE YEAH THE OTHER ONE YES
THERE'S TWO THAT ARE SECOND
FUNDS ONCE. OKAY. OKAY. ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. WHAT IS THIS ARE YOU
SEE CLARITY THAT YOUR YOUR
CLARIFYING THAT WERE REMOVING
THE FELONIES FROM THE SHOWS ARE
CORRECT AND ON THE MISDEMEANOR
OF PORTION OF THE OFFERS WILL
REMAIN. FOR WHICH CRIMES MISTER.
WE HAVE DO WE HAVE SPECIFIC I
JUST THOUGHT WE WERE MOVING
FELONIES ALL TOGETHER FROM
THERE BUT ALL THE WATERS THAT I
JUST AS THE IN THE WATERS THAT
YOU JUST DESCRIBED EXACTLY AND
ONLY THAT WATER SPORTS WILL
REMAIN IN THE BILL. SO THE IS
THE TEARS ARE PRESS THAT WE
REMOVE ALL THE WHILE THERE IS
THAT THE- M. STAFF JUST
MENTIONED. THAT TURNED TO
INTERNET OKAY IF THAT'S WHAT IT
TAKES TO MOVE THE BILL FORWARD.
AM I CORRECT MA'AM COUNCIL IT
HIGHLIGHTS CITY CURRENTLY HAD
DISCUSSED YES AND THAT THIS
BILL GOES TO JUDICIARY ROSY
DIGITIZATION YOU'LL TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SO I HAVE NOT CHECKED
THE TIME WHEN WOULD YOU TO
SHERRY SO I ASSUMING THAT BUT I
CHECKED WITH IN STATE IN ORDER
TO GET IT TO THEM IN TIME
YOU'LL HAVE TO COMMIT HERE TO
TAKE BACK THAT. WILL DRAFT HIM
AND JUDICIARY CAN CROSS THEM IT
TAKES TWO DAYS TO GET AND
FRIENDS WE CROSS THEM IF THEY
CROSS IMAGE ONE DAY AGO SO IN
ORDER TO HELP THEM IT'S BETTER
FOR THEM TO COST THEM. BY THANK
YOU- YEAH RESEARCHER I MEAN IT.
OUR PREFERENCE THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH. WYLER'S BUT IF
THE CHAIRS ARE QUESTIONABLE
THEM NOT AGREE TO THE. SINNERS
CAN. ARM I NOTICED THAT THERE
IS A SUNSET IF THE BOTTLERS ARE
REMOVED DO WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE THE SUNSET. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WAS PUT
IN BY SOMEBODY PUBLIC SAFETY SO
WE CAN HAVE A DISCUSSION WITH
THEM IF THEY'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT COMING OUT FINE FOR
ME MAY. I IF I MEAN AND THAT
IT'S UP TO YOU BUT THAT DOESN'T
YEAH SO WHAT WE HAD DONE WAS
PART OF THE QUESTION WHICH I
THINK IS A QUESTION POSED BY.
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE I SAID ON THE OTHER
SIDE AS WELL AS DOES THIS WORK
RIGHT IS RAISING CRIMES
ACTUALLY DETER. AND IN MOST
CASES THE ANSWER IS CLEARLY NO
BUT THIS IS SUCH A NARROWLY
FOCUSED BILL. FOCUSED ON A
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS WHO WE
KNOW WE ONLY HAVE ESCALATING
PROBLEMS ITH THAT WHAT WE HAD
AGREED TO WAS FOR THE WHILE
OTHERS REMAIN IN FOR THREE
YEARS TO REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THEN HOPEFULLY
I'LL STILL BE HERE BUT MANY OF
US HERE THREE YEARS OVER BACK
TO PUBLIC SAFETY ACTUALLY TAKE
A LOOK AND SEE DID THIS ACHIEVE
THE GOAL WHICH WAS TO ALLOW THE
RIGHT TO. SAFE ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE BUT
THE BEST SUNSET THE QUESTION WE
WERE ASKING WAS WHETHER THE LAW
BLURS WORKED SUNSET ONLY
RELATES TO THE WATER SO I DON'T
EVEN THINK I WOULD HAVE ANY
EFFECT TO BE HONEST. WELL IF.
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY'S
CONTROL. GIVEN THAT THE AUTHOR
IS ACCEPTED THE REMOVAL OF THE
BOTTLERS AND- IF THEY DIDN'T
HAVE OBJECTION SEEMS TO ME WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THE SUNSET. WELL
I'M NOT IN POSITION TO OVERDO
IT PUBLIC SAFETY AS JOHN
PURCELL I'M JUST GONNA RESPECT
THAT PROCESS IN. AND DEAL WITH
THE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S AGAIN
REMOVING THE FELONIES AND- WELL
I SUPPOSE ONE POSSIBLE BENEFIT
OF. LEAVING THE SUNSET IS THAT
THIS DOES NOT DETER DEFENDERS
THREE YEARS IT SHOWS THAT THE
MISDEMEANOR IS NOT ADEQUATE. TO
STOP REPEAT OFFENDERS THEN OF
COURSE THEN WE COULD ENTERTAIN.
THE LEVELLERS AGAIN BECAUSE
THAT WOULD BE AN INDICATION OF
THAT THE MISDEMEANORS WERE NOT
ADEQUATE TO DO SO. AND I
APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE THE
MOTIVATION OF THE BILL I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
TAKE THE AMENDMENTS BECAUSE THE
DIFFICULTY I THINK A LOT OF A
SPACES THAT. I FOR EXAMPLE HI
KERRY BILLS AT TIMES TO TRY TO
CORRECT WERE I THINK WE ARE
OVER- CHARGING AND I TRIED TO
BRING IT BACK TO MISDEMEANOR
BECAUSE IN MANY OF THE CASES AT
LEAST IN MY BILLS THOSE
SENTENCES CAN BEUP TO YEAR IN
COUNTY JAIL AND A YEAR AND
COUNTY JAIL IS QUITE
SIGNIFICANT FOR ANY OF US I
MEAN OUR LIVES ARE GREATLY
ALTERED IF WE ARE IN COUNTY
JAIL EVEN SIX MONTHS. WHEN WE
LOSE OUR JOBS MOST LIKELY WE
KNOW THERE'S MANY MANY FACTORS
AND THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE THAT
RECORD SO I FOR ONE AM NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THE ASSERTION
THAT A MISDEMEANOR MEANS
NOTHING HOWEVER IF WE FIND THAT
THIS IS NOT CREATE THE EFFECT
THAT WERE INTENDING AND WITH
THE HIGH FINES IN SECTION I
REALIZED THE ORGANIZED GROUPS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PAY THE
FINE SO AT LEAST- IF IT DOES
NOT CREATE THE EFFECT THAT WE
ARE TENDING BECAUSE I WANT
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GO TO A
CLINIC SAFELY. AND OF COURSE WE
CAN RE ENTERTAIN THE- HIGHER
PUNISHMENTS. SURE WINNER I
THANK YOU I THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I. E.
I AM WAS OPEN TO SUPPORTING
THIS AND YOU KNOW AND ANY OF
ITS FORMS BUT I APPRECIATE- THE
OTHER WORKING WITH THE CHAIR ON
ON THIS ON THIS- ISSUE I DO
ONCE I THINK HI I CANNOT BEGIN
TO COUNT THE NUMBER OF TIMES
THAT I'VE BEEN IN COMMUNITY
MEETINGS IN SAN FRANCISCO AS A
SUPERVISOR AS SENDER RIGHT GOT
INTO PUBLIC ARGUMENTS WITH
POLICE OFFICERS WHO. TELL THE
PUBLIC- IT'S ONLY A MISDEMEANOR
NOW- IF SAID AROUND PROP FORTY
SEVEN TO MISDEMEANOR SO WE
CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT
WHICH IS. JUST PATENTLY FALSE
AND TO SIGNAL TO THE PUBLIC
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
MISDEMEANOR SOMEHOW DON'T EXIST
ONE AS CENTER SKINNER QUICKLY
MENTIONED YOU CAN DO A WHOLE
BUNCH OF TIME IN COUNTY JAIL-
THE PROBLEM IS THAT WE HAVE. AT
TIMES LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO WILL
NOT- TAKE ACTION ON
MISDEMEANORS AND AT TIMES ARE
SOME COUNTIES WHERE THE COURTS
TO AN ACTOR MAYBE THE DA. IT
DOESN'T ACT AND YOU KNOW MIGHT
BE A CRIMINAL JUSTICE AS WE
NEED TO HAVE CONSISTENT
ENFORCEMENT AND ACCOUNTABILITY-
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE. YOU KNOW.
SHOCKINGLY LONG SENTENCES YOU
CAN ACHIEVE. WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH YOU KNOW WITH SHORTER
SENTENCES. SO I- YOU KNOW I
ALSO JUST WANT TO SAY- IN OUR
EFFORTS ARE CAMANCHE JUSTICE
REFORM I DO THINK THAT THERE'S
A LITTLE BIT OF DISTINCTION
BETWEEN WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE
AND I THINK. THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN GENERAL THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMMITTING THESE
CRIMES AND THEY ARE CRIMES
FRANKLY AT TIMES. CAN BE IT CAN
BECOME VERY SOCIOPATHIC IN
TERMS OF TO ABSOLUTELY TRYING
TO TERRIFY INTIMIDATE AND
HARASS PEOPLE INTO NOT SEEKING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
ABSOLUTELY DESPICABLE PEOPLE
ARE. ENTITLED TO WHATEVER VIEWS
THEY WANT TO HAVE ONE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ON ON
ABORTION SERVICES IT'S HARD-
BUT THE IDEA THAT YOU WOULD
STALK AND HARASS AND INTIMIDATE
AND JUST TRY TO TERRIFY. PEOPLE
PRIMER IN WOMEN'S IN GENERAL
FROM SEEKING SERVICES IS
CHARGED WITH SOCIOPATHIC AND SO
THESE ARE NOT- THIS IS NOT
COMPARABLE TO. PEOPLE WERE
GETTING ARRESTED ON YOU KNOW
LOW LEVEL CRIME DRUG OFFENSES
AND HAVING THEIR LIVES
DESTROYED THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TARGETING AND- AND JUST
DEEPLY HARMING. OTHER HUMAN
BEINGS AND SO I DON'T I DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THEM FACING.
CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING CON TO
FREEDOM. BOB FOR DOING THAT THE
FINES ARE GOOD I SUPPORT THAT
BUT AS IT'S BEEN NOTED. THOSE
CAN BE PAID BY OTHER PEOPLE SO
I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AGAIN FOR
BRINGS FORTH. THANK YOU. FOR
THE PRESCRIPTIONS ARE PAID ON
THIS NOW. ALSO I DON'T THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH COMMITTEE AND-
EXCEPT- COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AHA WE UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
VERY. DIFFICULT ISSUE AND I
THINK WE ALL AGREE THAT WOMEN
ARE YOU KNOW ANYONE WHO IS
SEEKING MEDICAL CARE SHOULDN'T
BE HARASSED AND THREATENED I
JUST SIMPLY BY- SEEKING A-
MEDICAL SERVICE OR ANY TYPE OF
SERVICES SO TO COMMONSENSE
MEASURE BUT ALSO WE- WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WE MAKE SURE
THAT IT WORKS BECAUSE WE'VE
SEEN HISTORY HAS PROVEN THAT
YOU NO. LONGER SENTENCES DOES
NECESSARY TO DETER DETER CRIME
BUT AS A HARSH CALLING FROM
OAKLAND STATER BERKELEY- WE'VE
SEEN WHAT THIS PANDEMIC IS DOWN
TO OUR LIVES IN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS TO A YEAR SO. IT CAN
HAVE DEVASTATING EFFECTS IF
YOU'RE- UNEMPLOYED FOR A YEAR
IF YOU'RE IN JAIL FOR YEARS SO-
THAT'S NOT TO BE TAKEN LIGHTLY
SO. UNDERSTANDING THAT- WE'RE
SEEKING A MOTION ON IT. AB BUT-
I'M SORRY AT THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX.
IT'S MOVED BY SENATOR AND
SENATOR WIENER WE HAVE A DO. AS
AMENDED. NOT TO TAKE THAT A
COMMITMENT TO AMENDED WILL THE
COMMITMENT TO AMEND THE BILL
AND TO INSURE. SHUTTLE MISTER
MAN JUST CLOSE AND COMING I
WANTED YES I'M SURE YOU CAN
MAKE YOUR CLOTHES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I DO AND I WANT
TO THANK THEM ALL OF YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. AND ESPECIALLY
WITH SKINNER'S FOCUS ON. BIG
DATA WHICH I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I HEAR ALL OF
YOU AND I VOTE FOR MOST OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
MEASURES WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
REDUCE SENTENCES. BUT BUT
LOSING YOUR OF YOUR FREEDOM IS
SIGNIFICANT BUT NOT BEING
DENIED THIS HEALTHCARE. AND
HAVING TO CARRY A PREGNANCY TO
TERM BECAUSE YOU WERE DENIED
THE RIGHT TO ABORTION. IS
EQUALLY AS SIGNIFICANT FOR THE
WOMEN WHO SUFFER THAT AND SO WE
HAVE TO BALANCE THOSE THINGS
AND KEEP THAT IN MIND. AND I
THINK WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT THIS QUESTION OF.
WHETHER OUR SYSTEM TREATS
VICTIMS WHO ARE WOMEN OF COLOR
IN THE SAME WAY THAT TREATS
OTHER VICTIMS. BECAUSE I CAN
TELL YOU IN LOOKING AT THE LAWS
IN DOING THIS. THE ANSWER TO
THAT IS NO. RIGHT YOU LEAVING
THIS COMMITTE TODAY IT IS A
FELONY. TO VICTIMIZE THE DOG
AND IT WILL NOT BE A FELONY TO
VICTIMIZE THESE WOMEN SO. WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY URGE
ASPIRIN I BOTH. THANK YOU-
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN- WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE- AUTHOR WILL TAKE THE
MEASUREMENTS AND JUDICIARY.
AND- HE SAID YEAH AS IT MOVED
TO JUDICIARY THANK YOU. AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIXTY PASSED TO
JUDICIARY BRADFORD ARM BRADFORD
AYE CHOI BOGUE NO TROUBLED
NEVER COME LONGER I HAVE COME
UNDER AYE SKINNER. WIENER
WIENER AYE THE MEASURE HAS
THREE VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON STOCK UP THE
GENDER BACK TO PAULINE THIRTEEN
AB.
NINE FIVE EIGHT. BACK YOU
MAY BEGIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
STILL MORNING GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I WISH I
WOULD HAVE ACTUALLY FOLLOWED-
RIGHT BEHIND SENATOR COM LAGER
BECAUSE HER COMMENTS- WAS VERY
TOUCHING AND VERY MOVING AND
APPRECIATE HER COMMENTS I THINK
THIS FALLS DIRECTLY IN LINE
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIVE
EIGHT WHICH SEEKS TO BAN POLICE
GANGS IN EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FIRST AND FOREMOST I
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN. OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND HIS STAFF
WORKING WITH MY TEAM AND MYSELF
IN STRENGTHENING THIS BILL AND
ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY IN THE ASSEMBLY SIDE-
FOR HIS DILIGENCE AND HIS
FORTITUDE IN THIS- IN THIS
REGARD- WE WORKING WITH- WITH
ON AN ON AMENDMENTS TO SATISFY
ALL THE CONCERNS OF OPPOSITION
WHO I HOPE WILL JOIN IN
SUPPORTING THIS BILL EIGHT
FIFTY NINE. I AM COMMITTED TO
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS- WHICH
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS PROPOSED
IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS BILL
STRONGER TO TRULY GET AT THE
ROOT OF THIS ISSUE. AMONG THE
OTHER POLICE REFORM BILLS.
EXCUSE ME THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT- PIECE TO THIS PUZZLE
IN ORDER TO CHANGE THE
DANGEROUS CULTURE- THAT
PRESENTS ITSELF AND HAS
PRESENTED ITSELF FOR DECADES-
NOT ONLY IN THIS STATE BUT
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY. LOYOLA
MARYMOUNT REPORTS FOUND NEARLY
FIFTY YEARS OF ACTIVITY AMONG
EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT POLICE GANGS
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY MANY OF
THEM HAVE TATTOOS. HAND SIGNALS
RITUALS THAT ARE SIMILAR TO
STREET GANGS. THIS BILL WILL
CALL OUT THE- THE- THE SECRECY
OF THE OR THE SECRET- NATURE OF
POLICE GANGS AND IT WILL BE BAD
IN THIS STATE. AB NINE THREE
NINE FIVE EIGHT WILL ALSO MAKE
UP OFFICERS PARTICIPATION IN
POLICE GANGS GROUNDS FOR
TERMINATION. HOW CAN WE EXPECT
AN OFFICER TO A POLE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY OF HIS OR HER COMMUNITY
WHEN THAT OFFICER IS PRESSURED
WITH IN THEIR OWN DEPARTMENT TO
JOIN A POLICE GANG LET ME PAUSE
HERE. IN MY OWN DISTRICT THE
SIXTY FOR THE FAMILY DISTRICT
COMPTON SHARE THERE IS ONE
DEBUSSCHERE WHO- WAS BULLIED
FOR FIVE YEARS PLACED IN
DANGEROUS POSITIONS BECAUSE
THIS INDIVIDUAL REFUSE TO BE
PART OF THE GANG CULTURE THAT
EXISTS IN THAT DEPARTMENT- AND
HE BECAME A WHISTLE BLOWER AND
SHOVEL. AND DEMONSTRATE WHAT
WAS GOING ON THIS TOURNAMENT
HAS RECEIVED BULLYING AND
THREATS AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE. AND SO THIS GIVE RISE
TO ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIVE
EIGHT AND IF. IF INDIVIDUALS
REFUSED TO JOIN THEY ARE
OSTRACIZED. BLACK SUPPORT EVEN
FACE RETALIATION THESE ARE
GROUPS THAT CELEBRATE.
EXCESSIVE FORCE DISCRIMINATION
RETALIATION AGAINST OTHER
OFFICERS. WHO RESIST PLEASE
REFORM IS TAKING PLACE AB FIVE
NINE. EIGHT FOUR NINE FIVE
EIGHT WILL PUT FORTH REFORM
THAT HAS- HAS BEEN NEEDED FOR
DECADES TO READ THIS PERVASIVE
CULTURE OF THOSE WHO ABUSE THE
POWER. WHICH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS GIVEN TO THESE
OFFICERS THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
IS TO SERVE AND PROTECT I STAND
HERE TODAY BEFORE YOU WITHOUT A
CO SPONSOR. ISN'T IT BECAUSE NO
MATTER WHAT I WILL NOT STOP
UNTIL POLICE OFFICER GANGS ARE
NO LONGER IN THIS STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY ARI WHO WE
HAVE AND YOUR LEAD WITNESS
BRANDON OUT BY MY CORRECT. NO
NO OKAY. YES I'M HERE ALL WHAT
MARKET ARE YOU CAN SUPPORT IT.
WELL I LIKE YOU A READ MY
STATEMENT THAT THE OKAY SHARE I
WANT I'M GONNA GO WITH
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT RIGHT NOW
AND ARE YOU YOUR WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. AT THE BILL THIS YEAR
FOR YOU. WE ARE THE PROUD CO
SPONSOR THIS MUCH NEEDED BILL.
AT THE AUTHOR MENTIONED THE
BILL WILL BE AMENDED MOST
MEDICAL NEEDS FURTHER ANALYSIS
ON OUR PART. HOWEVER WE ARE
HOPEFUL THESE AMENDMENTS WILL
NOT WEAKEN THE INTENT OF THE
BILL AND ALLOW US TO CONTINUE
RESPONSIBLE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW GO
TO WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM
IS ANYONE HERE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
FIVE EIGHT. SEEN ONE HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE WILL GO TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM OF TWENTY.
FORTY THERE'S NO ONE THERE AS
WELL MODERATOR CAN WE NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES AND SEE IF
THERE ARE CALLERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB. NINE
FIVE EIGHT. AND TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE FIVE EIGHT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MR HERE WE HAVE NO IN
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE NOW WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION- MMHM WE HAVE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS A MAX HUNTSMAN.
HUNTSMAN WHO'S HERE TO TESTIFY-
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE MR
HUNTSMAN ONLINE. YES YOU DO YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES MY NAME. MY
NAME IS MAX FUND SPENT ON THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I PERSONALLY THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON FOR HIS-
SUPPORT. BARTENDERS COUNTY
OPPOSES UNLESS AMENDED ALTHOUGH
I BELIEVE AS YOU DESCRIBED
THAT'S THE PLAN SHE COULD SEE
AN INTIMIDATION ARE WHAT MAKE A
GROUP OF ARMED MEN HEY GANG.
THREE DECADES AGO A FEDERAL
JUDGE FOUND THE LARGEST LOS
ANGELES DEPUTY GANG TO BE A
WHITE SUPREMACIST ORGANIZATION
RATHER THAN PROHIBIT THE GANGS
L. AST HAS EMBRACED THEM AND AS
A AS OF A DECADE AGO A MEMBER
OF THAT GROUP THE VIKINGS. HAD
RISEN TO THE UNDER SHARE THEM
PARTICULARS PROTECTING L. AST
SECRECY BY SENDING A HAND
PICKED TEAM TO INTIMIDATE YEAH
YEAH IT ENDED BADLY FOR THE
PRESENT BADLY BUT STILL HE HAS
CALLED FOUGHT AGAINST
PROHIBITING THE GANGS. WHEN
SURE OF ME IN A WAY THAT TOOK
OFFICE L. AST BEGAN OPENLY
ADOPTING SECRECY SECRECY. AND
INTIMIDATION. OCTOBER DEPART
POLICY. ONE OF THE NEW FIRST.
WAS TO UNLOCK WE A POLITICAL I.
THAT USED DEPUTY GET MEMBERS.
TO INTIMIDATE ANOTHER DEPUTY
AND BEEN FIRED. WHEN I PUBLICLY
RECORDED BUT THE SHERIFF WAS
DOING. GREAT NEED TO KEEP THE
RECORDS SECRET ANY PLACE ME ON
THE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION ARE
INVESTIGATING IT. IN THE TWO
YEARS SINCE L. AST HAS DOUBLED
DOWN ON THESE TACTICS FORMING A
POLITICAL DIRTY TRICKS WHILE.
RESTING JOURNALISTS AND
THREATENING CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION AGAINST THOSE WHO
SPEAK OUT IN OPPOSITION. THE
CONDUCT HAS ONLY WORSENED SINCE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL ANNOUNCED
A CIVIL. RIGHTS INVESTIGATION
INTO THE DEPARTMENT. NEWMAN
CORPORATE. INCLUDING REASON
ONCE AGAIN FAILURE TO POP
DISCLOSE DEPUTY MISCONDUCT
SECRECY. AND THE USE OF
POTENTIALLY LETHAL FORCE
AGAINST PEACEFUL PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS INTIMIDATION. OUR
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT CONTINUES
TO PROTECT THE GANGS WITH A
CODE OF SILENCE. MOST NOTABLY A
GANG STYLE BEATDOWN OF
DISRESPECTFUL DEPUTIES BY A
GROUP CALLING ITSELF THE
BANDIDOS WAS CRIMINALLY
INVESTIGATED WITH TWO THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES PERMITTED TO REFUSE
TO GIVE STATEMENTS AGAINST
THEIR FELLOW DEPUTIES IN
VIOLATION OF DEPARTMENT POLICY.
NOT SURPRISINGLY THE COVERUP
RESULTED IN NO CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS. LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. ASKED EIGHTY NINE FIVE
EIGHT BE AMENDED TO ADDRESS THE
RACISM OF THESE GANGS. BANDIDOS
AND EXECUTIONERS EXCLUDE
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND FEMALE
MEMBERS AND THE LATTER SPORS.
IN ROCKY HELD ON EXTENT TO. ALL
COULD PROHIBIT MEMBERSHIP JUST
TO BE DOES NOT NEVER IN OUR
QAEDA THE CAKE. AND TO PROVIDE
FOR EXT INVESTIGATION. WITHOUT
THESE AMENDMENTS THE BILL WILL
BE USED AS COVER FOR CONTINUED
INACTION. THE LOS ANGELES
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HAS NOT
USED INSTEAD BEGAN POLICY TO
FIRE A SINGLE GANG MEMBERS.
BECAUSE IT CONTAINS THE SAME
LOOPHOLES THAT THE ORIGINAL
VERSION OF THE BILL THAT IS
USED TO ENFORCE THE CODE OF
SILENCE THAT HAS ALLOWED LET'S
HANG MEMBERS INTO POSITIONS OF
LEADERSHIP AGAIN. SECRECY AND
INTIMIDATION HISTORY DOESN'T
REPEAT ITSELF BUT IT RHYMES.
THANK YOU TECHNICALLY MY TEST
MORE. THANK YOU. NOW WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE HEARING ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE FIVE
EIGHT. JEAN NINE AND NOW WILL
MOVE TO TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO
ONE THERE AS WELL MODERATOR NOW
LET'S GO TO PHONE LINES INTO
YOUR- CALLERS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TELEPHONICALLY
ARGUED. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
NINE FIVE EIGHT. THAT TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINE FIVE
EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP. THANK YOU
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE NOW FOR THE
DISCUSSION CENTER ONE. THE BILL
HAS BEEN MODE IN ADDITION
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE HERE. HI I
JUST WANT TO. FOLLOW THE
COMMENTS THAT- SENATOR PALMER
STATED A FEW MONTHS AGO IN
REGARDS TO HER BILL- AB THREE
THREE THREE- THE COMMONSENSE
APPROACH OF. GETTING
ENHANCEMENTS THAT CHANGE
INDIVIDUALS LIVES WHEN YOU'RE
BLACK AND BROWN BUT ALMOST A
HYPOCRISY OF THE DIFFERENCE
THAT HAS BEEN AFFORDED LAW
ENFORCEMENT. OVER THE LAST
FIFTY SIXTY YEARS WILL IT'S NO
DOUBT GANGS EXIST AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT- IT IT THERE ARE
GANG MEMBERS WHO HAVE JOINED
POLICE DEPARTMENTS SIMPLY TO
CONTINUE THEIR GANG ACTIVITY
THERE'S NO. SECRET THERE
ANDERSON AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP HE SAID- IT'S
SIMILAR BUT THERE'S NO
DIFFERENCE A POLICE GANG IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN A STREET GANG-
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
DIFFERENCE AND- I'VE IT
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE AND WORK
WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO PROBABLY.
SHOULD FOR THEIR TATTOOS. IT
THE VIKINGS THE UP DOUBLE
GLOBAL AS THEY CLEARLY SET TRIP
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER STREET
GANG. AND IT'S A DANGEROUS
ELEMENT AND THERE'S FBI REPORT
AND STUDY THAT CLEARLY STATES
THAT THE BIGGEST RECRUITMENT.
OF INDIVIDUALS PART OF AREA
NATION WHICH IS A GANG THE KKK
WHICH IS A GANG IS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SO IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HOLD THESE
INDIVIDUALS ACCOUNTABLE THAT AS
WE TALK ABOUT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM POLICE REFORM THAT WE
HAVE A FAIR. WAY OF A RADIC
HATING THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND
THAT TYPE OF BEHAVIOR. FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN ORDER FOR. THE
PUBLIC TO HAVE THE TRUST THAT
IS NEEDED IN ORDER FOR ONE
PERSON TO WORK EFFECTIVELY AND
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY SO- ON
THAT NOTE HI THANK YOU FOR THIS
MEASURE. AND I HOPE FOR TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE BUT I JUST
WANNA BE CLEAR ON. THE
AMENDMENTS AND THEY DO THE
FOLLOWING I IDENTIFY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT GANGS AS JUST THAT
GANGS NOT CLICKS. LOG THE OF
WHAT CONSTITUTES ONE FORSMAN
GANKS TO INCLUDE GROUPS THAT
ENGAGE AND HARASSMENT.
EXCLUSION AND DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST PEOPLE BASED ON THEIR
STATUS AND PROTECTED CLASS FILM
THAT COULD BE GENDER THAT COULD
BE REYES AGREE H. AND CLARIFY
THAT OFFICERS MAY BE
DISCIPLINED FOR PARTICIPATION
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT GANKS. AND
FOURTH REQUIRES LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO COOPERATE WITH
ATTORNEY GENERAL AN INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S INVESTIGATION RELATED
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT GANKS. THAT
THAT IS GOVERNOR STANDING YES
ON THAT NOTE ARE ASSUMING
GIPSON WHICH ELECTRICALS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THOSE ARE THE MOMENTS
THAT- WE'VE REACHED I'VE
WORKED- AND MY TEAM I WORK WITH
INSPECTOR GENERAL FROM THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES BUT I
WILL TAKE A STEPS INTO- THE
COMMENTS FROM THE EXPECTED
JOURNAL WHEN HE USED TO WORK
COVER UP FOR AN ACTIVITY- THIS
BILL I WOULDN'T SAY UPSET I WAS
GOING TO SAY SOMETHING ELSE
PROBABLY INAPPROPRIATE. BUT I
WANT YOU TO HEAR ME VERY
CLEARLY THIS BILL IS TO TRY TO
GET AT THE ROOT OF THE ISSUE-
THAT EXIST BASED ON WHAT HAS
TRANSPIRED IN MY CITY OF
COMPTON AND FOR THE DEPUTY
SHERIFF TO GO FIVE YEARS BEING
PLACED IN BEING INTIMIDATED
BECAUSE THAT'S INDIVIDUAL
REFUSED TO BE PART OF A GANG
AND IN THAT SAME GAME THAT
EXISTS IN A SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT A POLICE DEPARTMENT.
IT IS THE SAME GANG THAT NOW
YOU'RE CHARGED WITH TRYING TO
RATTA KATE ON THE STREETS.
YOU'RE NO DIFFERENT FROM ANYONE
ELSE. WHERE THE A CRIPPLED. IF
YOU WERE A BATCH. AND WE WANNA
RADIC HATE THAT SO TOO IS TO
IMPLY THAT THIS BILL IS TO
COVER UP IN ACTIVITY THIS IS.
ACTIVITY AT ITS BEST IN A VERY
PROACTIVE WAY. SO MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE. IF
YOU WERE SEEKING A MOTION TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WE HAVE A
MOTION VICE AND DINNER WINNER
HE HE MOVED IT THANK YOU AND SO
ON CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AB NINE FIVE EIGHT. BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE CHOI BOGUE.
TROUBLE GUY COMMAGER I COME
UNDER AYE SKINNER WIENER.
WIENER AYE THE MEASURE AS FOR
VOTE TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS CONGRADULATIONS
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO OUR
FINAL. ITEM AB. FIFTEEN FORTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM. ONCE
WE DO OUR LITTLE HOUSE KEEPING
YOU MAY BEGIN. WE HAVE A COUPLE
THE NAME MOTIONS WHILE THEY'RE
DOING THAT A FEW. YES CAN WE-
MAKE THE MOST EIGHT I'M SORRY
AB FORTY EIGHT SENATOR GONZALEZ
AB FORTY EIGHT CAN WE CAN
MOTION ONLY BE FORTY EIGHTS
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
WINNER. CANCEL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON A BEFORE YOU. BRADFORD
ARE BRADFORD I'D CHOI BOGUE.
ONE MOMENT THE FIRST BILL ON
THE AGENDA. NO THE TROUBLE NO
COMMAGER COME UNDER AYE SKINNER
WIENER WIENER AYE. WILL MOVE
THEM. BUT CERTAIN MEASURE ON
CALL. NO NO NOT YET- EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE JONES SAWYER.
IN MOBRIDGE A SENATOR CALM
WATER. I HAVE A PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS YES AB FORTY
THREE BRADFORD PARK ROAD FOR
DIETRO BOTH I HAVE A GUY COME
LONGER HI MARGARET I SKINNER.
WIENER WIENER HI PLEASE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AND I
THINK THAT'S IT JERRY.
SEVENTEEN WE HAVE YOU FOR
FIFTEEN FORTY AB FIFTEEN PORT
EFFECT AFFECTING CHAIR- I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN
FORTY FOR DECADES WE'VE HAD
RECENT THING LAWS ON THE BOOKS
YET ALMOST NONE OF THEM WERE
BEING UTILIZED I PROBABLY CARRY
THE BILL IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
ALLOW DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO
WORK WITH- JUDGES TO TAKE A
SECOND LOOK AT THE SENTENCING
AND THE SENTENCES. THAT THEY
ARE PROPOSED WHEN THEY ARE
PROSECUTED CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS
HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE BILL
ACTUALLY BEING USED BUT WITH
THIS BILL DOES IS TAKE THAT-
TAKE THESE CASES ALL WHERE MANY
COURTS HAVE KNOCKED ON THE
GRANTED ACTUALLY HAS TO HAVE
DENIED THE IMPACTED PERSONS
WITHOUT INFORMING THEM ABOUT
WHAT THE SITUATION WAS. THIS
BILL STREAMLINES THAT PROCESS
THE REALLY CLARIFIES AND PUTS
THE POWER BACK IN THE JUDGE'S
HAND TO BE ABLE TO REDUCE THE
CHARGE BUT ALSO ASK THAT THE-
COME FORWARD WITH THE REASONS
AS TO WHY. WHY THE- INDIVIDUAL
WASN'T ALLOWED TO BE
RESENTENCED ON THIS BILLS ARE
JUST BUILT UPON THE LEGISLATION
THAT WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST AND
AGAIN CONTINUES TO ALLOW THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN CHARGE
OF OUR COMMERCIAL SUCCESS IN TO
TAKE A SECOND LOOK ON SOME OF
THEIR ACTIONS WITH THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE.
INCARCERATED THIS COMES AT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE COMMITTEE
ON THE REVISION OF PENAL CODES-
WE THINK IT'S A GOOD
RECOMMENDATION THERE AND WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD TO CLARIFY EXISTING LAW
WITH THE B. FIFTEEN FORTY WITH
THAT WE HAVE TO WITNESSES-
VALERIE BOLDEN WHOSE
INDIVIDUALS BEEN IMPACTED AS
WELL AS OUR SO WE'LL HER TADO
THE MANAGING ATTORNEY OF THE
POST CONVICTION UNIT OF. THE
SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. WITNESSES
SUPPORT YOU HAVE OF THREE
MINUTES TOTAL- WAS PULLED AND
IF YOU'RE- TO COMPLAIN TO SOME.
IF I AND GOOD AFTERNOON. ROBERT
MY NAME IS VALERIE BOLDEN-
FIFTY NINE YEARS OLD AND AS A
DIRECT RESULT OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE I WAS INCARCERATED FOR
TWENTY FOUR YEARS AFTER
RECEIVING A SPENT A FIFTY FIFTY
FIFTY SIX YEARS TO LIFE FOR
SECOND DEGREE MURDER. THE FACT
THAT I THINKING WAS BASED ON A
GREAT TIME LAW WOULD MANDATE A
AN EXTREME PENSION BECAUSE THE
TIME I HAD ALREADY FOR DECADES
AGO. WHILE IN PRISON. AB HELPED
GROUPS AND CLASSES FOR YEARS
INCLUDING THE RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE GROUP BRIDGES HI WHAT
WAS THE BEST GROUP OF ME IN
TERMS OF DEVELOPING SELF
AWARENESS. I GOT MY HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA AND ASSOCIATE DEGREE
AND ALSO IN BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES.
I WORK ON ME WITHOUT KNOWING
THAT THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET THE
SENTENCE WHATEVER COM. WHEN YOU
HAVE THAT MUCH TIME TO DO IT
HARD TO HAVE ANY HOPE. MOST OF
THE TIME I FELT LIKE I WAS THE
BEST THING BASICALLY WALKING
AROUND LIKE A LOW BACK ON THE
PANEL PAINTINGS EVERY DAY. I AM
NOT CHILDREN ARE WHAT GOT ME
THROUGH ONE DAY AFTER ANOTHER.
IF I DIDN'T GET THE CHANCE TO
COMPOUND THEIR RESPECTIVE BAND
I WOULD HAVE EITHER DIED IN
PRISON OR MAYBE HAVE A CHANCE
TO WORK OUT IN MY NINETY. AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PRISON
STAFF RECOMMENDED ME FOR
RESPECT AND PAYING BILLS OF
EXCEPTIONAL BEHAVIOR BUT FOR ME
INCLUDED PROGRAMMING AND
REMAINING DISK. DISCIPLINARY
FREE FOR OVER A DECADE. THREE
FIVE BIG BAND WE STOP FOR ME
BECAUSE THEY WERE ATTACKING
PEOPLE RECOMMENDING PROBABLY
SPENT. BY THE R. EIGHTY THREE
R. I'M SORRY. I HAVE BEEN
REACHING OUT TO THEM FOR YEARS
ABOUT MY THREE FIVE EIGHT. AND
THEY WROTE AFTER BAKER
REPRESENT ME. OF COURSE I SAID
YES AND AFTER A WHILE I HAD A
RESENTENCING HEARINGS AND COURT
IN LOS ANGELES. THE JUDGE
RETENTION RATE OF FIFTEEN YEAR
FIVE AND ABOUT FIFTEEN NOT SIX
MONTHS LATER. I HAVE MY BIRTH
HELLO HEARING IN THE GRANITE
HELLO. MY RELEASE ON BEEN
WORKING ON GETTING CERTIFIED TO
BE A DOMESTIC BONTA ADVOCATE
AND TRYING TO GET TO KNOW MY
CHILDREN AS WOMEN NOW HOME I
LEFT AT EIGHT NINE TEN AND
FOURTEEN YEARS OLD. I WOULDN'T
HAVE HAD THE CHANCE TO GET
RESENTMENT IF I DIDN'T HAVE
REPRESENTATION. I KNOW PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALSO RECOMMENDED BY CDC
ARE BUT WHEN THEY CASES GOING
TO COURT. AND HAVE A CHANCE TO
GO TO COURT AND WERE DENIED
WITHOUT EVEN BEING CONSIDERED.
DEAD IF EITHER DISMISS THEM
BECAUSE THEY WANT THE MAYOR
WITH THE ELEVENTH SEVEN
REPENTANCE AND LAW ARE THEY
DIDN'T FIND IT TO BE OF ANY
IMPORTANT. ASKING YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN FORTY TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE HAVE A FAIR
CHANCE. EVERY SENTENCE BAND AND
COULD END UP HAVING A RIGHT TO
AN ATTORNEY AND HEARING. I LEFT
MANY PEOPLE SITTING IN PRISON
WHERE WORK HARD ON THEMSELVES.
AND ARE BETTER PEOPLE NOW THEY
DESERVE A CHANCE TO COME HOME
TO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. NOW
MISS HER TITLE. THANK YOU CHAIR
BRADFORD AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION.
AND THANK YOU VALERIE FOR
SHARING YOUR PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE- THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM FOR YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AND FOR PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY. HI
MY NAME IS MARCEL THE OLD
BATTLE AND THAT THE FAMILY
MEMBER TEAM MENTIONED ONE OF MY
RESPONSIBILITIES. IS MANAGING.
THE POST CONVICTION UNIT OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. MY UNIT HAS
WE SENTENCE FORTY FIVE PEOPLE
UNDER THE NEW RESENTENCING
PROVISIONS IN CALIFORNIA LAW
EACH PERSON WAS EPENTANCE WITH
A STRONG REENTRY PLAN. THANK
YOU TO THE CORPORATE CRITICAL
SUPERIOR COURT DEFENSE COUNSEL
AND COMMUNITY BASED PARTNERS
THAT HAVE MADE THAT POSSIBLE.
THE STORY ENDED THERE WE
WOULDN'T BE HERE TODAY WHILE AT
THE CRAFT WILL START THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
RESENTENCING LAW HAS REVEALED
SEVERAL PROCEDURAL CHALLENGES
THAT MUST BE REMEDY. ESTAMOS
PRACTICE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN THE STATE ON THIS
MATTER WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
CHANGES AB FIFTEEN FORTY. WE
ARE NOT ALONE IF YOU SEE A
BROAD COALITION OF REGISTERED
SUPPORTERS. IN ADDITION A
STATED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM
THE PROPOSED CHANGE IN LAW
COMES FROM RECOMMENDATIONS MADE
BY THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE. AB
FIFTEEN FORTY WILL RESULT IN
MORE CONSISTENT AND EQUITABLE
IMPLEMENTATION OF RECALL EVERY
SENSE OF THE ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
SPECIFICALLY AB FIFTEEN FORTY
WILL EXPAND THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
RECOMMEND THE PERSON FOR
RESENTENCING TO THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL. IF THEY
PROSECUTED THE CASE. YOU CAN
PROCEED DUE. BY PROVIDING
NOTICE BEING PART PERSONS
RECORD FOR SENTENCED.
ESTABLISHING COURT DEADLINE AND
ENSURING A CLEAR RIGHT TO A
HEARING. VERIFY THAT A JUDGE
CAN REDUCE THE CHARGE TO A
LESSER INCLUDED- LESTER RELATED
OFFENSE. THE CHOICE OF THE
APPROPRIATE TERM REMAINS WITH
THE COURT. PROVIDE A
PRESUMPTION IN FAVOUR OF
RESENTENCING WHEN LONG COURSE
AND MAKE THE REFERRAL. ENSURE
THE RIGHT TO COUNSEL AND MAKE
PENAL CODE SECTION ELEVEN
SEVENTY D. ONE ITS OWN PENAL
CODE SECTION TO CLARIFY THE
LAW. THIS BILL IS PRACTICAL
TIMELY AND NECESSARY. I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NOW WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM- FORTY
TWO OR THREE OR THEIR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SEEN NINE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S NO ONE
THERE AS WELL MODERATOR WOULD
NOW GO TO PHONE LINES. AND IF
THERE ARE WITNESSES WHO WANTED
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
FIFTEEN FORTY NOW IS THE TIME.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY ONE. HELLO
THIS IS LESLIE CALDWELL HOUSTON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE UP. LOCATION
SORRY- IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WHAT DOES. LINE SIXTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
DEREK MEANING LEADING IN
READING A LIST OF ORGANIZATIONS
IN SUPPORT ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
BEND THE ARC JEWISH ACTION
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
CALIFORNIANS BIRTHDATE THE
INJECTED CURB EIGHT MILLION
POWER NOW DREAM COURT JUSTICE
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS FOR THE
PEOPLE INITIATE DRASTIC JESSE'S
PLACE ADVOCATE GROUP LEGAL.
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN. BOTH POTTERY. RESTORE
DRASTIC AND COMMA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE
ONE SIXTY TWO. UNDERWATER WIH
THE CALIFORNIA TRAFFIC OFFER TO
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE SIXTY SIX.
YOUR MIND BURGER ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE BLIND
ONE FIFTY. OUR MAIN LINE ONE
FIFTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANTHONY
SAMPSON WITH SAMPSON ADVISORS
ON BEHALF OF FAN SUPPORT. BLIND.
EIGHTY EIGHT. BY EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HELLO. YOUR UTILIZED IS
OPEN. I DON'T. WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE SIXTY EIGHT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STAND PULLS OUT ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. WILL MOVE TO ALL
POSITION AND WILL FOR THEM THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY THERE'S ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS YOU'LL- FORTY
THREE MINUTES TOTAL SINCE
YOU'RE THE ONLY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
THE FOR MARCH. MR MORE SECURITY.
YES SIR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LARRY MORSE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION- WHILE WE
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TIM WORKING- TEAM
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
AND CONSIDERING OUR PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS CDA STILL HAS
CONCERNS ABOUT TWO PARTICULAR
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL OUR
GREATEST CONCERN DEALS WITH THE
PRESUMPTION CONTAINED OF THE
BILL IN FAVOR OF RESENTENCING
IT STATES QUOTE THERE SHALL BE
A PRESUMPTION. FAVORING RECALL
AND RE SENTENCING OF THE
DEFENDANT WHICH MAY ONLY BE
OVERCOME IF A COURT FINDS THE
DEFENDANT IS AN UNREASONABLE
RISK OF DANGER TO PUBLIC SAFETY
AS DEFINED IN SUBDIVISION CITY
OF SECTION ELEVEN SEVENTY POINT
EIGHTEEN THAT IS THE DEFINITION
OF A SO CALLED SUPER STRIKE A
VERY NARROW SET OF VIOLENT
FELONIES INCLUDING MURDER
SEXUALLY VIOLENT OFFENSES CHILD
MOLESTATION ASSAULT WITH THE
MACHINE GUN ON A PEACE OFFICER
OR FIREFIGHTER. AND POSSESSION
OF A WEAPON OF MASS DESTRUCTION
THIS PRESUMPTION WILL
ESSENTIALLY REQUIRE THE
PROSECUTION TO BE NOSTRA
DOMINANCE AND PROVED TO A COURT
THAT THE DEFENDANT IS AN
UNREASONABLE RISK TO COMMIT ONE
OF THESE SUPER STRIKES IN THE
FUTURE. AND THE PRESUMPTION
ARBITRARY FAVORING RESENTENCING
WITHOUT REGARD TO THE NATURE OF
THE CASE INJURY TO THE VICTIM
IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITY FOR THE
PARTICULARS OF THE OFFENDER BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
PRESUMPTION IS SIMPLY NOT
NEEDED THE LAW ALREADY PROVIDES
THAT THE COURT QUOTE SHALL
APPLY THE SENTENCING RULES OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND APPLY
ANY CHANGES IN LAW THAT REDUCED
SENTENCES WILL PROVIDE FOR
JUDICIAL DISCRETION SO AS TO
ELIMINATE THE SEVERITY OF
SENTENCES. AND TO PROMOTE
UNIFORMITY OF SENSORS AND QUOTE
THE BILL ALLOWS FOR A REDUCTION
IN THE DEFENDANT'S. TERM
APPROVED IT IMPRISONMENT AND
EVEN THE ANSWERS OF. INCLUDE IN
LESS RELATE OFFENSE. AND THE
JUDGE MAY CONSIDER A WHOLE HOST
OF CRITERIA INCLUDING POST
CONVICTION FACTORS THE BILL
ALSO MANDATES THE HEARING WHERE
ALL PARTIES HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HEARD. JUDGES SHOULD BE
ABLE TO USE THEIR CELL
DISCRETION AN EXISTING RULES TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS IN THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE TOTALITY. JERRY
PRESUMPTION THAT TILTS THE
SCALES OF JUSTICE IF ANYTHING
THERE SHOULD BE A PRESUMPTION
IN FAVOUR OF THE ORIGINAL SAYS
WHICH IS A VALID AND FINAL
JUDGMENT WOEFULLY IMPOSED UNDER
LAW AND MANY TIMES AFFIRMED ON
APPEAL. OUR OTHER CONCERN DEALS
WITH RECENT AMENDMENT TO THE
BILL THAT EXPANDS RESENTENCING
TWO OUT OF CUSTODY DEFENDANTS.
WHAT IS THE POINT OF
RESENTENCING A DEFENDANT WHO IS
NOT CURRENTLY INCARCERATED.
THIS COULD OVERWHELM COURTS
WOULD MOVE RESENTENCING
HEARINGS AND BECAUSE ADDED AN
UNNECESSARY WORKLOAD PRESSURES
ON LOCAL PROSECUTORS AGAIN WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING'S
CONSIDERATION OF ALL PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. BUT WE MUST REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL GIVEN OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE THANK. THANK YOU NOW
WILL COME BACK TO THE HEARING
ROOM IS THERE ANYONE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
MAJOR I SEE NO ONE THERE WILL
MOVE DOWN TO TWENTY FORTY.
THERE'S NO ONE IN THAT ROOM
EITHER SO MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES AND SEE IF
THERE IS A WITNESSES. WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN FORTY. THANK YOU TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE EIGHTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EIGHTY EIGHT. HELLO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
WE'RE LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION
ARE YOU IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
MEASURE FIFTEEN FORTY. HELLO.
HELLO THE ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR WE NEED YOUR TESTIMONY.
OKAY YES I WAS ACTUALLY QUEUED
UP FOR THE COURT- MY NAME IS.
AND DID EVERYTHING MY NUMBER
SO- BUT I'M GLAD I'M HERE NOW I
WOULD LIKE TO READ OFF A LIST
OF THE BORDER- IT IS PREPARED
ADVOCACY NETWORK. I REBOUND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO OFFICE
FIGURE JUSTICE TRYING NOT FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE NORTH COUNTY SAN
DIEGO. WELCOME VALLEY DEBUG.
YES CALIFORNIA AND A PROSECUTOR
SLAMMED THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES CONNECTION
PROJECT STARTING OVER IN. EXACT
STORY PROGRAM SURVIVED AND
PUNISHED D. G. I. JUSTICE
PROJECT. HEY WORK HEY WHAT
BRINGS EDUCATED WHITE PEOPLE
FOR BLACK LIVES YOUNG WOMAN
STREET IN CENTER- AND MY NAME
IS A CLEAR WITHOUT COMBAT
LADYBUG. IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. AT THIS WE HAVE LONG
LINES INTO MISTER SHERMAN GREAT
THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE OR IS THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AS
REAL IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
WIENER. ANY TO SACRAMENTS ALL
RIGHT SOONER TO COMMIT
SIMPLEMENTE NO ONE MAKER BY
SENATORS THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU WALL- MISTER
MORRIS IS NOT IS CORRECT- I
WASN'T ABLE TO CONSULT WITH
NOSTRADAMUS WE DO CONSULT.
MAYBE ON THE REVISION OF PENAL
CODES. AND THIS WAS THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THIS IS
ACTUALLY NOT ARBITRATE THIS IS
A COMMISSION. THAT WAS ASKED TO
REVIEW THE PENAL CODES INCLUDED
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS. THEY
TOOK THE STARTER TOOK THEIR
PURPOSE VERY SERIOUSLY- THE
BILL IS AMENDED. DEMANDS THE
RESENTENCING PROVISIONS WITH
THEIR SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION
ON THE COURTS- ED BOARD OF WHAT
THE COURTS PRESUMPTION HEROES
AND WHAT THEY CAN DO SO WE
THINK THIS IS A VERY GOOD.
RECOMMENDATION I THINK I JUST
UNDERSTOOD UNDERSCORE WHY THIS
IS AN ISSUE CDC ARE
RECOMMENDED- EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
CASES TO BE REVIEWED THE COURTS
ONLY TOOK UP TWELVE HUNDRED. OF
THOSE TOLD HUNDRED THE ONLY
HEARD SIX HUNDRED CASES SO
AGAIN. THAT MEANT THAT OVER.
TWELVE HUNDRED PEOPLE ALL
WAITING WHO RECOMMEND
RECOMMENDED BY CDC ARE WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO HAVE THEIR CASES
EVEN HURDLE FOR REVIEW. AND
WE'RE NOT EVEN TOLD MARK SO
AGAIN THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE
REAL FAMILIES WHO ARE THEIR OWN
FACILITIES HAVE DETERMINED THAT
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
RESENTENCING. REALLY I WE FEEL
THAT THEY DESERVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY WE DO BELIEVE WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THEY DESERVE AN
ANSWER AND THIS PROCESS NEEDS
TO BE. STREAMLINED SO THEY CAN
AT LEAST GET THEIR DAY IN
COURT. WHAT THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE ON THE B.
FIFTEEN FORTY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COUNCIL PLEASE
CALL THE. ROLL ON A. B. FIFTEEN
FORTY. AND BRADFORD ARE
BRADFORD. VOGUE TROUBLE NO
KAMLAGER HI COMMA GARAGE
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE. WIENER
WIENER AYE FOR ONE FOR THE ONE
THAT MEASURES OUT
CONGRADULATIONS SHIFTING.
ASSIMILATING AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK AT THE ROOF ROLE
ON IT A. B. ONE TWO FOUR
COUNCIL AB ONE TWO FOUR- BUT
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TWO ZERO
BRADFORD ARE BRADFORD AYE VOTES
FOR ZERO. FOUR ZERO THAT
MEASURES OUT. THE REST YEAH YOU.
YEAH THERE ARE ALSO THEY'RE
GONNA START LIFTING OKAY SO.
RECONSTRUCTION. OKAY JUST STOP
AFTER IT FAMILIES TAKING
SURVEYS AND FIND GREAT THAT.
OKAY WELL WITH CALLS AB FORTY
EIGHT CURRENT VOTE IS THREE TO
ONE. SKINNER AB. FOR IT'S FORTY
ONE SO FACE. AB FORTY EIGHT
PASSES WITH A FOUR TO ONE OKAY.
CONSENT CALENDAR- SKINNER I
SKINNER FIVE FIVE TWO ZERO. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR PASSES WITH A
FIVE TWO ZERO. EIGHTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE JONES SAWYER-
SKINNER. SKINNER I FIVE TWO
ZERO SO THAT BUILD MOVIES
MUSSAR PASSES WITH A FIVE TWO
ZERO VOTE. AB TWO NINETY TWO
STONE THE CURRENT VOTE IS TWO
TO ONE SKINNER SKINNER I
WINNER. WINNER II FORTY ONE.
THE BILL PASSES WITH A FOUR TO
ONE VOTE. OKAY A. B. SEVEN
SEVENTEEN STONE- VOTERS FOR TWO
ZERO CHERUSCI SKINNER SKINNER
HI FIVE TWO ZERO TO THE BEST OF
THE FIVE TWO ZERO. AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX ARMBAR QUE HAN CHAIRS
I'D VOTE IS THREE TO ONE THERE
IS A COMMITMENT TO AMENDED
JUDICIARY- SKINNER. SKINNER I'D
VOTERS FOUR TO ONE. THE BILL
PASSES FORTY ONE. AB SIX SIX
NINE LACKEY- CHAIR IS NOT
VOTING THERE'S CURRENTLY THE
VOTE IS ONE TO ONE SKINNER. NOT
VOTING SLAVO REMAINS ONE TO ONE
LEVEL A RECONSIDERATION IS
GRANTED. ARM AB NINE FIFTY
EIGHT THE VOTE IS FOUR TWO ZERO
SKINNER. SKINNER I. THE BILL
PASSES. FIVE ZERO. YES AMENDED
THAT WAS AS AMENDED AB THREE
THREE FIFTY THREE- THE VOTE IS
THREE TO ONE WIENER. WIENER HI
THE BILL PASSES FOR BORDER ONE.
THAT SHOULD BE A THANK YOU. AND
I BELIEVE THAT CONCLUDES OUR
MEETING FOR TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US AND
MAKE IT A GREAT DAY.